hello everyone and welcome to simply
learns youtube channel today we'll be
taking you through the javascript and
typescript full course
this course is designed in such a way
that it will cover every important
aspect from the basics of both
javascript and typescript to advanced
level topics and some hands-on projects
we'll see how typescript is different
from javascript by the end of this
tutorial you guys will be able to
implement javascript and typescript in
different ways
so before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
technology videos so if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hunt for the latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribe to our youtube channel
and press that bell icon to never miss
any updates from simply learn so without
any further delay let's get started
let's go through the agenda for this
full course tutorial we'll start this
video with an introduction to javascript
and why one should learn javascript
following that we'll cover basic
javascript topics like areas loops and
functions in javascript along with some
advanced level topics like promises in
javascript
we have some specific projects waiting
for you guys we'll create some games to
understand javascript in a better way
upon completing javascript we'll move on
and cover typescript
we'll cover everything you need to know
and understand about typescript we'll
see what type script is will then cover
the difference between javascript and
typescript following that we'll cover
topics like typescript generics
and how typescript is used with react
and node.js
at the end of this full course we'll go
through typescript projects and some
commonly asked typescript interview
questions it will surely help you
understand typescript in a better way so
let's start this video with an
introduction to javascript
javascript was developed in the year
by a person named brendan ike
brendan was working for netscape
communications while he developed
javascript in 10 days
there were a few changes in the name of
javascript initially it was mocha which
was later changed to live script and
then it finally became javascript
the start of javascript wasn't that good
as so many developers who were using
java at that time
they considered javascript as a language
for designers and non-engineers
no one ever knew that this small side
scripting language would have a great
future today more than 90 percent of the
websites out there they are using
javascript somehow many of you guys gets
confused with java and javascript let me
clear it for you that both java and
javascript they are different languages
they have almost nothing in common many
people say that javascript was named
after java as a part of a marketing
strategy to gain wider acceptance and
recognition in 1995 java was a buzzword
when javascript was developed that's why
they renamed javascript after java let's
move on to what is javascript
have you guys ever been through a
website where you can see images that
slides automatically one such website is
amazon the home page of amazon where we
can see different types of ongoing sales
is an example of javascript
in layman language javascript is a
lightweight scripting language used to
make web pages more interactive and more
lively earlier when javascript was
developed it was only a side scripting
language to do basic tasks like you can
add pop-ups in your web page or you can
make your web page more interactive
nothing more than that but now the whole
scenario has changed
with the help of javascript we can
create applications as well
if we talk about applications let's take
an example let's suppose we want to
create an app we can create it in
android or in ios but we have to learn
few different languages to create those
apps for android we have to learn java
and xml and swift we have to learn for
ios but with the help of javascript you
can create hybrid applications which can
work on any platform without any problem
tech giants like google paypal amazon
and youtube they are using javascript
these days the evolution of javascript
in the past few years was unbelievable
suppose you want to create a single page
website every one of us is familiar with
gmail let's suppose
so gmail is a single page website which
looks more like a desktop software than
a website so gmail is based on
angular.js
it is a popular framework by google
which is free of cost and it is totally
based on javascript now let's go over
some of the features of javascript these
features are actually why it is
considered that using javascript is
advantageous over other languages
so let's start with some of these points
javascript is not a proper programming
language indeed it is a scripting
language
which works in the runtime environment
just like python
so there are few other languages like c
plus plus and java they need a compiler
to work but with javascript you don't
need a compiler once you are done with
the script
it will interpret and show you the
output in the browser directly
next up is lightweighted javascript can
provide programming facility to some
extent in javascript you don't need to
specify any data type or return type
which helps in making development more
quicker that's why it is known as light
weighted
javascript is both client-side as well
as server-side technology client-side
technology runs on the user's computer
whereas the server-side technology runs
on the web browser initially when
javascript was introduced it was
introduced as a client-side technology
but with the introduction of node.js in
2009 one can now work in the back end as
well
there is a way to validate the user's
data before sending it to the web server
and we can do that with the help of
javascript the data will be checked for
correct form and value
all we have to do is start a loop give
it the condition
to check the data javascript is also
platform independent although originally
designed to work on browsers only but
now it is a platform independent
language which means once you are done
with the script you can use it on any
browser or platform without any problem
javascript is an object based scripting
language although many programmers do
not consider javascript as a true object
oriented programming language due to its
lack of class concept
it does support other features of object
oriented programming like it supports
encapsulation it supports polymorphism
and also it supports prototypal
inheritance
the last but not the least feature of
javascript is case sensitive so when it
comes to keywords identifiers names and
functions javascript differentiates
between capital and lowercase letters we
have to keep this in mind while
programming
now i will quickly go over some of the
javascript applications where javascript
is currently being implemented
first one that comes to every person's
mind is web development it was also the
main motive behind developing javascript
we have technologies like angular we
have node.js we can create beautiful web
pages
also javascript can be used along with
html and css to make those static
looking web pages more engaging if we
talk about other applications of
javascript we can use it in app
development either mobile app or web app
like we took the example before that how
hybrid apps made with the help of
javascript
can take over traditional android and
ios app
one of the most important and unique
application of javascript is in
smartwatches the bengal.js is an open
sourced smartwatch powered by javascript
gordon williams the man who is currently
working on this project it is said that
this new open sourced stack built around
javascript will replace the onboard
firmware soon the next application of
javascript is client-side validation as
we discussed earlier javascript is used
to validate the user data whether the
user's input is correct or not by
cross-checking it with the given
condition like the user wants to enter
in your website and you want it to be a
user with at the right gmail.com in his
email id so you will give that condition
to javascript and it will cross check it
with the user's information like when
the user will try to enter in your
website it will check that if at the
rate gmail.com is there or not in the
user's email id
so it can validate the user also apart
from that one more application of
javascript is game development
javascript can be used to make fully
fleshed 2d or 3d games using different
libraries although most javascript game
development focuses on creating games
used in browsers only
till now we have an idea about what
javascript is
its features and its applications so if
you want to learn javascript you need to
do some basic things to make your
learning experience more smoother let's
take a look at the prerequisites to use
javascript the first one is the basic
knowledge of html and css to use
javascript along with html and css you
first need to know how html and css
works see html is used to create the
structure of a web page while css is
used to style that web page in order to
use these two with javascript you need
to have the basic knowledge of html and
css because if you want to learn a new
language first of all you need to know
why to use that technology and to learn
javascript more efficiently you need to
have the basic knowledge of html and css
it's better to have a web browser that
supports javascript like google chrome
or mozilla firefox or you can use safari
as well if you are using a macbook you
will need an operating system like
windows linux or mac operating system to
learn javascript a computer with minimum
512 mb of ram would be enough for you to
start learning javascript but i will
recommend you a computer with 1gb of ram
or 4gb of ram for a better experience
you can use any text editor you have
notepad which is free and is already
available for windows
if you don't want to use notepad you can
use other free softwares like sublime or
you can use visual code in this
particular course we will be using
visual code and i'll tell you how to
install visible code and what are the
features of visual code also suppose you
do not have any prior knowledge about
javascript don't worry about it
we will take you through the whole
course and we will ensure that you can
understand javascript
let's start this video with some facts
about javascript
javascript is the only programming
language that a browser can understand
25 years ago when developers were
thinking about a language that a browser
can understand
there were a few languages that were
present in the market at that time just
like java still there were some problems
with these languages that these
languages need a server to work with the
browser javascript on the other hand can
work directly with the browser you write
the code in the editor the browser will
go through it it will interpret it and
then runs the program
the popularity of javascript increased
with time
being a language which can do so many
tasks whether it be designing a
website's front end or going through any
websites back-end javascript can do
anything by the end of 2018 over 95 of
the internet was powered by javascript
means almost every website out there is
using javascript in some way or another
do you guys know about stack overflow a
website for every programmer don't worry
you will get to know about it once you
start with the programming part stack
overflow states that javascript is the
most popular programming language used
by the developers
let me quickly run you through the
reasons why one should learn javascript
and then we'll briefly elaborate each of
these reasons
javascript has the most powerful
frameworks
javascript is constantly growing and is
a well-paid job
javascript is beginner friendly and it
has the largest community
javascript provides wide range of usage
as well
let's move on further and see
why each of these reason is important
javascript has the most powerful
frameworks for every task a user wants
to do like for designing a single page
website like you want to
design a website like gmail you can use
angular.js if you want to design ui
components or user interfaces for single
page application you have react.js you
want to develop a mobile or a desktop
application let's suppose you have
view.js for that as well basically you
can do anything with powerful javascript
frameworks
next up is constant truth one of the
main reasons behind one should learn
javascript javascript is one of the
fastest growing languages and stands
among the top 10 languages used by the
developers with so much increase in
mobile market mobile web development has
seen an immense rise in need of
interactivity
which is possible only with the help of
javascript
that's why javascript is continuously
growing and there is no way that
javascript will go down shortly
the developers working in javascript are
well paid across the world anyone who
wants to be a web designer or a web
developer needs to learn javascript it
is a must have skill for being a good
web developer we will discuss it in
javascript jobs section
javascript is an easy to learn language
compared to many other programming
languages
like java python and php javascript
provides easy entry points to the world
of programming the best thing about
javascript is that it comes
pre-installed on almost every web
browser so you don't need to set up any
environment to start development in
javascript which means you can start
coding right away
javascript has the largest community
among all the programming languages out
there
community size does matter when it comes
to programming language because the
larger the community size is
the more help you would be likely to get
currently javascript has the biggest
stack overflow community it has
overtaken java in terms of community
size and is still growing at a rapid
pace wide range of usage in my opinion
one of the most important reasons why
one should learn javascript by knowing
javascript you can build an entire
website from its backend to the front
apart from that you can also build a
full flash mobile application for the
backend you don't need to learn other
programming languages node.js is enough
with a bit of knowledge about database
and apis there is nothing you can't do
with javascript when it comes to website
development
let's move on and discuss few jobs you
can take up after learning javascript
and will also discuss their average
salaries in usa and in india
so the first one is a full stack
developer a full stack developer is one
of the highest paid jobs in web
development sector a full stack
developer is equally proficient in
client side as well as server side
development a full stack developer earns
around 9 lakh per annum which is quite a
decent amount of money for a person
living in india but if you are a full
stack developer in u.s you can earn up
to 100 000 dollars per annum which is a
huge amount
a front-end developer is the one who
deals with the front end of any website
or application it's obvious that a
front-end developer will not earn as
much as a full stack developer
but the amount of money a front-end
developer earns in a year is decent a
javascript developer works on the
front-end and sometimes back-end also
a javascript developer may be
responsible for the whole website or
just a few aspects or pages of different
websites they earn quite well when it
comes to salary a js developer in us
earns around 75 000 per annum which when
converted to indian rupees sums around
55 lakhs approx which is a huge amount
designing a ui is an interesting job as
it needs creativity along with skills
it's always fun to design interfaces to
attract users one should need a lot of
creativity for this job the amount of
money a ui ux designer earns in india is
around 7 lakh per annum but it can go up
as much as 20 lakh per annum depends
upon the skills possessed and creativity
of the designer so choose your career
wisely
let's start this video with the
introduction to dom
dom stands for document object model it
is an api for html and xml documents
which helps javascript to understand
what is there written inside the html
document
api stands for application programming
interface to understand api better let's
take an example of a restaurant
imagine yourself in the restaurant you
are sitting at the table with the menu
the chef in the kitchen is also part of
the system the waiter here works as a
messenger between you and the chef
that's what api does
it works as a moderator between
javascript and the html document
dom defines the whole html document in a
hierarchical form to make it
understandable for javascript so that
other javascript functions can work over
it
it represents the entire document in the
form of object and nodes
whether it be elements or text or
anything stored in the document the
entire page content can be accessed or
manipulated by javascript
dom is not used with javascript only
other languages like python also uses
dom dom was designed to be used
independently to begin with dom there is
nothing special you have to do different
browsers have different implementation
of the document object model
every browser uses dom to make the web
page of the document accessible by
javascript let's move on and see what is
document object model with the help of
an example
i believe you guys have the basic
knowledge of html and css a prerequisite
for this course let's start things off
with a basic html example here we have a
code that consists tags like html head
body heading tag etc we have the html
tag here the opening html tag and the
closing html tag
inside the html tag we have the head tag
which contains the document's header
part inside the head tag there is a
title tag that contains the title of the
web page then comes the body tag which
contains a heading tag and two div tags
with ids as div 1 and div 2 a div tag
defines a particular section in the html
document the id used within the div tag
it is an attribute basically that has to
be unique within the document to make
the element unique from other elements
next up we have a paragraph tag with a
class attribute within it css and
javascript uses classes to select and
access specific elements don't worry
guys if you have no idea about it
let us first see the output of this code
before going to the document object
model of this whole document so guys
this is the output of the previous code
we just came through here we can see the
title of the web page as well as heading
after it there were two different div
tags used in the code here is the output
of both the div tags the question here
is where are those id and class
attributes seen in the output the answer
to this question is there is nothing on
this web page that can show both of them
we can use them in our css file or
through javascript to specify the
containers in which they are used so we
have concluded how a normal document
works and how the browser interprets the
html code but how javascript uses this
code is a bit different that's where dom
comes into play when the actual html
document is loaded in the browser
another representation of that document
is created known as document object
model here's the model you can see on
your screen
each of the tags used in html document
is correspondingly represented as object
in the dom
like starting from the html tag and
covering all the other tags like head
title body and few more
the same hierarchy as there was in the
html document goes with the document
object model also
document object model is simply the same
html document with different
representation
the reason behind this different
representation is that it's easy for
javascript to interpret this format
javascript can't understand tags but it
can understand these objects javascript
can easily manipulate these objects
using different functions which we will
see in future while working on these
functions for example if you want to
access the text present inside the
heading tag you can do it by accessing
the heading tag with javascript you can
also work on the style of this text with
the help of javascript as well
javascript uses the concept of nodes it
can access nodes of the document object
model there are many types of nodes
present in the dom the basic three types
are element node attribute node and text
mode the element node consists of all
the tags used in html document like the
head tag and the body tag
the attribute node contains the
attributes used in html document by now
i hope you have understood the concept
of attributes so javascript can access
these attributes as well and the user
can work upon them as per requirements
the text here in the html document that
is simply
it can also be accessed with the help of
javascript it is the value of that
particular element
before installing vs code let's discuss
a few things about what is an ide
so ide stands for integrated development
environment it is a software application
basically it comprehends facilities to a
programmer for software development just
like photoshop makes it easier for us to
edit photos in the same way ide makes it
easier for a programmer to write code if
you want to write code ide will help you
write that and it will help you in
software development
there are a number of ides present in
the market today we have sublime we have
pycharm we have comodo we have notepad
and notepad plus plus as well but in
this particular course we will be using
visual studio code or vs code we can say
so let me run you through some of the
advantages that why we are using vs code
for this codes so first of all vs code
is free to use as it is an open source
software so you can use it without any
cost
it supports multiple programming
languages there is nothing like you need
any web support or work on different
editors for different programming you
can use vs code for different languages
extensions are also one of the main
reasons behind using vs code see you
want to work on a programming language
it does not support all you have to do
is add an extension search for it and
you are good to go it will also not
affect the speed of the editor as it
runs as a different process it can also
detect code snippet whether it is
complete or not like you are using a
variable in your program and you forgot
to declare it vs code will do it for you
this property is known as intellisense
besides all these properties one main
key feature behind using vs code is it
is cross platform it is available for
mac it is available for linux and
windows as well i think there are enough
features we have discussed till now
there are many more features we will
discuss them while installing or while
working in vs code so for now let's move
on to the installation process the
installation process for vs code is
pretty simple just go to google and
search for vs code
the next page which will open here you
can see that the first link available is
from the official website click on that
and you will go to their official
website here in the front you can see
the download this you can download the
stable version from here only
or if you want to download it for you
according to your pc's specifications
you can click on the download button
present at the top right corner of your
screen here you can see that vs code is
available for different platforms it is
available for windows for linux and for
mac as well you can download it from
here as well so if you want to download
it for windows you can click here
it will take you to another page and it
will start downloading vs once the
download completes open the setup file
from your downloads and it will take you
to the license agreement page you have
to agree with all the terms and
conditions you can go through the full
license but then it will take a lot of
time to go through all this once you
click on it
this window will open where you have to
select the location you want your vs
code to locate
any id you install the default location
for all the editors is the same you can
click on browse and select any other
location if you want
but for now i'll be leaving it as it is
and i'll click on next now this will
open and you will click next from here
now it will ask you some questions like
if you want to create a desktop icon or
not select all of them and click on next
now click on install and it will install
vs code for you sit back and relax it'll
take time so once you are done with the
installation process click on finish and
the visual studio code will start
automatically
so here we are you can see that we are
on the welcome page so let's start with
these icon present on the left side of
the editor
this icon here is explorer so vs code
works with the folders in your system
click on open folder
and just
search any folder or you can take any
folder of your choice so here in my pc
i'll go to work and i'll
take javascript as my folder i'll select
it and see it will open the folder and i
already have a few programs written over
here like this
and i have a few more programs like this
and this
you can open any program from that
folder by using this explorer option you
can open any program present in that
folder so basically what it does any
program you make in visual studio code
you will save it in this folder only so
it will be easy for you
to open any program anytime next up we
have the search button
to find any keyword or word present in
your code whatever you write here it
will show you where it is present in
your code or in your document
so let's suppose i write here simply
learn c it will show you simply learn in
your main screen so you have a shortcut
key for this also press control plus f
from your keyboard and write anything
here like it's written simply linear
press enter and it'll show you the
result the third option here is for
version control if you want to use any
version control like you want to use git
vs code has very good integration with
kit the next button here is for debug or
it will run your program once you are
done with writing the code click here
and run and debug just open it with
chrome you have a shortcut for this as
well press f5 from your keyboard and it
will do the same the next button here is
for extensions here you can find many
extensions given by the vs code
community they are free to use for now
we will use these three extensions the
first one is html css support just click
on the search button write html css
support the first option click on that
and install that extension similarly you
have to install few more you have to
install javascript and type script
nightly
and you have to install live server in
the same way i'll tell you the use of
live server in the next video when we
will be writing our first hello world
program let me end this video by giving
you a shortcut let's create a new file
here click here create a new file
just
close it create a new file we will name
it as
new
dot html
so it's new.html here one thing you have
to keep in mind
while saving a file make sure to save
that file with dot html extension here
we are about to start writing our first
program so just write
exclamation mark and press enter it will
do this see it will write the basic html
code which you will need in almost every
program from now on so you don't have to
write this code every time just do it
this way and start writing main
program we are using vs code studio as a
text editor to write the script here we
have already discussed the benefits as
well as the features of vs code in the
previous video so as i have already
mentioned you must have a web browser
with javascript enabled in it so if you
are using google chrome it's quite easy
to enable javascript let me take you
through open google chrome go to
settings and just write javascript in
the search option go to site settings
and scroll down you will find here
javascript allow it if it's not allowed
in my case it's already allowed so i'm
good to go
once you have downloaded the editor and
you are done with the environment setup
and all you can start writing the
program so let's go
to vs code we will open a new file here
and save it with a name let's open a new
file and we will save it with name
first dot html make sure to save your
file with dot html extension as it will
make it easy for the computer to
understand that this particular file is
an html file so
in the last video we installed an
extension named live server let me tell
you how to use it and what are the
benefits of using live server so let's
write a basic html program or
just press the exclamation key and press
enter here we are with the basic html
program
we have not done anything yet just edit
it a little bit we will add a heading
tag and inside the heading tag we will
write a heading let's suppose we are
writing hello so now right click on your
desktop and click on open with live
server
what this will do
it will open your program in the browser
see it's the basic thing
so let me tell you what its benefits are
it will open your program in the browser
and whatever changes you are making in
the programs will be directly shown in
the browser the moment you save them see
just use google chrome or whatever
browser you are using
and in the vs code side by side we will
be using it side by side now
let's suppose we'll change something
here let's add a word here hello
world and the moment we save it it will
be reflected in your browser as well so
that's the benefit of using live server
we will be using it during our whole
code so now we are done with that let's
start with the program so here we are
with our basic html code which has only
tags in it it will print that thing if i
remove this heading tag let me remove it
and movement i save it it will print
nothing
so guys let me give you a brief
introduction to these tags these html
tags are used to render html files
properties so that the browser can
differentiate between simple text and
html tags
you can use as many tags according to
your requirements in our first program
we will write a single line statement
over the browser for that we will need
the script tag don't worry if you don't
know much about script
let me tell you briefly about this text
functionality it is used to embed a
client-side script language remember
guys script tag is used to embed
javascript with html this is where html
and javascript comes together
it may contain the scripting statements
or point towards the external script
through the src attribute we will see
the src attribute as well we'll use the
script tag inside the body tag or we can
use it wherever we want to use it like
it's not necessary to use it inside the
body tag only we can use it anywhere in
our program so let's start with this
first
let's
start the scripted
we are done with it now the script tag
we have to type an attribute
the attribute is the type is it's a text
file
we are done with our script tag to write
on the web page we use a very basic
command the document.write
it is a javascript method using which
you can print anything on the browser
let's see what document.write can do
let's write here something
document.write
and any text you want to write inside it
let's suppose hello world
welcome to
simply code
so guys we are done with this we have
written a text over here hello world
welcome to simply code let's see what
will happen when we save it
press ctrl plus s and the moment you
save it here it will be reflected on
your browser here you can see in our
browser it's written over here hello
world welcome to simply we can define
javascript in an external file as well
let's see how we can do this how this
script tag will point towards an
external javascript file here what you
have to do you have written script just
before type use an attribute src
and give it the source of the file but
till now we don't have any javascript
file so let's create a file first name
it as
script.js remember you have to save it
with dot js extension we are done with
it and we are good to go so here we will
write document
dot right
and any text you want to write here
hello world welcome to
simply learn
we will save it the moment we will save
it here
there's something wrong i guess
okay we have not given the source code
of that javascript so here we have to
give the name of that file it was
script.
moment we will save it see the text has
changed here initially it was hello
world welcome to simply code but now it
is hello world welcome to simply learn
this document.write is not interpreted
by the browser that's because this
script tag is now pointing towards an
external javascript file anything you
will write inside this script tag will
not be considered now so we are done
with the script tag here we now have an
idea of how to embed javascript with
html and now let's see some of the
features of document.write so let's
suppose you are you have written this
text here let's erase it and see what
else it can do let's give it a task to
add two numbers let's suppose we have
given here 9 plus 3 let's see if it
works
see
it will give you the output directly
here document.write 9 plus 3 it will
give you the output as 12. similarly you
will do
any mathematical task any calculation
you want to do
let's suppose
7 multiply by
see
you can see here 12 56 square let's
give it another one nine multiply five
minus let's suppose three and save it
three nine into five is forty five and
if you minus three from forty five
you'll get forty two here is the answer
for s 42
56 is for 7 into 8 7 multiplied by 8 and
12 is for 9 plus 3
so with that we are done with how to
embed with javascript with html let's
move on to another concept in javascript
that is console.log console.log is a
function in javascript that works the
same as document.write
but it will not print anything in the
browser let's give it a try
let's
clear this and
suppose we write here
console.log
and give it a command
save it and see there is nothing printed
on the browser let's write something in
the body tag we'll use a heading tag and
write something here let's go again and
go to body tag we'll use a heading tag
here as well
and write something here let's suppose
we write
plea code save it see this is printed on
the browser to open your browser's
console go to browser right click here
and go to inspect element or you can use
control plus shift plus i which i
normally do here you can see the console
option see it has many options like
elements consoles sources network and
many more but for now let's focus on
console here you can see the text
printed here so what's the point of
doing this whenever we write a code we
usually have many variables and
functions and a lot of these kinds of
things
we don't always know what to expect as
the output maybe we expect a particular
result but we might get something else
one way of debugging our code is that we
can pass a value to this function here
only and we can check the result of that
value out of the code let's add two
numbers here so if you don't understand
it basically what we are doing for now
we are writing a small piece of code
like the program is not that big but
later on when we are good with
javascript and we'll use javascript as a
primary language the
size of the program will go longer and
longer so not every time you are
supposed to
check the output of your code by doing
that only so if you are using any
variables or you are using any functions
you can check the output here only if
you have to use that variable in that
way or you have to change something so
you will get it here only that's the use
of console.log
let's add two numbers
and remove it a is equal to five and let
these value is eight
suppose
okay we are done with these two numbers
and we will what we will do we will
write
console.log
we have given it the command to add a
and b
let's see if it works here
see the value of a plus b is 13 you can
see it here in console the value is 13
you can say it here so here we can see
that the output is
13 you can do any complex calculation
here in the console it will give you the
correct answer you can see here script
dot js colon 4 the number after the
column is the line in script dot js here
in our file we can see that the
console.log command is in line number
four so here it is written that it is
line number four here so if you click on
this
you can see
the script.js opened in a very small
window and you can edit it from here as
well so this is not a random line number
to prove this let's go on to a program
and let's move this to another line see
now the console.log is in line 11.
save it and here you can see this also
changed to 11 so let's make this more
complex add another variable c we'll add
another variable here let suppose we had
c here we'll give it a more complex
equation let's suppose
let c equals to
the moment we save it it will give it
the answer
oh no we are done with the equation
let's change it here also
the value of
c
is
let's see if it works or not press
control plus s it's saved and the value
of c is 7. let's see if this value is
correct or not the value of a was 5 5
into 3 is 15
15 plus 8 is 23 23 plus 4 is 27
plus a minus 25 value of a is 5 minus 25
is minus 20
27 minus 20 the value of c is 7 say it's
correct
check it yourself if you can do
something more interesting with this
console.log or you can do something more
interesting with document.write
so console.log allows us to debug our
code and we can use it if we are not
sure about the output in a lengthy
program
so variables are named storage that a
program can manipulate as the name
suggests a variable is a value that can
change according to conditions variables
refers to those memory blocks inside the
computer where we can store information
let's suppose you want to store any
value inside your computer so variable
will represent the location of that
value
in simple terms variables are cups with
stuff inside them and you can use that
stuff later again and again according to
the way you want to before the
introduction of es6 or ecmascript we can
say which is the updated version of
javascript variables were declared using
a single keyword only which is where
we'll try to declare a few variables
here we'll see how where keyword works
so let's comment this thing first
so let's declare a few variables let's
suppose where a equals to
15 will declare
where b and the value of b will be six
we will declare where
c and the value of c would be
a plus b so here we have defined three
variables a b and c
a is a variable with value 15 stored
inside it and so is b the value of b is
six
but c is a variable that will contain
the value of a plus b let's try to print
this on browser
document.write
and we will print the value of c
save it and here you can see the value
of c is 21
that's the correct answer so similarly
you can also print a and b as well let's
print a and b as well here
what we will do we will copy this line
we will paste it for
a and
we will update this here as well
so it won't create any confusion
so here you can see the value of c is 21
the value of a is 15 and the value of b
is 6. it shows the value of all the
three variables we declared but with the
introduction of es6 or ecmascript in
two more ways were introduced to declare
a variable these are let and const we
shall discuss these two terms in the
later part of this session let me show
you how to declare a variable there are
a few things you have to keep in mind
while declaring a variable name here we
have seen we use three variables a b and
c
that was an easy task to do but giving a
variable any name like something other
than a single alphabet so you have to
keep a few things in mind while naming
them start them with a letter underscore
or a dollar sign
you can't use any sign except underscore
or dollar
so if you are
giving a variable name
you can't use any other sign except the
underscore or the dollar sign
you can use these two signs only you
can't use any other sign
you can't use a number in the starting
apart from that let's suppose you want
to give it a name as 9be you can't do
that in javascript javascript won't
allow you this if you try to save it it
will throw you an error invalid or
unexpected token so you can't do this in
javascript there is no limit for the
length of the variable name
but you can't use reserved keywords in a
variable name like let's try to create a
variable with name as class class is a
reserved keyword in javascript
we'll save it
and see here it throws an error
unexpected token class
but
you can use a class with capital c
let's save it and here it will work fine
why it works because javascript
variables are case sensitive if we try
to create a variable with same name
let's see we try to create a variable
with where girl and another variable
will be where girl with capital g this
time javascript will treat these two
variables differently these two are
different variables for javascript as
javascript is case sensitive when it
comes to variables
let's declare a few more variables let's
remove it we'll declare a few more
variables let's comment this part as
well
it will declare a few more variables
suppose we declare a variable with
keyword where and we will name this
variable as bikening
where
bike name
and press enter
if we leave this variable without
assigning it any value the by default
value will be undefined let's try to
print the value of this variable
right we will try to print the value of
byte name
save it here you can see the value it
shows is undefined so the by default
value of a variable if you do not assign
it any value will be undefined
let's try to give it a value let's
suppose we
try to give bike name
we use equals to operator to assign it a
value to assign let's suppose we will
assign it
yamaha
semicolon and press ctrl plus s to save
this and here you can see the output as
yamaha you can also assign a value to
the variable during declaration as we
have done in the previous examples here
we have assigned the variables value at
the time of declaration only let's move
on to let and const
so we will discuss let and cons but
first we will compare let with where let
is also used to declare a variable just
like where is used but there is a
limitation to use let
let is not accessible outside the block
in which it is declared
so we will use let here only let bike
name equals and we will change this
value as well we will change it to hero
let's say
save it and here you can see the output
as hero but if we try to put this code
inside a block
let's suppose we put this code inside
this block a pair of curly braces
and we will again try to access
document.write we will try to access
bike name again
from here from outside the block we try
to access this save it and here you can
see by name is not defined it is an
error in line 18. so what's happening
here basically you can't access a let
variable outside the scope
you can't access it from here but it
will work with where we try to replace
let with where and save it here you can
see it says hero and hero
because first it will interpret this
method and then it will interpret this
as well in case of where due to its
limited scope let variables are used
when there is limited use only like in
for loop or in while loop we will learn
these loop in future let will not allow
you to re-declare any variable let's
understand this with an example here is
the code as well we have declared
where bike name and we'll remove this
and first we'll try to do this with
where let's suppose where bike name
equals to tbs control plus s it says
hero and tvs so the variable name the
bike name is same in both cases here and
here as well
these are same but with where keyword
you can do that let will not allow you
to do this if we use let here in place
of
where we'll write let here as well and
we'll change the value as well we will
give it as
kawasaki
and
let's suppose suzuki here
save it
see
bike name has already been declared
so that's what let won't allow you to do
you can repeat the same let variable in
different scope it won't create any
problem but it will not allow you to
redeclare any declared variable so let's
move on to const we use const when there
are values we don't want to change or
that will never change basically so the
keyword constant is little misleading as
it defines a constant reference to a
value not the constant value we can't
change the primitive value but we can
change the properties of constant
objects
let's write another piece of code for
const keyword
so let's declare a
variable const
x
is equal to
comma y is equal to
7 let's say once
so here what we have done we declared a
variable x and a variable y with value
as 5 and 7 we declared this time with
const keyword and variable z which is x
plus y
we printed z on the browser and it shows
the value as 12 which is x plus y 7 plus
5 is equal to 12 now what we will do
const will let you do this but if you
try to update the value of x let's
suppose we try to
update the value of x as x equals to x
plus 10
we'll print
x this time
document.write
x let's save this it will throw an error
assignment to a constant variable in
line 24 so here you want to update the
value of x you can't do this with const
keyword you can do this with let and
where as well but you can't do this with
const
also const won't allow you to redeclare
any variable just like let so if you try
to use const x again
is equal to 10 save it
so here it says identifier x has already
been declared this thing you can do with
cons the scope of const is the same as
let it can be used within the block
where it is declared
data types is an essential concept in
every programming language to work on
any variable you should know its type
it refers to the kind of data which is
being stored inside a variable
the type of variable is holding
basically
every programming language has its own
set of data types which is unique in its
own way
we discussed earlier that javascript is
a lightweight scripting language
because we don't need to specify any
data type in javascript after all all
the variables in javascript are loosely
packed or we can say javascript is a
dynamically typed scripting language we
shall discuss these properties later in
this video for now let me tell you about
different data types present in
javascript
so javascript data types are divided
into two categories primitive data types
and non-primitive data types primitive
data types are stored in stack whereas
non-primitive data types they are stored
in heap i don't want you to go deep in
these two terms as if you are new to
programming so we'll leave it just keep
one thing in mind that primitive data
types are base data types whereas
non-primitive data types are objects or
we can say they are derived
primitive data types they are further
divided into five categories they are
divided as numbers strings boolean
undefined null non-primitive data types
or complex data types we can say on the
other hand they are divided into two
parts arrays and objects we'll have
separate videos on these topics for now
let's discuss primitive data types to
understand primitive data types much
better
let's declare a few variable here
let's say we declare where x and give it
the value as 16
we'll declare where y
and we'll give it value
hello wool we'll declare one more let's
say where
flag
and the value will be true
here we can talk about those properties
of javascript which i mentioned earlier
javascript variables are loosely packed
and javascript is a dynamically typed
scripting language these two points
refer to the same thing here you can see
we have defined three variables
x we have defined variable x we have
defined variable y and flag as well
the values for all three variables is
different from one another
see variable x is holding a value that
is 16 variable y
is holding a value hello world which is
a string so 16 is a number hello world
is a string and variable flag is holding
a value that refers to a boolean value
in place of true we can also write false
here
so
what's happening here here you can see
there is no data type if you are coming
from a c plus plus background or a java
background
this will be a little bit weird for you
guys because in c plus and java we used
to do it like we will define an integer
let let me show you
so how we will define integer in c plus
plus or what we'll say we'll use int x
equals to five
or something like that we already had a
data type for string as well we have
carrying c plus plus but here in
javascript we have no data type we are
only using the where keyword that's what
we call as loosely typed
this line means that you don't have to
define the data type of the variable
what happens in javascript is whatever
the type of value you will pass to the
variable the data type will change
accordingly
so you don't need to worry about if you
are passing a number or if you are
passing in string
just relax just when you pass the value
to the variable it will be determined
automatically so these are the three
basic primitive data types present in
javascript
which are number
boolean value and string
so let's move on to the next one which
is undefined we'll define a variable p
and we'll leave it as it is so this
variable p has an undefined data type it
means that any variable which is already
declared but has no value inside it it
has an undefined data type
i'll tell you a basic operator the type
of operator
will go through the operators in later
videos but just try to understand the
basic need and use it with me for now
this operator will help you know the
type of value a variable is holding see
let's use it here we have declared a
variable p
will check the type of p
so to use this operator you have to use
it with document dot right now
so we'll do document.write and we'll use
two brackets
and inside it will write
type of and whatever like if you want to
know the type of variable x let's
suppose we'll write here x
semicolon save it and you can see here
it says number this means that this
variable has a value which is a number
similarly we will check for all the
variables present here we'll check for
every variable we'll check for why we'll
check for flag and we'll check for p as
well let's copy this and
paste it three times and let's change
the value here
from x to y in this line
and from x to flag here
and here we'll change it to p
so we have done it we'll save it and see
here it says number first variable y it
says it's a string because you know
hello world is a string it's a sequence
of character
for
variable flag it says boolean so it's
defined as true or false and
for variable p it's written here
undefined with this we are left with
only one primitive data type the null
data type there is a difference between
a null value and an undefined value
undefined means lack of value whereas
null means the absence of any value
suppose you are using null as the value
for any variable the type of operator
will return this variable as an object
but if you are not giving any value to
this variable you are leaving it after
declaration the type of operator will
return undefined here's an example for
this c
we'll declare one more variable here
we'll declare where
num let's name this variable num and we
will give it the value as null
we'll use document.write type of and we
will check with the help of type of
operator that what type of value the
variable num is holding so let's give
here
number we are good to go press control
plus s and c
here it says it's an object
so a null value will always be shown as
an object
we'll talk about the complex types or
composite types in further videos we'll
have separate videos for each of these
types don't worry about it
in any programming language an operator
is a symbol that makes the computer
understand that it needs to do some
specific tasks
like if we want to perform an addition
between two numbers let's say we want to
perform addition between 4 and 5
so guys
if you see the plus sign here this is
known as the operator and the two terms
which are four and five these two
numbers
these are known as the operands
we have different operators for
different purposes like we have plus for
addition we have minus for subtraction
we have star or asterisk we can say for
multiplication and many more other
operators as well
so there are many more operators present
in almost every programming language
which is present out there like it
operators are present in java they are
present in c plus plus in c almost every
programming language out there has the
concept of operators it's essential for
you to know how and where to use any
operator despite of the language you are
working on one needs to understand which
operators are available right so in this
particular video i'll take you through
the basic types of operator present in
javascript i'll let you know the types
and we'll learn about how to use them
and of course i'll take you through the
different categories of operators
present in javascript so in javascript
there are basically eight categories
into which operators are divided
which are we have arithmetic operators
we have assignment we have string we
have conditional we have logical bitwise
comparison and type of operator
we'll discuss the first three types in
this video that is we'll discuss the
arithmetic operators we'll discuss the
assignment and the string operators
rest we'll talk about in the following
video
first up here is the arithmetic operator
hope you all are aware of the term
arithmetic
right
so
arithmetic operators perform
mathematical calculations like it
performs addition subtraction
multiplication and division as well
so here are the few operators you can
see on your screen the plus operator
minus asterisk division we have modulus
we have increments we have decrement so
these are the basic arithmetic operator
we'll see each of these operator with an
example so let's move on to the
programming part first so guys i want to
mention one more thing here i want all
of you to make a separate file for each
topic we'll be covering from now on like
for operators you'll create a separate
file will create a separate one for
control statements and other topics will
cover in future from today so i want you
to create a separate file because you
know in future if you want to access
these topics it will be easy for you to
access those files instead if you are
using a single file for all the topics
it will be quite confusing so let's
start with the arithmetic operators
first let's take two variables we are in
the javascript file let's take two
variables let's say where
x equals to 6
and we'll take another variable let's
say where y equals to
4.
now we'll perform some arithmetic
operations on these two variables we
have already seen the arithmetic
operators present like we have plus
minus we have increment decrement we
have multiplication division so we'll go
through all of these right so let's
start with it here we are done with our
basic three operators which is addition
subtraction and multiplication i have
commented the division because i have
something to tell you about the division
so let's check the output here first
let's save it and see the output is
addition 10 subtraction 2 and
multiplication 24. for addition it added
the two numbers it's 6 plus 4 similarly
for subtraction and multiplication it is
6 minus 4 and it's 6 multiplied by 4.
for division i have left division
because i hope you guys know the
difference between division and the
modulus operator let's try to use the
modulus operator along with the division
so what we'll do we'll comment these
three and let's remove it from here and
what we'll do we'll
paste this here and we'll use the
modulus here so
now let's check the output what it says
for division and modulus
see
we have divided 6 by 4
division it says it's 1.5
6 divided by 4 that is 1.5 it will show
the quotient here for modulus it's
saying 2 because
in modulus it gives you the remainder
and in
division it gives you the quotient as
the answer so keep this thing in mind
guys keep this in mind always take a
note of it so we are done with division
and modulus next up we have the
increment and the decrement operators
let me show them to you real quick so
what we'll do we'll declare another
variable let's say where z equals to 5
and
we'll use the increment operator here
we'll use again document.write
and here we'll let's say we write
increment how to use increment operator
for increment operator you have to use
plus
plus whatever variable you have used so
we'll use plus plus z
and similarly we'll copy this
paste it here and here we'll use
minus minus for decrement
and change here as well
so let's see what happens
let me give some space in between them
so that you won't get confused
let's save it and check the output here
increment is it says 6 and decrement it
is 5.
so you can see here the functioning of
decrement and increment operator the
increment operator will increase the
value of z by 1 and the decrement
operator will do the opposite of this it
will decrease the value by 1. so we are
done with the arithmetic operators next
up we have the assignment operators
assignment operators are used to assign
values to different javascript variables
let's see the types first and then we'll
see how to use them so we have these
assignment operators here here we have
equals to plus equals to minus equals to
and we have
multiplied equals to we have divide
equals to modulus equals two and a few
more
so let's see each of them with example
maybe not each of them but we'll try to
cover almost every
single operator out there which is
present in your screen so let's move on
and see let's move on to the programming
part so here we are guys let's declare a
few variables let's say we are declaring
a variable a
and we are giving it the value as 10
suppose
and we'll declare another one let's say
where b and give it the value
5.
so for assignment operators what
assignment operator
mean
we have used here the equal to sign
right we have used a equals to 10.
this means whatever value present on the
right side of the operator like here it
is 10 it will be assigned to the
variable a
i hope you guys are getting this keep
this in mind
so we have the value 10 and we are
assigning this value to the variable a
it says let's try to check the output of
a let's try to print a on the screen
okay
document
see here you can see that the value of a
it says 10
and similarly the value of b is 5. so
let's do one more thing we'll assign the
value of a to b how to do this let's
change the value here only let's suppose
we are using the value of where a s 13
okay and the value of where b will be
providing as let's say a
so
now let's try to print the value of b
here we will change we'll print the
value of b only
let's save it and see the output see it
says the value of b is 13
because we have assigned b the value
present at variable a which is 13 that's
why it is showing the value of b as 13
this is what assignment operator is
let's try other assignment operators as
well
let's take another variable
so let's say where even
equals to let's say 51
so the next operator we will be using is
let's update the value of a1 first so
how to
do this let's say a 1 equals 2
no it's a 1 plus equals to 9
and
we'll print the value
let's check the output now see it says
the value of a1 is 60 here we have given
that a1 plus equals to 9 see a 1 plus
equals to 9 is the same as if you don't
want to write here a 1 plus equals to 9
you can also write it as a 1
equals to
a 1
plus 9
both of these lines are same both these
statements means the same they are
performing the same task
so a 1 equals to a 1 plus 9 is same as a
1 plus equals to 9. that's what i want
you to understand with assignment
operators
similarly if you want to perform a 1
minus equals 2 you can do it as well so
let's say even minus is equal to 5 and
we'll copy this line from here paste it
here again and save it now let's see the
output here what it says some of you
guys may get confused that here it shows
the value of 6 is 69 of a1 so in the
first statement when we tried to print a
1 here the initial value was 51 then
this statement was performed and the
value was updated to 60 then after that
one more statement this statement is
also performed and the value updated to
69 it's 51 plus 9 plus 9 and the value
we have here is 69 now what happens if
we are using the minus equals 2 operator
what it will do it will
decrease the value of a 1 by 5 it means
that
a 1 equals to a 1 minus 5 the value of a
1 is 69 and it will subtract 5 from 69
so here it says the value of a1 is 64.
hope you guys are getting this
so we have so many operators we have so
many of them like let's try a few more
so we have multiply equals to we have
division equals to we have modulus
equals to so i'll write these and then
we'll see the output
so we are done with it let's check the
output here for a3 a4 and a5 you can see
for a3 we have used multiply equals to
for a4 we have used divide equals to and
for a5 we have used modulus equals to
let's check the output here
save it and see
it says the value of a3 50
it here we have taken a3 s5 it's 10 into
5 because a3 equals to a3 into 5 so it's
10 into 5 it shows the value as 50.
similarly here it says the value of a4
is 3.75 because we have used here 4 so
instead of 4 let's try to use 3 and save
it see here you can see it divides it
and gives you the quotient and the value
of a4 divided by 3 is 5.
so
similarly for a5 it shows the value of
a5 is 6
because we have used the modulus
operator here and 20 divided by 7 we
have 6 as remainder
so
i hope you guys are pretty clear with
assignment operators now next up we have
string operators the plus operator which
we used as the arithmetic operators
earlier right it also operates as a
string operator so we can use it to
concatenate two strings that mean we can
add two strings as well in javascript it
is possible with the help of string
operator similarly we have plus equals
to operator for strings as well like we
have plus equal to for assignment it has
the same functioning for string as well
let's take the example for these two
operators let's move on to the
programming part
so here you can see we have two
variables where str1 and where str2 the
value of where str1 is hello and the
value of where str2 is world so what
we'll do we will add str1 and str2 so
let's check the output here save it and
see here you can see the output as hello
world
but there is no space between hello and
world keep this point in mind guys so if
you are adding two strings just like
this there will be no space between the
two string so if you want to add any
space between these two but you have to
do you have to mention it here
separately
and this this is the syntax if you want
to add space between your strings
so let's save it now and see here you
can see there is a space between hello
and world
so this is the use of plus operator in
strings so the next one we have plus
equals to let's take another string
let's take it as whereas tr3 and we'll
give it the value as
welcome
so what we'll do
we'll use the plus equal to operator
here str3 plus equals to
let's say
to
simply code
and
what we'll do we'll print the value of
str3 here
so save it now
so here you can see the value of str3 if
we remove this this line
let's see what happens now
and we'll give it a space here
save it now
see here you can see it says hello world
for the first str1 plus str2 it says
hello world
for str3 it says welcome to simply code
see here the space is already given so
it will show this in the output but
between welcome and 2 if you want to add
space you have to
do the same what you have done for str1
and str2 so let's do it here as well
plus sign yes
save it now and see here you can see
it says welcome to simply code with
proper space now we will cover the rest
of the operators now we are left with
five more these are the first three
operators now we are left with
conditional operators logical operators
we have bitwise operator and we have
comparison and finally we have the type
of operator
so these are the five operators we are
going to cover today
before we start with the operators let
us first discuss associativity talking
about associativity
it refers to the direction in which the
entire expression is evaluated for
example if you have any expression let's
say you have a plus b
so the direction in which this
expression will be evaluated either it
will be from left to right or from right
to left so this is known as
associativity let's understand it with
the help of an example
so here you can see i have taken three
variables i have taken variable a
and i have assigned it value as 12 i
have taken variable b and the value
assigned to b is 8 and finally i have a
variable result which stores the value
of a plus b
lastly what i am doing is i am printing
out the result variable inside the h1
tag here you can see i've used the h1
tags
and
i have used the plus operator to
concatenate the strings right i have
concatenated these two strings along
with the result along with the answer of
result
so the plus operator here is doing two
different tasks right
here you can see it is performing the
addition of two numbers right and here
you can see it is used to concatenate
two strings so now let's talk about
associativity because i guess you guys
are clear with string operator till now
we have discussed them in the previous
video right
so let's talk about associativity now so
certain operators have right to left
associativity and certain operators have
left to right associativity
so when i say right to left
associativity in this case the value
present at the right side of the
operator see if you are using any
operator for example here you we have
used the assignment operator right we
have discussed the assignment operator
earlier so here you can see the value
present at the right hand side of the
operator will be assigned to the
variable which is present at the left
hand side of the term so
it's going this way like first the
computer will check the for the value
present at the right it's going from
right towards the left this is what we
are known as right to left associativity
and assignment operators like equals to
this have right to left associativity
let's add here one more variable let's
say we are adding a variable variable c
and we are giving it the value as
5 and what we will do we will update
result as well let me first show you the
output of this particular program see
the output will be value of result is 20
and high there high there is
concatenated with
the string value of result is and 20 is
the actual answer the 20 is the value of
result so let's add one more variable
here let's say we are adding a variable
c and the value of c will be 5.
what we will do now we will update
result as well here you can see i have
done a plus b plus c so
save it and here you can see the value
updated
to 25 the value of result is updated
right
so the plus operator has associativity
from left to right till now we have
talked about right to left as for
assignment operators but for plus
operators the associativity is from left
to right it means it will first perform
a plus b
and then the value of c will be added to
that of a plus b first it will perform
12 plus 8 and then finally it will add 5
to that value so it will be 20 plus 5
and that's why the output here is 25
we know that javascript is a loosely
typed programming language right which
means that we don't have to specify data
types every time
like we are using if we are using any
data type we don't need to specify it
every time like
let's do one thing let's add a string
here so what we'll do we'll add a string
let's suppose i'm adding hello
so practically the answer would be hello
plus
25 or hello 25 it should be the answer
but let's check the output now save it
and here you can see the output is hello
one two eight five what happened here is
the associativity of the plus operator
is from left to right we know this so it
will start from the left and it will see
that okay the first thing to add is a
string so it will assume that everything
ahead of this will be a string that's
why we have the output as hello
12 8 and 5 so 12 8 and 5 all are acting
as string here
let me clear this one for you with a
little bit of modification now what
we'll do
we'll
remove this string from here and we'll
add it somewhere else let's say we are
adding it here
so
let's add one more variable to make it
more clear let's say we are using
variable d and the value will be 10
and what we will do we will perform a
plus b before the string and then we
will perform c plus d
right so here you can see when you save
it
it says 20 hello 510
so when it reached out the first
variable it finds out that the first
variable is a number so it added the
first two numbers right it added 12 and
8 the answer is 20 then it came across
this string hello and then finally
assume that everything ahead of this
will be a string so that's the output 20
is the addition of a plus b and then the
string hello and finally we have the
value of c and d as string so we have
the value 5 and 10 not 15 right i hope
you guys get this
so
let's move on to conditional operators
the conditional operators assign a value
to a variable based on a certain
condition like it contains a condition
and you know for every condition like
there exists only two possibilities
either it can be true or it can be false
there is nothing else you can do with a
conditional operator so it works the
same as if else statements which we'll
cover in further videos the only
difference between if else and
conditional operators that it takes less
time or we can say its usage is pretty
easy
so here is the syntax for conditional
operators
so it seems pretty straightforward right
so here you can see we have a variable
name we have a condition depending upon
the condition we have two values
here is the example as well c
you can see we have a variable voter
next up we have a condition if h is less
than 18 so it will check for the
condition that if the value of age is
actually less than 18 let's suppose the
value of age is 15
so it will check if 15 is less than 18
it's true then it will print 2m or if
the value of h is greater than 18 then
it will print false or you can say it
will print old enough here
so let's move on to the programming part
so here you can see i have taken a
variable x and the value assigned to x
is 30. what we'll do in variable y i
have given it a condition so it will
check for x which is 30 if 30 is greater
than or equal to 50
so if it's true if 30 is actually
greater than 50 then it will print true
else it will print false so we'll check
the output once let's save it and see
here you can see the output as false so
if we update the value of axial let's
suppose we are updating the value of x
let's suppose it's
60 save it now and see the output has
changed to true because 60 is greater
than 50 right
also if you want to write a message here
only you can do it write it here as
so we'll copy it from here we'll copy
document.write
and we'll paste it here
let's remove this
document.right and we what we'll do
we'll
use this bracket
here
and if any message you want to write
like you want to write
value of
so
and now what we'll do we'll
save it
see it says value of true
so
or you can write any other message here
as well you can write value of x is
greater than or you can write whatever
so if you want to update it like value
is
and here we will update true
with
greater
and here we will use
smaller
save it now
see here it says value is greater value
of x is greater than y
so that's all for conditional operators
also one more thing and conditional
operators has three different parts
right
and that's why it is also known as
ternary operator three different parts
as in it has a
condition like here it is it's it has a
condition and it has two values right it
has true or false so that's why it is
also known as ternary operator
next up we have the logical operators
so logical operators are used to
determine the logic between two
variables or values we can say
we use logical operators to check
whether multiple conditions are true or
false
here on your screen you can see the
three different types of logical
operators present in javascript along
with the syntax and example
so the end or not are the three
operators present in javascript
the and operator here you can see
it it is holding two values right it
it has x less than 10 and y greater than
one
so the end operator will return true
only if both the conditions are true
like x has to be less than 10 and y has
to be
greater than 1. so here you can see we
have taken x equals to 7 and y equals to
4 so both the conditions are satisfying
here so that's why
the output of the and operator will be
true
for our operator the case is a bit
different
so if any one of these two conditions
like we have two conditions if any one
of these two is true then the output
will be true and if both are false then
only the output will be false
the north operator on the other hand
will check if x is equals to y if the
value x is holding is equals to that of
y
if the value is not equal then it will
return true
i hope you are getting this that's a
little bit
confusing but if the value x and y
holding
if they are not equal then it will
return true if they are equal then it
will return false
right
we will understand the programming
concept of logical operators in further
videos when we learn about control
statements
we primarily use logical operators with
the if statement through which we'll
come across in the following video in
the next video we will go through the
control statements so we'll understand
the programming part of logical operator
there only
next up we have the comparison operators
so comparison operators are similar to
logical operators in some way they are
also used to check for true and false as
the name suggests we use comparison
operator to compare two values or we can
say to compare two variables using
different operators
so here you can see on your screen these
are the different types of comparison
operators present in javascript we have
equals 2 we have not equals 2 we have
equal value and data type we have
greater than less than and we have a few
more so
i hope you guys must remember from the
previous video that a single equals two
operator is an assignment operator so if
we are using a single equals to then it
will be considered as an assignment
operator for comparison we have to use
double equal to keep this thing in mind
whenever you are using any operator in
javascript or especially the equals two
operator so if you want to compare two
values you have to use double equals two
because single equals 2 is used to
assign values this is an assignment
operator so let's move on to the
programming part now
so guys here you can see i have taken a
variable x and the value assigned to x
is 10
this code seems a little bit longer to
you but that's a simple piece of code
like i've used almost every comparison
operator we came across in the previous
slide i have used each one of them
and i have used the document.write after
every
comparison operator to put some spaces
in between so that you guys don't
confuse between them
so let's check the output now see as you
can see i have used the double equals to
the triple equals to
i have used x not equals to it so let's
check the output
save it and see here it says false false
true true true false true false so for x
equals to equals to it it compared the
value 10 with it
and 10 and 8 are not equals to so the
output will be false as similar for 10
and we have used the triple equals 2
operator which means equal value and
data type so both 10 and 8 have equal
data type they both have the same data
type that is number but the values are
different
so it will print false
for x not equals to it it says 10 is not
equals to it yeah 10 is not equals to it
actually so it will print true similarly
for x
naught equals to equals to it it will
check that
both the values are not equal but the
data types are equal right so it will
print true for this as well
for x greater than 8 yeah 10 is greater
than 8 so it will print true
similarly for it will check for x
smaller than 8 and it will check for x
greater than equals to it and also for x
less than equals to it
so
by now you have understood how
comparison operators work so comparison
operators are the easiest to use in
programming
and that's all for comparison operators
let's move on to the next one we have
the next type of operator we have is the
type of operator you guys have an idea
about the type of operators right as we
have discussed it earlier in case you
haven't watched the previous videos let
me give you a brief introduction about
this type of operator
so the type of operator is used to
provide you with the type of whatever
value you
put to the right of it like if you are
using any data type and you want to know
about the data type of a particular
variable let's say so you can use the
type of operator it will tell you the
actual data type of any variable so
in javascript as we have discussed
earlier in the video where we have
particularly discussed about the data
types so there are five different types
of primitive data types right we have
the numbers we have strings we have
boolean we have null and undefined
so let's try to use type of operator
so here you can see i have used four
different variables which are i've used
variable x
variable y
and variable flag and variable p so the
values are different the x is holding 17
y is holding hey there and flag has the
value as false and i have defined p but
i have not assigned it any value till
now
so what i'll do i have used the type of
operator to find out the type of every
variable like here i have used it for x
for y for flag and for p
let's
check the output now
save it and see it says number string
boolean and undefined
see here we have given x the value as 17
so 17 is a number then it says it is a
number
for hedia it says it is a string for
false it says it is a boolean value like
in boolean value we have only two values
like false and true
so for variable p it says undefined
you know there is a difference between
undefined and null data types undefined
means lack of value whereas null means
this absence of value that there is no
value at all
so suppose you are using null as the
value for any variable right the type of
operator will return
object but if you are not giving any
value to
any variable like you are using the
variable as it is like here we have not
given it any value so if you are doing
this the type of operator will return
undefined so let's take an example of
null as well
let's declare another variable let's say
where
abc
and we'll give it the value as
null so and finally what we'll do we'll
use type of operator
save it and see here it says the type of
variable abc is an object
so remember this thing guys
and now we are done with almost seven
operators we had and we are left with
one operator only
so let's move on to our last operator
which is the bitwise operator this
operator doesn't have that much of
practical usage in the real world they
are not definitely useless but this is
something like we are not going to use
on a daily basis so in computers
if you know the numbers are stored in
binary format
bitwise operators work on 32 bit numbers
and we have decimal numbers like we
understand decimal numbers computer
works on binary numbers right so when
bitwise operators are used any operand
present in the operation
is first converted to a binary number
and then converted back to a javascript
number
so
here you can see on your screen
we have four different
bitwise operators we have the and
operator we have or we have not and we
have
zor or we can say exclusive or
the result and the answers are also here
it's pretty simple see
we have used the and operator before as
well while we were in logical operators
but the syntax was different and
here you can see we have a single
ampersand sign to use bitwise and
operator
so here you can see
how the decimal number first changes to
a binary number suppose we have x as 5
here you can see x is first changed to a
binary number this is the binary
equivalent of 5 and 1 is also changed to
a binary number and finally the result
whatever result we get it is changed to
a decimal number so that's how bitwise
operators work let's take an example of
bitwise operators
so here you can see i have taken two
variables i have taken variable x and
the value of variable x is 5 and another
variable is y and the value of y is one
and then i have used
all the four bitwise operators like i
have used x and y i have used x or y
i have used not x and i have used the
xor operator between x and y so let's
check the output now
here you can see
if we talk about the output
see here it says 1 5 minus 6 and 4 so
for x and y see
the value of x is 0 1 0 1 and for end
operators
it will return 1 if both the values are
1. if any one of the 2 values are 0 then
it will return 0. so what it will return
here it will return 0 for 0 0 for 1 0 it
will also return 0 similarly for 0 0 it
will also return 0 and for 1 month it
will return 1
which is the binary equivalent of 1 so
the answer here is 1. for x or y it will
return one if any one of the two values
are one
see if both are zero it will return zero
if any one of the two values is one it
will return one
it will return 0 again and finally it
has 2 ones so it will return 1
and 0 1 0 1 is the binary equivalent of
5 that's why the output here is 5
for not operator it works a little bit
different it gives you the output which
is same as
minus x minus 1 so minus x minus 1 will
be
see minus x minus 1 will be minus 5
minus 1 which is minus 6 so this is a
bit different here the not operator here
is a bit different
for
xor operator or we can say exclusive or
it will return 4
why it will return 4 it will return one
when
any one of the two values is one if both
are one then also it will return false
it will return one only in one condition
if any one of the two values is one then
only it will return one that's why the
output here
the output here will be 0 1 0 0 that's
why it's written as 4 which is the
binary equivalent of 0 1 0 0.
so the term control statement is pretty
self-explanatory and straightforward
right we came across javascript
statements in previous videos javascript
statements are the instructions that
tells the browser to perform specific
actions
control statements are also instructions
and they govern the flow of control in a
program
so let's take a look at control
statements with the help of an example
let's suppose we have a piece of code
that has n number of statements here
let's say we have this code and so the
conventional workflow will be it will
first execute the first statement then
second then third and so on till
statement n right
so this is the basic flow right from
statement one till statement n and it
will execute each statement in between
however in real world the scenario is
different like we don't write the code
in same menu every time
for example let's suppose
you are in line 5 and you want to print
this line 10 times so what should you do
you can write this line 10 times or
you can copy paste it right okay let's
forget about 10 times let's suppose you
have to use this
code or we can say let's suppose you
have to print this statement 100 times
doing this like copy pasting it for 100
times or writing this statement 400
times that's useless and unnecessary
right so that's where control statements
comes into picture we'll discuss them in
a while let's assume another situation
this time you want to make a choice
based on certain conditions you can use
conditional operators but then it has
limitations right to tackle this problem
we have control statements in javascript
so these are the very basic reasons why
we need control statements for
performing a certain activity
like if we want to perform a certain
activity n number of times or if you
want to make a certain decision making
kind of scenarios in your program that's
where we need control statements in
javascript
in javascript we have two different
types of control statements depending
upon what action we are performing so we
have the conditional control statements
and we have the iterative or
we can say
looping control statements
talking about conditional statements as
the name suggests we use conditional
statements when we have to make
decisions based on conditions when we
have two choices or when we can say when
we have two different conditions and we
want to make choices accordingly so
that's where we use conditional
statements we have two different types
of conditional statements the if else
statements and the switch case
talking about the iterative statements
as the name suggests if you want to
perform any action more than once or
maybe n number of times
instead of writing them again and again
we use loops so loops are basically
statements
we use loops to perform any activity n
number of times with specific conditions
so in javascript we have four different
type of loops we have for loop while
loop do while loop and foreign loop
so the for loop while loop and do while
loop you might have heard about them
earlier because they are also present in
other programming languages
but this foreign loop
this is a new type of loop present in
javascript
we use foreign loop with objects we'll
go through objects in
upcoming videos and of course we'll be
looking at each of these control
statements in detail
will have a particular video for each of
these topic
now let me introduce to you the break
and the continue statement
they are not the types of control
statements but they do assist in other
control statements
the break is used to exit a switch
statement or loop like when used in a
loop
it breaks the loop and continues
executing the code after it
and
on the other hand the continue statement
breaks a single iteration when used in a
loop when we use continuous statement in
a loop it breaks a single iteration and
it breaks the iteration only if the
specified condition occurs and then it
will continue with the next iteration in
the loop
so the if else conditional statement is
used whenever we work with condition
it can be either a single condition or
maybe more than one condition or
multiple conditions we can work with
so let's try to write a basic
program with a single condition
so then we'll
move on to multiple conditions using the
else if statement so we'll create a new
file today so
i hope you guys know the importance of
creating a separate file for every topic
you know it will be easy for you to work
or to find out that separate file later
if you want to revise that topic
so here is the program where we have
taken a variable x and the value of x is
10 so what we are doing in this program
is we are checking if the value the
variable x is holding that is the value
and if the value is less than
10 or if the value is
greater than 10 so we have only two
conditions either the value can be less
than 10 or the value can be greater than
10 or equals to 10 as
so here in this program what we'll do
will
first will update this value as 8 so the
variable x is holding the value 8
so to check the output let's save it and
here you can see it says the value of x
is less than 10 of course the value 8 is
always less than 10 right so for it
that's fine it will say the value is
less than 10 and similarly if we do the
same for let's say 11 save it now and
see it says the value of x is greater
than 10
so that's quite simple right but what if
we are giving the value as 10
we know 10 is equals to 10 so save it
now and see here you can see
it says the value of x is greater than
this is happening because what we did we
as we told the interpreter to check the
value if the value of x is less than 10.
we didn't mention that if what to do if
the value is equals to 10 so it will
check for only x is less than 10 not for
equals to 10 or greater than 10
so here what it is doing it is checking
if the value is less than 10 so that it
says okay let's print this statement if
the value is less than 10
or
if the value is not less than 10 or if
the value is equals to or greater than
10 it will print the value of x is
greater than 10.
to avoid this type of misunderstanding
we use an else if statement so the
concept of elsif statement is the same
as if statement what we are doing we are
using
multiple conditions right we are giving
it more than one condition so how to use
elsif it's quite easy
and the syntax is also similar to
the if statement the only difference is
that it contains an else before if so
it's an elsif so what we are doing is
we are giving it a condition that else
if x equals to 10.
so now what it will do it will check for
two conditions that if the value x is
holding is less than 10 or equals to 10
and what we will do will update it is
let's check the output now
save and see here it says the value of x
is equals to 10 right so i hope you guys
are getting this
the execution flow for this program will
be like it will check for the first
condition if x is less than 10 if yes it
will print the value of x is less than
10. if no it will move on to the
following condition like under the else
if statement it finds a condition that
if x is equals to 10 it will check for
it if yes if x is equals to 10 then it
will print the value of x is equals to
or if not then otherwise it will move to
else statement and print the value of x
is greater than 10. we do not need to
specify any particular condition for
this you know because we have already
specified the two conditions that
if x is less than 10 or if x is equals
to 10 now we'll take a look at some
basic programs other than this one we'll
take a look at a few more basic programs
so here is the another program
what we are doing here is we are taking
a variable x and the value of x is 5
so what we are doing is we are checking
if the number is an even number or an
odd number
thing you have to keep in mind is the
logic to find whether a number is even
or an odd number so to check uh whether
a number is even you what we do will
divide that number with 2 right what
basically we want is we want
the remainder as 0 when we use the
modulus operator so what we'll do here
we have written x mod 2 equals to equals
to 0. so if the remainder is 0
then the number will be an even number
because it is divisible by 2 else it
will be an odd number so that's quite
simple right let's save it and check the
output for 5 it says odd number yeah 5
is of course an odd number right so
that's for even an odd number
so here we are with another program
here it says we have a variable y and
the value of y is
let's say
and what we are doing here is we are
checking if a number is positive or
negative or zero so we have three
different conditions either number can
be positive or it can be a negative
number any number greater than zero is a
positive number right and any number
less than zero is a negative number and
the third one is
a number zero it's neither positive nor
negative
so let's check for the number eight save
it and see here you can see it is a
positive number let's see for
minus 2 save it now it says a negative
number for 0 it will say 0.
so these two programs are quite simple
guys right the conditions are pretty
simple we use
modulus operator we used greater than or
less than sign and
that's quite easy to use right so let's
move on to the next program which is a
bit tricky than these two so what we'll
do in our next program is we'll check if
a number is positive or negative
and at the same time we'll check for
even and odd also
if we are giving any number as input
like let's suppose we are using 5 we'll
check if the number is positive or
negative and odd or even so we'll do
this simultaneously let's move on to
this program so there are two ways to
check whether the number is
positive or negative and
order even
so the two methods we will discuss them
one by one the first one here is
to use nested if and another one is when
we use logical operators along with the
if else if statement
so this one here you can see right in
front of your screen is
the
nested if method so here you can see we
have used the if statement we have given
one more condition inside another if
statement so first it will check whether
a number is positive
or not for x greater than 0 it will
check if the number x is greater than 0
then if yes if it will find it that yes
this number is greater than 0 then it
will move on to the
nested if and it will check for odd or
even
for odd number and even number it will
check if it finds that the number is
even it will print that the number
is positive and even
if the number is not even it will print
the number is positive and odd so
here you can see the difference what the
interpreter is doing is it will check
for the number as positive and if the
number is positive then it will move on
to the nested if and check for the even
or odd so if it finds that the number is
even it will print positive and even
otherwise it will print positive and odd
then it will move on to the next
condition which is for negative number
if x is less than 0 then it will again
move to the nested if and it will check
for even and odd
so if it finds that the number is even
it will print negative and even
otherwise it will print negative and odd
and the last condition is for the number
zero
let's
try to find out the output of this and
what we'll do will update the value of x
as
it
so save it now here it says the positive
and even so 8 is a positive number and
even as well
let's update the value of x as minus
save it now it says negative and odd
number minus 5 is a negative odd number
right so that's how it will check for
positive
or negative and odd or even so we are
doing both the things simultaneously in
a program
we have an alternate method as well here
you can see on your screen we have
written a program and here we have taken
a variable x the functioning of both the
programs is same
both of these program will check for
positive or negative and
order even
so
here you can see i have taken a variable
x let's say the value of x is
it will check for
x greater than 0 and x
mod 2 is equals to equals to 0. so we
have 4 different conditions right a
number is
greater than 0 that means a number is
positive and
even a number is positive and odd a
number is negative and even a number is
negative and odd and the final one is a
number is zero
okay we have five conditions and we have
to specify these four conditions here so
here we you can see we are using the
logical and operator this means it will
print this statement let's suppose for
this statement it will print this only
if both the conditions are true
right if the number if the value x is
holding is both greater than 0 and an
even number
so if you try to
find out the output now save it and see
here it says number is positive and odd
so the number 7 is greater than 0
but the number 7 is not an even number
that's why this line is not there on the
browser it will print this line because
the number is
positive and odd
right
the switch case is another conditional
control statement and just like the if
else control statement there is a
difference between the usage of if else
and switch case statement
now both if else and switch case works
with conditions and we have to choose
when to use switch case
over if else
switch case is generally preferred over
the if else when there is n number of
test cases present or we can say when we
are working with a lot of conditions
let's say we are working on a program
and you ask the user
for an input between 50 and 100 a
numeric input basically
and in the output we have to print the
textual form of that number suppose if
the user enters 75 right the output will
be like this
so what we are doing we we are taking a
number from the user as an input and we
are printing the textual form of that
number right
so we can use the if else
or we can say elsif control statement
but the program will be so lengthy and
not so clean
also switch case is much more efficient
than if else when it comes to execution
time like if we have n number of
conditions then using switch case is a
better option
we'll get to know why in a bit
so let's move on to the programming part
and today
we'll write a program where we have to
find the month in a year by accepting
its number
so we have 12 months in a year for
example if we enter 4 then the output
will be april and if we enter 8 then the
output will be august because august is
the 8th month of the year right so i
hope you guys are clear with the
question of course we can do this
program with the help of if else
statement but we discussed earlier that
using if else in such cases is not
efficient right we can use switch case
in this scenario
so let's create a variable first let's
say we are creating a variable where
month and
you can give any value to this variable
from 1 to 12 you can provide it with any
initial value
so let's create a variable first let's
say we are creating a variable where
month
and
the value we are providing it one as the
hardcore initial value for simplicity
again we are not taking the input from
the user or from the browser to do so we
have to first
go through the dom manipulations and
we'll go through it in later videos so
let's start with the switch case now
the syntax for switch case is quite
simple just write down
switch and
pass the variable month
so we have to check in this round
bracket for the variable month because
you know any value you are providing to
month the switch will check the program
accordingly so for now we have taken the
value as 1 for month we can take any
value like we can take 3 we can take 11
12 or any value other than 1 to 12 as
well so whatever value you are providing
to the variable you can provide the
variable to the switch statement right
so
next up we have an open and curly braces
for the body of the switch case we have
to test for 12 different conditions
inside this
starting from 1 to 12 right so the
syntax goes like this you have to write
case
and then the value
month variable might hold like 1 2 3 and
so on followed by a colon right so we
have to write the value 1 and
a column not a semicolon but a colon
keep this thing in mind guys
and below that we are going to write
what we want when the value is one like
what the output we want when the value
is one so we have to write
document
dot right
and
whatever you want as the output like for
one the first month is january so we are
writing here
january
and a semicolon
so if the value of the month is 1 you
will get the output as january save it
and here you can see the output is
january
let me increase the font size for this
as well
so here you can see the output is
january right next we'll use a break
statement
if you guys remember we discussed the
break statement in the control
statements video right the break
statement is not actually a type of
control statement but it assists other
control statements or we can say it
helps us manage the control statements
right what this statement does is
once we are done with our output we get
our output right once we are done with
case 1 we get our output as january this
break statement helps us to come out of
the switch case so to understand this
much better let's write here one more
case
so let's say we are writing here one
more case as
case two
and the output will be
document
dot write
the second month is february right
and
february i can write
so
we'll include one break here like will
come in the first case and include a
break statement so here's how you can
write a break statement how you can
include a break statement in your code
so let's check the output now
so for now it says january
so if we don't include this break
statement here when the interpreter will
execute this code
and it will see that the case is one
right so it will print january
but
it will print other statements as well
so for example if we remove this break
statement and save it now see you can
see here the output as january and
february january and february both are
getting printed on the output so we need
a break statement to break it here
see the value is 1 and if we include
break statement here
the moment the interpreter finds the
answer the correct answer as january it
will come out of the switch case
so i hope you guys are getting this
similarly will write all the cases for
all the months let me show you all the
cases
so here you can see on your screen that
we have 12 different cases from 1 to 12
one for each month depending on the
value the variable month is holding
right
the output will be june if the value is
6 and if we say 10 the output will be
october and so on and so forth
now
the question here is what if we try to
write a random value for the variable
month
by random value we mean that
if we try to write any value other than
these 12 values from 1 to 12 if
if we leave these values then if we try
to write another value like if we write
here 13
so what will be the output now let's
save it and see
there's no output and there might be no
error for this as well so if you try to
check for an error go to inspect and
check out
see there's no error right so in that
case we have one more case like we have
default case
so let me show you how to include
default in your program what you have to
do is write here
default
with a colon and write
document
dot right and
let's suppose we are writing here
wrong input
what is happening is let's try to run
this program first
press ctrl s and now you can see it says
raw input for value 13.
so what is happening is the switch case
will first check these 12 cases and any
value other than 1 to 12 will get the
output as wrong input it works the same
as the else statement right
in else statement we don't need to
specify any particular condition any
condition other than the if condition or
else if condition will fall inside the
else statement it's not necessary to add
default in your program it's just if you
want to give the user a prompt that he
has entered a wrong value
so
you must include this default case in
your program every time while using
switches because it's quite useful you
know
okay so this is the complete program to
find out
the month by accepting its number
if you try
and save it now it will say june if we
try 10 save it it will say october if we
try 12 save it it will say december so i
hope this is clear to you guys
next up let's discuss about switch case
in detail because the switch case in
javascript works differently from other
languages like switch case is also
present in c plus plus and java but in
javascript it is a bit different so in
javascript
switch case can accept numbers it can
accept strings and boolean values as
well
now let's have a look at how the switch
case works with string values
so here is an example of string values
you can see the value variable month is
holding is june right and you can use
this string in case as well so here you
have to
give the case as a string value right
because we are using switch case
statement with
strings
so the first case here is when the value
will be june the output should be sixth
month
and when the value is july the output
will be seventh month so let's check it
out if this is working or not let's save
this program and see for june it says
sixth month and similarly we can check
it for july as well let's check for july
save it and see it says seventh month
you can include the default case as well
if you want to
it will be similar like there is no
difference for default case let me show
you how
we'll write here wrong input
and save it and now let's try to change
the value here let's say we are using
may
save it and see it says wrong input but
if we use a numerical value here let's
try to use 2 save it now it says wrong
input for 2 as well it will give you the
output when the value is either june or
july
so any other value you try to use here
it will give the output as wrong input
in the same way it works for boolean
values as well let me show you how it
works for boolean values
so what you have to do instead of 2 you
have to give here a boolean value let's
suppose you are writing here true
and for true you have to change the case
as well for true
you have to change the output as
let's say for true it the output will be
one
okay and similarly for false
the output should be
zero
and the output should be wrong input for
any other case right so save it now and
see here for true it says one the output
you can see here is one
and if you try to do the same for false
like let's write here false
and now try to check the output see here
it says
zero
you can see the output is correct right
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know
we more discuss
our first iterative control statement
that is the for loop in javascript
so iterative statements or looping
statements we can say are used when we
want to perform an activity multiple
times or n number of times so we don't
have to copy paste that code every time
but we can use iterative statements
using iterative statements will make our
code clean and definitely more efficient
so we have four different types of
iterative control statements right we
discussed it in the previous video let's
move on to for loop which is a first
iterative control statement and we'll
move on to the programming part directly
so before we start one thing to keep in
mind guys is that
we use for loop when we are clear with
the number of iterations in advance
so let's start with our first program in
this program we will print the
multiplication table of 10
from 10 into 1 to 10 into 10.
let's start with coding
first we write the for keyword and then
we have
three different parts we have the
initialization
which is separated by a semicolon next
up we have the condition
and finally
we have the increment or decrement
so this is the syntax for for loop
next up we have the open and the closed
curly braces for the body of for loop
we'll change these three values
as these are not the actual values right
or parameters for these three different
parts of the loop are going to be
different so let me comment this one
so we'll what we'll do we'll leave it
here only we'll change it from here so
in the initialization part what we are
going to do is we will create a variable
let's say we are creating a variable
where a and the value of and the initial
value of a will be 1.
this initialization happens only one
time when the for loop begins we have to
be careful about the condition we are
going to use
because sometimes what happens is the
loop runs forever because of a wrong
condition which will ultimately crash
our program
so in the condition what we have to do
is we have to give a value as in for how
long a for loop should execute here in
this case
we want to print the table of 10 right
we want to have 10 iteration
so what it will do it will start from a
equals to 1 and it will go till this
final condition so let's suppose we are
writing here a less than equals to 10
it will start from
a equals to 1 and it will go till a less
than or equals to 10 and next up we will
use the increment operator we want to
increment the value of a by 1 every time
right so we'll use increment operator a
plus plus or we can say a equals to a
plus 1 both are the same things right so
here the condition will be like this for
variable a equals to 1 a less than
equals to 10 and a plus plus
so here you can see the loop will
execute from a equals to 1 till a equals
to 10 and the value will be increased by
1 every time
because we have used the increment
operator right next up the body of for
loop will go like so what we want to
print here we want to print the
table of 10 right so we'll use document
dot write and inside document
document.write we'll use the h1 tag
so what we want to do is we want to
print the table of 10 right so we'll
multiply 10 by a
for every iteration the value of a will
be multiplied by 10 and then it will be
printed on the browser
so we'll close the h1 tag here
in the semicolon
so here you can see we have printed 10
into a let's save it and check the
output first and then we'll look at the
execution flow of this program
see here the multiplication table of 10
is printed on the browser you can see 10
20 30 40 so on and so forth till 100
so what is happening is firstly the for
loop is also known as the entry control
loop it means
that the condition is checked initially
the first time the for loop runs
we perform initialization only once so
here the value stored at variable a is 1
initially the value is 1 next up it will
check for a less than equals to 10 is a
which is 1 is 1 less than equals to 10
then true the control will be shifted to
document.write and it will print
10 into the value of a is 1 right so it
will print 10 here
next thing it will go for the increment
and the value of a will be changed to 2
from 1 1 plus 1 or we can say 1 equals
to 1 plus 1 right so it will be 2 now
next thing it will leave this now
because the initialization happens only
once now it will go for the condition
directly now it will check for is 2 less
than or equals to 10 if yes then again
the control will be shifted here and it
will print 10 into 2 because the value
of a is 2 now and after that it it will
print 20 here and after that
the value of a will be increased to 3
because we have used a plus plus then it
will check for 3 is 3 less than 10 and
same thing will happen it will print 30
and so on and so forth till the value of
a is 10 now if the value of a is 10 it
will print 100 right and when the value
is incremented it will become 11
so what will happen now it will check
for 11 less than equals to 10
no we know that 11 is not less than
equal to 10 right then it comes out of
the loop and it will print nothing after
that so this is the basic working of the
for loop we'll go through one more
program wherein we'll print the odd
numbers
between 1 and 10.
so what are odd numbers odd numbers are
those numbers which are not divisible by
2 right so we have the odd numbers as 1
3 5 7 9 and we want to print them so the
difference between each number is of 2
the 1 plus 2 plus 2 plus 2 till 9 right
so what we have to do is we have to
write here a
plus equals to 2 we have to increase the
value of a by 2
and instead of writing here 10 into a
because this time we don't want to
print any multiplication table we want
to print a number only right so we'll
use a only
save it and check the output it says one
three five seven nine so these are the
odd numbers present between one and ten
keep one thing in mind that you have to
give the condition wisely every time
so next up we have the while loop like
the for loop while loop is also an entry
control loop which means that the
condition will be checked first so the
question here is how while loop is
different from the for loop if you guys
remember when we discussed that we must
know the exact number of iterations then
only we can use the for loop right so
the while loop is preferred when we are
not aware of the number of iterations or
we can say we don't know if the
condition will be true for a certain
number of times
we'll start with the programming part
now
and then we will discuss more about when
to use while loop over for loop
so let's start with the program in this
particular program we will print odd
numbers up to a specific number
let's say we want to print all the odd
numbers up to 50.
so we want to print all the odd numbers
from 1 till 50 right we came across the
same program in the previous video as
well but this time we will use the while
loop instead of for loop
so the syntax for the while loop is
relatively easy to use
the code goes like we start with the
while keyword
then
opening and closing round brackets and
finally the body of while loop in curly
braces
if you guys remember from the previous
video wherein we used the for loop we
had three different parts right we had
the initialization we had conditions and
the increment decrement part here we
have only one condition and until this
condition holds true the while loop will
be executed for example here we want to
print all the odd numbers from 1 to 50
right so we'll first initialize a
variable
let's initialize a variable first let's
say we have a variable x and the value
of x will be
1. we used here one because
one is the very first odd number right
after that inside the condition what we
want to do is we want to print the odd
numbers
up to 50.
so while the condition will be like
while
x
less than equals to 50
so the loop will go till x is less than
or equals to 50
or we can say x less than 15. that
depends on us if we want to check for 50
or not so the odd numbers will go like
1 and then we have 3 then we have 5 then
we have 7 and up to
50. so the last odd number will be 49
so inside the while loop we will print
the value of x so here we will print the
value of x let's print it
document
dot right
and inside this we will print the value
of x inside the h1 tag
suppose we try to run this program now
it will go on an infinite loop and the
reason for this is we are not doing
anything to increment the value of x
just like in for loop if you remember we
had the initialization first we had the
initialization here as well
then we had the condition we have a
condition here as well and then finally
it has an increment or decrement part
right so here we don't have that same
increment or decrement part we have to
do it separately so we'll increment the
value of x here only so here we will
write x
plus equals to 2 or we can say it is
same as
x equals to x plus 2 you guys are aware
of it right so
the reason is simple because we want to
go from 1 to 3 to 5 and so on that's why
we use x plus equals to 2. we
incremented the value of x by 2.
save it here and let's check the output
so here you can see it says 1 3 5 7 9
and
so on and so forth till 49 so 49 is the
last odd number before 50 because we are
checking between 1 and 50 right so 49 is
the last
odd number
let me show you how the program goes
into an infinite loop
so for that what we have to do we will
comment this whole line here let's check
the output now save it and here you can
see
it is refreshing forever and this is
basically how a program in an infinite
loop looks like
the output of this program is the
program will ultimately crash so what we
have to do we have to open a new tab and
then again we have to run the program
with correct increment part so here you
can see you can wait for it to become
responsive or exit the page so here you
can see we have all the odd numbers from
up to 50 and the last one is 49
coming back to the difference between
the while loop and the for loop we did
the same program previously right using
the for loop so where to use
while loop
over for loop so consider a scenario
where we are taking input from the user
and the input from the user is why we
want to do something let's say we want
to print something on the screen or if
the input from the user is n we want the
process to be stopped we can give the
condition in the while loop which will
go like when the character y becomes n
the process will be stopped we'll go
through one such program once we are
done with the dom manipulation part
wherein we take the input from the user
let's move on to the do while loop in
javascript
in the previous videos we have already
discussed that both for loop and the
while loop are entry control loop that
means the conditions are checked first
right but the do-while loop is a bit
different or we can say it is an exit
control loop wherein the condition is
checked after the execution of the
loop's body thus an exit control loop
executes at least once even if the test
condition fails or we can say the
condition is wrong
the loop will execute once
using the do while loop is relatively
easy it seems like we are giving the
system a command to do something while
the condition is something
so let's start with the syntax now
the syntax goes like this we write the
keyword do and we have a pair of curly
braces for the body of the loop and
after that we have the while keyword and
here we will write the condition
make sure you are using the semicolon
after the while loop it's necessary
while using do while loop keep this
thing in mind
so we have two parts in the do-while
loop the do part and the while part or
we can say the condition part while part
is the part where we write the condition
so let's define a variable first let's
say we are using a variable we are using
a variable x and the value of x will be
5.
so here we have taken 5 as a random
value you can take 1 as well now inside
the condition part of the do while loop
this is the condition part where we are
using the while keyword so we'll give a
condition let's say we are using while x
greater than 5 it will check for the
condition that if the value of x is
greater than 5
or if the value of x is smaller than or
equal to 5 it will come out of the loop
in the do part we will write what we
want to do let's say we want to print a
single sentence here
we write document.write
and whatever sentence we want to write
let's say we are using
welcome to
simply code so here you might be
thinking that the condition is false but
the condition will be checked after the
first iteration in the do while loop so
no matter what the condition is the
first iteration will happen always
so if we try to save this program and
let's try to run this here you can see
the output is welcome to simply code a
single line is printed
what is happening here is although the
condition we used was wrong but the
condition will be checked only after the
first iteration when the do-while loop
will perform this
particular statement when the
document.write will be performed after
that it will check for the condition if
x is greater than 5 or not
if we use here 6 instead of 5
let's try to write here 6 instead of 5
and if we run this program now it will
go into an infinite loop because we are
not performing the increment decrement
operator here right
as we have discussed in the previous
videos the importance of increment
decrement part
so we need to do it here after the
document.write part so what we'll do
here we'll write x minus minus today we
are using x minus minus and for the
other two loops we use the plus
increment operator right so the x minus
minus is the same as x equals to x minus
1 let's check the output now
save it here you can see the output is
still welcome to simply code the
execution flow of this program will be
like it will first perform the iteration
before checking the condition
and it will print here welcome to simply
code for the first time when the loop
will start executing it will first
perform this statement and it will write
here welcome to simply code
so then it will perform x minus minus
means the value of x is now 5 because we
are decrementing the value by 1 so when
the value of x is 5 then it will check
for the condition if x is greater than 5
or not so here we can see clearly x is
not greater than 5 because x equals to 5
and it is equals to 5 right so it will
come out of the loop
let's make few changes in the code here
suppose
we use here 10 instead of 6 now
and let's print the value of x as well
it will be easy for you to understand so
we'll print here x
and we'll use a
space
so that it will be clear for you
we'll use here the brtech and now let's
try to run this program here you can see
the output goes from 10 to 6 and it
prints welcome to simply code every time
right if you guys are wondering where we
use the do while loop sometimes it may
happen that even though the condition is
false but we have to execute that
command we use the do while loop when we
want the code to output some sort of
menu to the user or to generate the menu
at least once we'll get to know about
the do while loop in future videos when
we create a program specifically for the
do while loop this video is just a
syntax demonstration
we'll go through the examples
of all the three loops present in
javascript so today we have three
different problems
for three separate loops right we'll go
through each of the problems and we'll
discuss the execution flow for each loop
we'll go through
so let's start this session with the
first problem statement so the first
problem statement goes like this so here
we have to write a program to check
whether a number is prime or not i hope
you guys are aware of what prime numbers
are right so a prime number is a
positive number
that is only divisible by 1 and itself
for example
2 3 5 and we have 7 and 11 these are the
first few prime numbers right
if we take an example let's say we are
taking an example of 7 so 7 is a number
which is divisible by 1 and 7 only no
other number can divide 7 right so here
in this code we have to check whether up
number is prime or not so let me take
you through the code
so here is the code to check whether a
number is a prime number or not let me
take you through this first
so we have a variable number and the
value of variable number can be any
random value like any number you want to
check if the number is prime number or
not you can give that value to the
variable number
so here we have taken 83 next up we have
a variable is prime
whose value is a boolean value right it
can be true for a prime number or it can
be false for a prime number so we have
used comments in this program to make it
easier for you guys to understand so
here we have used the if statement to
check if the number is 1 because we know
that 1 is neither a prime number nor a
composite number right so we have to
check if the
user enters the value 1 or if we are
giving the value 1 we have to check for
it so if user enters the value 1 it will
print this statement that 1 is neither
prime nor composite
here in elsif we are checking if the
value of number is greater than 1 or not
so if the value of number is greater
than 1 the control will be shifted to
for loop present inside the else if
statement right here you can see we have
the for loop here the control will be
shifted to this for loop so here you can
see we have initialized the variable i
and the initial value is set to 2
that's because any prime number is
divisible by 1 as well right so it won't
make any sense to include 1 here
we'll start from 2 and we'll check until
the value of i becomes half of the value
of number so if we take an example of 10
we'll check until 5 because you know any
number greater than 5 won't divide 10
right it's practically not possible so
we'll check for number by 2 or we can
say we'll check till 5 only and the
value will be increased by 1 every time
till now i hope you guys are aware of
how to use for loop and why we are using
for loop here we can do the same program
using while loop as well but to make it
more clear how to use for loop we are
doing this program with the help of for
loop so then we have the i plus plus or
we can say we have increased the value
of i by 1 after every iteration until
the value of i becomes
half of the number
so the condition number percent i equals
2 equals to 0
so here is the main condition to check
if the number is divisible by
i or not
so the execution will be like if we are
taking here a number 10 it will start
from 2 and it will check if the
remainder is 0 or not so if the
remainder is 0
then the value of is prime will be
changed to false and it will come out of
the loop
next it will check for the value of s
prime if the value of s prime is true or
not here you can see if the value of is
prime is true then it will print
n or we can say then it will print that
the number is a prime number else it
will print that
the number is not a prime number if the
value of is prime is false for example
when we took the example of
number as 10 so the value of s prime
will be changed to false because you
know 10 divides by 2 is equals to 0
or we can say the remainder will be zero
so the value of s prime will be changed
to false and for false it will print
number is not a prime number
so at last we will check if the number
is less than one if the number entered
by the user or any other number we have
taken like if we take here minus 5
so it will print the number is not a
prime number
because by the usual definition of
prime numbers
any negative number
cannot be a prime number that's a usual
definition right so we have to keep this
thing in mind and here in this else loop
we'll
print that if any negative number is
entered we'll make sure that the program
gives the output that the number is not
a prime number
so let's try to run this program and
check the output let's save this program
and
the output says 83 is a prime number as
83 is not divisible by any number except
1 and 83 for example if we take here any
number which is divisible by so let's
say we are taking 75 save it now and see
it says 75 is not a prime number okay
here's a spelling mistake it says 75 is
a not prime number so here we will
correct this
is
so we are done with it and save it now
now it says 75 is not a prime number s75
is divisible by numbers other than one
end itself right it is divisible by 3 it
is divisible by 5 15 and 25 as well all
these numbers divide 75 basically so
let's take a different value here
let's say we are taking
minus 7
let's change the value here as or we can
take it as -75 let's save it now so it
says the number is not a prime number
or if we want to try for 1 as well let's
take it as 1
and let's check the output now so it
says 1 is neither prime nor composite
number because we have given here the
condition if number is equals to is
equals to 1 then it will print that 1 is
neither a prime nor a composite number
you can try this program with the help
of other loops as well
so let's move on to the second problem
statement but before that let me take
you through
the same program using the while loop so
here you can see we have used the while
loop for the same instead of for loop
here you can see we have used while i
less than a
number by 2 and we have given the
increment condition here and we have
initialized the value of i
at
the start of the program so if we try to
run this program it will give us the
same output there will be no change in
the output so we can use while loop as
well so we'll use the while loop in
other program
let's move on to the second problem
statement so in this example we'll learn
to write a program in javascript to
check whether a number is an armstrong
number or not
so we'll do this with the help of while
loop let's have a look at how to
implement this program
before proceeding to the coding part
let's have a look at what is an
armstrong number so an armstrong number
of three digits is an integer such that
the sum of the cubes of its digits is
equal to the number itself
so for example 153 is an armstrong
number since 1 into 1 into 1 it means
the cube of the digit 1
plus the cube of 5 that is 5 into 5 into
5 which is equal to 125 and
the cube of 3 which is 3 3's are 9 and 9
3's are 27 so it will go like
plus 27 plus
1 so which is equal to 153 so an
armstrong number of three digits is an
integer such that the sum of the cubes
of its digits is equal to the number
itself so here we have the code for the
same this is the code to check whether
the number is an armstrong number or not
so here we have taken a variable and the
value is 153 the value of the variable
number is 153 right because we already
know that 153 is an armstrong number
there are few more numbers like 3 7 1 is
also an armstrong number
next up we have taken a variable sum and
the initial value of sum is zero we have
used the variable sum to store the value
of the cubes
and next up we have a temporary variable
so that we can break a three digit
number and we need
the number after all this all this
program all these loops and all we'll
need the number will need the original
number to compare it with the sum of the
cubes which will be hold in sum so but
we need to break the number as well
right so we need a temporary variable to
break it
here we use the while loop and the loop
will run until the value of variable
temp is greater than 0 so the initial
value of temp will be 153 here in this
particular case the initial value will
be 1 5 3 and the loop will run until the
value of 1 5 3 is greater than 0.
next up we have a variable remainder
that stores the
last digits value as we are dividing 153
by 10.
so
the remainder here will be 3 so the
value saved at variable remainder will
be 3 for the first time then what will
happen with we are updating the value of
sum and the new value of sum will be
0 plus 3 into 3 into 3 so 3 3's are 9
and 9 3's are 27 so the
updated value of sum will be 27 next up
we are
removing the last digit from the number
so
for example we have here 153 and if we
divide 153 by 10
the answer will be 15.3
that's why we are using here percent
because what percent will do it will
convert the float value into an integer
so if we try to perform a simple divide
in javascript like if we try to divide
153 by 10 it will give us 1 5.3 it will
give us a float value but we want an
integer value right so pass it will
change this value to the nearest integer
so 1 5.3 the nearest integer will be 1 5
so the new value of temp will be 1 5
then again this loop will be executed
and
for this time the variable reminder will
hold the value of 15
modulus 10 and the remainder will be 5
right
so the new value of remainder is 5 and
the value of sum is 27 plus 5 into 5
into 5
which is 27 plus 125 right so the new
value of sum will be 152
and then again it will go to the temp
and it will divide 15 by 10 and it will
change the value to an integer so 1.5
will be changed to 1 and next up the
final value of temp is 1 which is
greater than 0 right so it will divide
10 by 1 and the remainder will be 1
so next up it will add 152 plus 1 into 1
into 1 that is 153 right and then it
will divide 1 by 10
using the power sent but this time the
value will be 0 because there is no
remainder right
next up we'll compare the value of the
sum and the number variable so the sum
variable here it is holding the value as
153. we break this number into three
different parts then we took the cube of
these three number and added them so the
final value of the variable sum is 153
and the initial value of number or we
can say the value we gave to the
variable number is 153 so right it will
print here that 153 is an armstrong
number
or if we use any other number instead of
153 let's suppose we are using 121 so it
will print 121 is not an armstrong
number let's
check out the output once let's save it
and see the output is 153 is an
armstrong number so if we change the
value of one five three to
one to one
so let's check the output now it says
one two one is not an armstrong number
why because if we take the cube of each
of the digit and we'll add them suppose
the answer here will be 10 because the
cube of 1 is 1 and the cube of 2 is 8
and the cube of the final one is 1 so 8
plus 1 plus 1 is equals to 10
so that's why 1 2 1 is not an arm strong
number
let's move on to our last problem
statement
where we'll use the do while loop to
find the factorial of a number
so here is the problem statement where
we will have to write a program to find
the factorial of a number
so factorial of an integer is the
product of an integer and all the
integers below it or we can say before
it till 1 so if we take an example of 5
so the factorial of 5 will be
it will multiply each number before it
if we take 5 the factorial will be
5 into 4
into 3 into 2 into 1
or if we don't include 1 that's totally
fine
so this program is pretty simple as
compared to the previous two we did
so this is a small one too let me take
you through this so here we have the
program
and here we have three variables right
we have a variable i which is
initialized as one then we have a
variable n which is five and then we
have a
variable f whose value is 1 f is for
factorial and n is for number we want to
check the factorial of and i is for
checking the condition
so here what we will do we'll use a loop
where
if we for example if we are taking 5
then the loop will go from 1 into 2 into
3 into 4 into 5 from 1 to that number
it's not
like if we are using from 5 towards 1
but we are going from 1 towards 5
the answer will be same right because we
are multiplying all the numbers in both
the cases
so here we took 5 as the number next up
we have a variable f and the value of f
is also 1 as you know
so here we are using the do while loop
for the first iteration it will perform
this so the value of f for the first
iteration will be f equals to f into i
which means f equals to 1 into 1 which
is 1 so the value of i will be increased
and it will become 2 and now it will
check for
while 2 is less than equals to n yes 2
is less than n so it will again go up
and it will update the value of f and
the new value of of f will be 1 into 2
that is 2 then again the value will be
increased and it will become 3
and then it will
change the value of
f as well if it will become 6 and the
value of i will become 4 then it will
check if 4 is less than 5 yes 4 is less
than 5
and then it will multiply 4 with 6
because the value of f was 6 right so 4
into 6 it will become 24 and then
finally the value of i will be 5 and it
will check if the value of i is less
than or equals to 5 right while i is
less than equals to 5 yes that's true
because now 5 is equals to 5 and it will
again execute the loop and the value of
f will be 24 into 5 which is 120 and
then again the value of i will be
increased now it will become 6 which is
greater than 5 so it will come out of
the loop and it will print the factorial
of the number so let's save this program
so the factorial of 5 is 120
because see here we have used the
factorial of
n n is 5
and the factorial is 120 so if we
try to give any other number here other
than 5 let's say we are using here 10
save it
it says the factorial is
three six two double eight double zero
so it's 36 lakh twenty eight thousand
eight hundred so if you try to multiply
ten into nine into eight into seven so
on till
two or we can say one the answer will be
this you can check it you can google it
or you can go through it in your
calculator
the typical definition of function
states that to work in a proper or in a
particular way
similarly functions in javascript are a
block of code that is used to perform a
specific task
in this particular video we will go
through the syntax and usage of
functions
so a function has a particular name and
we can reuse that block of code again
and again in our entire program
for example
let's suppose that we have to add two
numbers in a program that's a basic
program right sum of two numbers
so let's write the code first so we are
going to take a variable x and the value
of x will be 10
then again we are going to take a
variable y and the value of y will be 5.
lastly we are going to take a variable
total and the value of total will be
x plus y
so
the last thing
we are going to do is we are going to
print this on a browser
so here we are we are done with our
program we are done with adding two
numbers so let's save it and check the
output see the output here says 15
so what is happening is
the value of x plus y which is 10 plus 5
is stored in the variable total and we
are displaying total on a browser
so that's a very basic program right
now consider a scenario where we have to
do this addition for n number of times
at different intervals so we have to
perform the same task of addition at
different intervals so in that case what
we can do is we can copy paste this same
code repeatedly but the length of the
program will increase because of that
right and it doesn't make any sense to
copy paste the same code again and again
so this is where functions come into
play with the help of functions we can
create a separate function to do this
particular task and we can call that
function again and again i'll take you
through it so basically a function has
three parts we'll go through each of
them a function has function declaration
then it has function definition and then
finally it has function calling
so we'll perform this same program of
adding two numbers we'll add two numbers
but this time we'll use the concept of
functions
so we'll use this whole code
we are going to use it inside the
function
so let's move on and see how the
function looks like how the syntax of
function looks like
so we use the keyword function
and then we have the function name
so let's suppose here we are naming the
function as sum
then we have the opening and closing
round brackets
which denotes that this is a function
this is the way to write a function next
up we have a pair of curly braces for
the body of the function so this is the
basic syntax of how a function looks
like
the naming convention for functions is
the same as we had for variables in
javascript if you guys remember we have
already discussed this naming convention
of variables
so this is the basic structure of a
function
so now we'll cut this whole code
and we'll
paste it here inside the function
right so we are done with it we are done
with our functions first part first we
declared a function with name sum then
we are done with the definition of
function
now what if we try to run this program
let's save this program and see it is
not printing anything on screen but if
you try to check out for any errors it
won't show any errors see there is no
error in this program this is happening
because we haven't called the function
yet right so to call the function we
have to write a single word just write
sum
with
opening and closing
round brackets and save it now now you
can see the output here is 15 so this is
known as function calling the program
already knows that there is a function
by the name sum
it will go and check for the same if the
function is there or not if the program
finds it it will execute the function
next up a function can also have
parameters what do i mean by parameters
is we don't have to declare these
variables variable x and variable y here
instead of declaring them here we can
pass these values to the function let's
say we are passing x and y here or we
can pass a and b any variable you want
to pass
you can pass it here
now we can remove this
variable x and variable y
we have to write here where because we
still need the variable total and next
up we have to pass the value for these
variables when we call the function so
we have to pass the values here let's
say we are passing the values as
and
so
let's try to run this program now and
see if it works let's save it and see
you can see here the output as 7
we can also pass strings over here so
instead of 4 if we try to pass any
string let's say we are passing
welcome 2
and instead of 3
we'll pass
simply code right now let's save this
program and see the output it says
welcome to simply code we don't have to
worry about the data type we'll use here
because javascript is a loosely typed
language right so the function will
automatically adapt to the data type
according to the value we will pass
during the function call
here in this code
variable x holds the value welcome to
and the variable y is having simply code
allocated to them dynamically so this is
what is known as
parameter passing in functions
let's move on and discuss the return
types in functions so a function can
also return a value right now
we can see that a function is doing the
printing task what if we remove this
document dot right from here and we'll
paste it somewhere else on the program
outside the function so we'll paste it
here right now the function will perform
addition only it won't print anything it
will just perform the addition let's
save this and see there's nothing so if
we try to check for error it says total
is not defined because total is defined
inside the function this is because of
the concept of local and global variable
we will discuss this concept in upcoming
video
so
here you can see it says total is not
defined right so now what we have to do
is we have to write here
return
total
so now the function will return the
value of total outside
what this return statement does is
whenever we call the function as you can
see here we are calling the function
from outside and we are passing the
parameters as welcome to and simply code
right
so these parameters will go as x and y
and we are getting the concatenation of
welcome to simply code
right so when this return statement
comes into function
the value of this total variable will be
given out of the function
so there has to be a particular variable
to hold the value returned by the
function
we'll
use a variable here let's say we are
using the variable output
and in the rhs we are calling the
function so we have an equals to between
the lhs and rhs that's because when we
are calling the function it will return
a value and the assignment is done from
right to left in the case of an
assignment operator if you guys remember
we came across this
that whenever we are using an assignment
operator the assignment will be done
from right towards the left
so whatever value the function will
return upon calling will be assigned to
the variable output
in this program we are passing welcome
to and simply code right so let's change
these two values now we'll change them
to a numerical value let's say we are
using here
and instead of simply code we'll use a
15 and we are going to print here output
on the browser because the variable
output is holding the value returned by
the function right so let's save it now
and see the output is 50
okay guys so this was the syntax
demonstration of functions in javascript
with a quick small program of course
the javascript is a loosely typed
scripting language right that means we
don't need to specify the data types
every time
so a variable is basically a container
that can store data values those values
can be changed whenever needed in this
particular video we are going to discuss
the scope of variables in javascript so
what does this scope mean in variables
so scope refers to the life of a
variable in a program
there are basically two types of
variables present in javascript local
variables and global variables
depending upon where we are creating a
variable variable may have two different
types of scope so let's have a look at
these two different types of variables
with the help of examples
let's say we are creating a variable
here let's say we are creating a
variable where a and the value of a will
be 5 so we have created a variable here
and let's print the value of this
variable in the browser so what we'll do
we'll print this value in the browser
so let's print the value of this
variable on the browser so here we have
printed the value of variable a
so here you can see the value is 5.
so we can print the value of this
variable anytime and anywhere in our
program right so if we try to copy this
line from here and we'll paste it
somewhere else in a program let's say we
are pasting it here so if we try to save
it now see here you can see that we have
two values of a because we have printed
a twice here right once we have used
this a here then we have used this a
here so here you can see we have two
values of a five and five so this
variable a is a global variable which
means
its life is available throughout the
entire program or the entire script we
can say
and when we declare a variable inside a
function that variable is known as a
local variable for that function so
let's try to do it as well we already
know what functions are as we saw in the
previous video right so what we'll do
we'll
make a function here let's say we are
creating a function
function
my function
opening and closing round bracket and
the body of the function right so let's
declare a variable here let's say we are
using a variable where x and the value
of x will be 10 right let's try to print
this value
so we have created a function here now
we are left with the function call only
so let's call the function here
but we'll do we'll call my function
right
save it and now here you can see the
output is 10 5 and 5. so if we comment
these three lines if we remove these
three lines and we'll save it now so
here you can see we have the output as
10 only so this variable x which is
declared inside a function so why it is
a local variable because if we try to
access this variable from outside the
function it is not possible so let's
cut this line from here and let's try to
paste it here so now what we are doing
is we are trying to access this variable
from outside the function let's save it
now
let's save this program now and see the
there is no output in the browser
because a local variable can be accessed
only in that function we can't access it
from outside of the function
so this is happening because as soon as
the function is executed the variable
gets destroyed means there is no
variable present in the memory now
the same thing applies to the memory
whenever we run a javascript program the
whole browser is present in the ram
or we can say in the memory so these
local variables are created only till
the function is executing once the
function is done running the same
function wipes out of the memory
whereas the case is different for global
variables so global variables are
available throughout the script they
have a global lifetime which means that
they will exist throughout the program's
running
or we can say until the tab is open
the next exciting thing about global
variables is
that we can access global variables from
inside the function so what we'll do
let's
cut this line from here
and we'll paste it
here
so now what we'll do we'll declare a
variable here let's say we are declaring
a variable where y and the value of y
will be
so
copy this line
and paste it again now what we will do
we will try to access y from inside the
function
so let's save the program and see the
output here is 10 and 15. 10 is the
value of x and x is a local variable for
function my function because we have
declared x inside the function whereas
variable y is a global variable we have
declared it outside the function and we
tried to access it from inside of the
function right so we tried to access y
here and we can see the value of y is 15
which is printed on the browser this is
what global variables are one more
exciting thing i want to mention at the
end of this video is if we declare any
variable in javascript without using the
where keyword so if we try to declare a
variable here let's say we are declaring
var1 okay we have not used any var
keyword so what we are doing is we are
declaring a variable and the value of
where one is 15. so we don't need the
where keyword separately when we are
declaring a variable however some of the
newer versions of web browser have some
sort of issue if we try to declare a
variable inside this function without
using the where keyword
so let's try to access this variable
let's try to access let's declare it
inside the function
okay what we'll do is we'll
declare this variable inside the
function
and we'll comment this line and what
we'll do is we'll try to access it from
outside the function right
what we'll do is
we'll write here var1
save this
and see if
you don't understand it let me change
the value of where1 let's change this
value to 20 save it now and see the
output here is 10 and 20. so where1 is a
variable which is declared without using
the where keyword right so we can access
this variable from outside the function
as well any variable which is declared
without using where keyword is a global
variable keep this thing in mind guys
we came across the different types of
data types present in javascript
in the previous video where we came
across the types of primitive data types
in javascript we discussed number string
and we had boolean null and undefined
right so these are the five types of
primitive data types present in
javascript
we know that strings in any programming
language are used to store and
manipulate textual value a string
contains a sequence of characters
written inside double quotes
so let's declare a basic string here
let's say we have a variable
and we have a variable as where x and
the value of x will be a basic string
let's say we have hi there as the value
okay
next thing we'll print this on a browser
document.write and we'll print x on a
browser
so this here is a string that holds a
textual value right suppose we try to
find the type of the variable x so
i hope you guys are aware of that if
you're not then please go through the
previous video on data types in
javascript let's print this value on
browser first
so here you can see it says hi there so
this is a string and let's try to
determine the type of variable x and
we'll see if it returns a string or
something else we'll do it with the help
of type of operator right i hope you
guys remember that so let's try to use
type of operator here
and
here we'll use
type of x
so let's
save it
and see
here you can see we have a string as the
type of variable x so strings are
helpful
for holding data that can be represented
in textual form so let's move on to a
first topic for today and
that is escape sequence in javascript so
if you guys ever noticed that in the
previous few videos we use a lot of html
tags in javascript right for example we
use the heading tag so often
like when we are using the
document.write to print anything on the
browser we use heading tag quite a lot
right so the thing to notice here is
that these tags behaves as html tags
right we use them inside the double
inverted commas just like strings but
they still act like html tags so let's
understand this with the help of an
example
what we'll do is we'll remove this code
will print a simple
statement in a browser so we'll use
document.write
and we'll write here hi there
and we'll use a
tag
right so a basic html tag we are going
to use
let's say we are using the break tag i
hope you all are aware of the break tag
so the next sentence will be
so here in this example we try to print
a sentence and we are using the br tag
right so let's print it on the browser
so we are using the break tag in between
the sentences we have hi there and we
have welcome to simply code
so
we use this break tag
in a string right so the output
what we were expecting was hi there and
the br should be written in
string but there's a difference in the
output right the br tag is actually
functioning as an html tag
so here the break tag works the same as
it did for html so with this we can
conclude that if we try to infuse any
html tag inside the javascript statement
it will act as that tag only
so let's move on and we'll look at some
other types of escape characters present
in
javascript so
let's say we want to print this line
okay we'll
edit this one only so what we will do is
we will remove this break tag and
suppose we want to print this on screen
so we want this on our screen and we
want the welcome to be inside the double
inverted comma in output as well
so if we try to run this program now
there will be nothing
in the browser let's try to check if
it gets any error so here it says uncut
syntax error it says missing
after the argument list
so how to print this on the browser we
want to highlight the word welcome so if
we try to run this program as it is it's
not working right
to do this type of task we have the
backslash escape character
to print the double quotes inside a
string we use a single backslash with a
double inverted comma in the syntax is
we have to use this backslash before the
double inverted comma so now if we try
to print this on browser here you can
see it says hi there and welcome is
written within double inverted commas
right
so that's how you can print this on a
screen next up if we want to use a
single inverted comma we have to use a
single backslash with a single inverted
comma so just like we did here with the
double inverted comma similarly we can
do it for single inverted comma as well
what we'll do is we'll copy this
document dot right and we'll print it
here
so here what we will print is will print
here it's all right okay
so we are using here a backslash with a
single inverted comma now we'll write s
the output will be it's all right so
we have to use them because
we need them in a program at times right
so to avoid any confusion one must know
how to use this sequence character in
javascript let's save this and see
if we try to comment this line
let me commend this to make it more
easier for you to understand let's save
it now and see it says it's all right
you can't print it's in similar way
without using the backslash escape
character
lastly if we want to put a backslash in
our string if we want to put a backslash
we want to show it in the browser so the
syntax for that will go like
we have the document.right right so here
we will write
the character
and we'll use two backslashes
is called
backslash
so let's try to print this
so here one thing you can notice
only a single backslash is printed on
the browser the first one is used as a
backslash escape character and the
second one which we have used will be
printed on the browser
we have a few more escape sequence
present in javascript like the backslash
and or we can say newline
we don't use them quite often i'll let
you know if we use them in future so for
now it's enough for escape sequences
present in javascript
so if you guys remember we discussed
data type in previous videos right so
data types in javascript are of two
kinds we discussed the primitive data
types and the other type is
non-primitive or we can say complex or
composite data types right so an array
comes under the category of composite
data types or non-primitive we can say
so
the basic definition of array states
that an array is a collection of
elements stored in contiguous memory
locations so array is a list of similar
type of elements or in javascript array
acts a bit different from other
programming languages we can discuss it
later so let's understand the concept of
errors with the help of an example we'll
move to the programming part directly
let's consider a scenario
where we have a collection of similar
types of variables suppose we have a
list of cars
let's create a small list here for a few
different car companies let's say we
have a variable where carbon
and the value of carbon will be
let's say
honda
okay and then we have another variable
let's say car 2 and the value of car 2
will be kia
and finally we have a variable let's say
where
car 3
and the value of car 3 will be let's say
ford so here we have taken three
different car manufacturers we have
honda we have kia and we have four and
we have three different variables right
so if we want to print all three of them
what we have to do is we have to use the
document.write method right so we have
to use the document.write again and
again
so we can do it for this small piece of
code right let's print the value of all
three variables here let's say we are
using document
dot write and we will print the value of
all three variables
so here we have printed the value of all
three variables right we have carbon the
value was honda we have honda here we
have kia and we have ford as well
so this task is a bit simple for this
small piece of code right now imagine if
we have 100 values here instead of just
three values or maybe we can say we have
thousand values in a list we can't
follow the same procedure in that case
right
that's where arrays come into play what
we can do is we can use a single
variable and we can store as many values
as we want inside a single variable by
doing this we don't have to access each
and every variable separately while
printing them the data types of those
values present inside the array does not
matter at all so we can save either
numbers or strings or a value with any
data type we'll discuss it in a moment
let's try to define an array here first
so the syntax for array goes like this
we have to take a variable let's say
we'll declare an array here
let's say we are taking a variable where
car
and these opening and closing square
brackets represent the array it means
that it is an array if we are using them
in a variable inside this we can use
double quotes with the value we want to
insert it will go like this let's
suppose we have three values here right
we'll use these three values only we'll
use honda kia and food so to insert
these three values we have to follow
this syntax
so let's say we have the first
manufacturer as honda the next one we
have is
kia
and the last one we have is
four right so we have all the three
values here present inside a single
variable so we have a single variable
where car and we have all the three
values we have honda we have kia and we
have four
so
we can insert as many values as we want
like if we have a list of hundred car
manufacturers we can insert them in this
array now let's print the output of this
array so the output will go like we will
copy document dot right from here
paste it here
and the output will go like this
so we don't need this piece of code
right now so we'll commend this
so that we can understand the difference
between these two codes
and now let's save this program
and see here you can see we have all the
three elements of the array we have
honda we have kia and we have ford as
well
so an array is a non-primitive data type
or composite data type
with one single name and can hold
multiple values here the array name is
car and it stores three similar values
right here we have three string values
we have honda kia and food so this array
can store
any number of values we want to store in
that array
so what if we want to print a single
value from these three values we have we
have honda here and four right so if we
want to print kia let's suppose so it's
easy to print this on a browser all we
need to know is the index number of that
value
so the index number in the case of
arrays starts from zero and
goes further
so we have three values here
as we can see so the index value
for these variables will be so for honda
the index value will be
0 and for kia the index value will be 1
and for 4 the index value will be 2.
so the index value starts from 0 and
goes on further so one thing to keep in
mind guys whatever number of values an
array is holding the last index value
will always be one less than the number
of values so as here you can see we have
three values right so the index number
of the last value will be one less than
three
it means the index number will be two
because the index number starts from
zero
let's try to access the element present
at index index1
so we have kia here right all we have to
do is we have to put square brackets
here in the document.right here we have
to put square brackets
and we have to write the index value
inside of these square brackets so if we
write here 1 and if we save this program
now so here you can see we have kia only
it will print
the element present at index number 1.
so here in this particular case it is
kia
we can also loop through this area using
the index values let's say we want to
print each element on a separate line
every time right so we can use the loop
here i hope you guys are aware of the
for loop by now we'll write here so
we'll
we have declared an array so we will use
the for loop here and we will print here
for will take a variable i
and the value of i will be initial value
will be 0
and then we'll give the condition the
condition will be i less than 3 because
we know there are three values only and
it will go till 2 only because it's
going for the index value and the final
condition will be i
plus plus
so here we'll
use the curly braces
because this is the syntax for
for loop and the i value will iterate
through the array and print all the
values present at indexes till the index
2.
so the same thing goes for 100 elements
as well we can use the for loop to
access all the 100 elements in separate
lines
so guys if we save this and here you can
see okay
it is printing kia kia and kia because
we have
particularly mentioned here cars
present at index one so we have to
remove one here and we'll save it now
so the document.write syntax will be
changed a bit we will write here i
and
if we save it now so we have all the
three values here you can see guys the i
value here will iterate through the
array and print all the values present
at indexes till the index 2. so the same
thing goes for 100 elements as well we
can use the for loop to access all the
100 elements present in the array
we can use the same iteration concept
for doing so
so guys there's another way to represent
an array in javascript it goes like this
we have a let's say we have a variable
this time we'll take the variable as
well fruits
so the syntax will be like new we have
to use the new keyword and then we will
use
new array
and we have to give a space here and the
elements we want to store inside the
area so we'll use a apple then we have
let's say
banana and finally we have let's say
mango
okay
and we can access the elements of these
array with the help of a for loop we can
use the similar for loop here so if we
copy this for loop from here
and we'll paste it here
instead of cars
we'll use
a fruits
right and we'll give the value as i
because we want to
iterate the variable i through each
index so we have once again the index
value as 0 for apple one for banana and
two for mango let's comment this program
as well so that it will be easy for you
guys to understand
let's save this program now
and see we have the list of all the
elements present at array fruits so we
have apple we have banana and we have
mango printed on our browser
so this way of array representation or
declaration is less recommended because
the other way which we discussed earlier
like when we discuss the car
manufacturers
so that way is a bit easier to use so
i'll recommend that way only because
this way is a bit tricky as well
so let's move on to our next topic of
discussion so if you know guys errors in
javascript work differently when
compared to other programming languages
like java and c
so errors in javascript have dynamic
nature which means we can add or remove
elements from an array at runtime
just like we saw the string methods in
the previous video for arrays also we
have a few methods like if we want to
add elements into an array or if we want
to delete an element from an array we
have the push and pop methods available
to do such tasks
to add an element into an array we use
the push method and the syntax for
pushing elements into an array goes like
so we'll
remove this piece of code
and we'll use the first one only the car
manufacturer
so if we want to push
something inside the array right
we'll write here the variable name dot
we use the push method and we'll push
whatever value we want to push let's say
we are adding another car manufacturer
let's say we are adding nissan
we have to change the value here as well
because what will happen we have used
the condition i less than 3 so it will
check for indexes till index 2 only it
won't check for index 3 so if we write
here i less than 4 it will check for
nissan now let's save this and see a new
value is pushed into the array which is
nissan
so let's move on and discuss the pop
method so the pop method in array
removes the last present element from
the array if we use this pop method here
it will remove nissan in this case so
now you can see we have four car
manufacturers present in a array so if
we use the
pop option now if we use car.pop and
let's run this program
and see it says undefined this is
happening because as you can see we have
pushed the value nissan into our array
so an
address in the memory location was
reserved for that particular
element now if we pop out that
particular element so if we try to use
cars.pop once again
let's save it now and see it removed the
element forward as well so
let's try to push one more
value in this particular scenario let's
say we are pushing a value as
hyundai
and now let's run this so you can see
here it have inserted hyundai in place
of ford because we have used the pop
method to put ford out of our array
so i hope you guys understood this so
these are the different methods for
arrays in javascript which are already
predefined to do some specific tasks
like this sort method if we write here
card dot so here are all the methods
here are all the array methods present
in javascript so if we use this sort
method what it will do it will sort the
array in ascending order
the array.length property so just like
we had the length property in strings so
we have the property in arrays as well
the array.length property is used to
find the length of the array so if we
use it in a for loop in place of this i
less than 4 so
here you can see we have used i less
than 4 now if we write here
array dot length so if we write here
car
dot length so
now we don't have to change this value
again and again so if we are inserting
any value or if we are removing any
value from this for loop so if we are
removing any value from this
array so we don't have to write here 3
or we don't have to change it to 4 every
time we insert an element we don't have
to change that value basically what will
happen it will check for the length of
the array so the length here is
let's say we have the length here 3
right so it will check for the length
and it will be 1 less than the length of
the array so if we run this program now
it will work fine i hope you guys
understood the concept of array methods
present in javascript the other main
difference
array has in javascript which makes it
different from c plus plus or java is we
can add elements with other data types
in javascript we try to use the push
method to insert a numeric value here in
this cars area so we will push another
value let's say we are pushing car dot
push and this time we will push
a numeric value let's say we are pushing
here 20
so let's save it and here you can see
the value 20 is inserted inside the
array car
so we can
use
any data type inside a array in
javascript
objects are the most powerful and the
most used data types in javascript so
far we have seen that we can use a
single variable to store a value the
value can be a string or a number or any
other type of variable
after that we have seen arrays in which
we can store multiple values like we can
store list in arrays
so let's take a scenario here
and let's say we have a piece of code we
are taking a variable let's say where
car manufacturer
and the value of this car manufacturer
will be rd a string right
next up we have another variable let's
say we have a variable car model
and the value of this will be let's say
car from od is q7
then we have another variable let's say
where price of this car
and the price will be
let's say
50 000 us dollars all right next up we
have a function
let's say we are using a function
that is all wheel drive
so we are having a function all wheel
drive
the opening and closing curly braces for
the body of the function and inside this
all wheel drive function we are using
document.write
and here what we will write
will write let's suppose
this car comes
with
quattro all all-wheel drive quattro i
hope you guys are aware of this word
quattro it means that four-wheel drive
next up we will call this all-wheel
drive function here
so here's the data about a particular
car from a particular brand od right so
the car model is q7 and the price of
this car is 50 000 us dollars so these
are the three different things we are
storing for a car of a particular brand
next up we have a function which states
the capability of the car the function
here is the all-wheel drive which means
that this car comes with four wheel
drive instead of general front wheel
drive or rear wheel drive
so this function is the behavior of the
car right
it shows that the car is four wheel
drive things are pretty sorted here
right we have the data about the car and
a function associated with it so let's
save this and we can see the output here
the car comes with quattro all wheel
drive so this is a basic piece of code
right
we have been through functions we know
how to use functions we know how to call
them so that's quite easy for now right
the problem occurs when we have a list
of cars let's say that we have to
maintain 100 different cars with all the
data of car manufacturer we have car
model price and then we have different
behaviors for different cars not all
cars have the all-wheel drive property
so
what we will do in such a case where we
have to use the same property again and
again for 100 different cars or 100
different entities we can copy paste
this same piece of code repeatedly
and we have to change the value every
time we copy paste it so we have to
change the variable name the car
manufacturer the car model and the price
as well imagine we are doing this for a
list of cars then it goes on and on so
this is the most inefficient way of
tackling this problem right
this is where the concept of objects
come into play
these objects help us to bundle all
these properties and attributes about
one particular entity if we talk about
this particular example of a car we can
put all these properties and many other
properties like car weight we have car
color and so on together under
one name and make it an object
let's move on to the syntax for objects
in javascript we'll do it for this same
program we'll use
objects now let's go ahead and have a
look at the syntax for objects
so before we start
there are few ways in which we can
create objects in javascript we are
going to discuss two different ways of
doing so the first one is the literal
way also known as the literal object way
so the syntax for literal object way
goes like this
let's say we are declaring a variable
where car and
curly braces so these curly braces
represent that this car variable is
actually an object
inside this
we will define all the cars properties
that is whatever data we want to store
about the car like car manufacturer car
model and price in this particular
scenario so let's
use them here so we have
car manufacturer
and the car manufacturer is
od
right
next up we have car model
car model is
q7
finally we have the price which is
50 000
so you can identify the difference here
inside the object right when we declare
a variable we usually use the equals to
sign for assignment but here in objects
we use the colon and we are using commas
here because we have some more
properties so these three are the
properties for this object car we have
three properties associated with it we
can also add this all wheel drive
function inside the object and when we
use this function inside the object it
will be called a method whenever we use
a function inside a class or an object
so it is known as a method keep this
thing in mind guys so that syntax is
also a bit different when it comes to
methods inside an object the syntax for
that will be
we have to write here all wheel drive
and we'll use the colon then it is a
function so we will write a function
with opening and closing round brackets
and body of the function
so what we want to write here is we want
to we want this function to return the
value right we want this function to
return this value so we'll copy it from
here
and we'll paste it here
so we want this function to return this
value so we'll write here return instead
of
document.write now this function will
return this string that this cars comes
with a quattro all wheel drive
so if you want to change this string a
little bit you can change because we
have already
used this string in the previous program
we did so let's suppose
we'll write here
four wheel drive now this will be easier
for you to understand this
so this is what an object looks like our
object is entirely ready what we did
here is we bundled all these things and
coupled them we bundled all these things
we bundled
all the three variables we bundled this
function we bundled all of them together
inside a single variable and now this
particular variable car is an object now
if we want to access these properties of
the object like car manufacturer car
model etc whatever properties we have
here so what we have to do is we have to
use document.write so it is quite simple
so after this object we'll write here
document
dot right
and to access this object what we have
to do is we have to use the
object name with the dot operator and
the property name so if we want to let's
suppose
we will use here
car dot and property name will be car
underscore
manufacturer
so here is the syntax the syntax is
quite
easy you can see here we have used the
car object with the dot operator and
then we have the property name whatever
property we want to access
so let's save this program now and see
here it says od
by using this dot operator we can access
any property of the car not just a
property we can access the method as
well so if we want to access the method
like if we want to access this all wheel
drive function
we can do it simply by writing here car
dot and we'll write here instead of this
we'll write a all wheel drive and
we are good to go so if we save this now
so here you can see it says this car
comes with four wheel drive so it is
quite easy to access these properties of
an object so we can do it by using this
now suppose we call this function
normally with the document.write inside
the function in place of return so if we
write here
document.write
it's normal like how we normally call a
function so if we write here
document.write inside this function and
we can call this function by the normal
method like if you are calling this
function from outside what we'll do
we'll write here car dot
and the function name
so if we save this now here you can see
the string is printed on the browser
this car comes with four wheel drive and
you can see here we didn't use any h1
tag or h2 tag so
you can spot the difference right
so that's how you can call the method of
an object from outside this is the
normal way
so now you guys might be wondering what
if we want to add more cars into this we
can copy paste it again to do so and
change the value of properties again it
is the same thing we can do with the
variables so this is where the following
way of creating objects come into the
picture
in which we use something different
known as object constructor that's a bit
different from other object oriented
programming languages so don't worry if
you don't know about it also in the
newer versions
javascript supports the concept of
classes and object
so what we used to say earlier is
javascript is an object oriented
scripting language because it does not
supports the concept of classes and
objects fully but now the scenario has
changed javascript do support the
concept of classes and objects but we'll
keep it a bit simple so let's comment
this code as well
and we'll use this code for reference so
we'll commend this that's why we are not
removing it
but we can remove this piece of code
so let's remove it
and let's
move on to user second way of creating
an object
now we will create multiple objects
using a single template which is known
as a constructor function
let's have a look at the syntax for this
method so we'll write the function
keyword and we have named this function
as cars and in parenthesis we will
provide the
properties s parameters so these are the
properties we have car manufacturer we
have car model and we have car price
so these are the properties which we
used in the previous code as well so
here we have also used these properties
so we'll keep it that way only
now inside a function these parameters
are known as arguments so if we talk
about the naming convention so these
parameters are known as arguments
so let's move on to the body of the
function and inside the body we will use
this keyword here
this keyword refers to the object it
belongs to so here in this program this
will refer to the object basically
so what we are doing here is whenever we
are creating any object using this
constructor function we will pass
specific values
like the car manufacturer car model and
the price all of these values so all
these values will be present at the rhs
so let me write this first let's say we
are using this
dot and the property name car
manufacturer
will write here
car manufacturer
so all these values will be present at
the rhs and the actual property of the
object will be this dot car manufacturer
so
this is the actual property of this
method you will understand it much
better when we create the object for now
let's mention here the other two
properties and method as well so
let's
use the other two properties which were
this dot
car model
and
we'll write a car model the last one was
this
dot
price we'll write here price
let's add the method here as well inside
the constructor function we'll use this
keyword again to add the method the
syntax will go like this
we'll use
this dot all wheel drive
and this is a
function so we'll write here function
with the opening and closing round
brackets and then we have the body of
the function
inside the body of this function we will
write
whatever we have written in the previous
program so we'll copy it from here
and we'll paste it here
right so this is a complete constructor
function now using this constructor
function we can create multiple objects
of this car type so this constructor
function works like a template or like
the classes work in other languages like
c plus plus and java
so let's create an object here
so we'll create a variable here let's
say we are creating a variable c1 now
we'll use the new keyword and along with
the
constructor function so we'll use your
cars and we'll pass the values for all
the three properties so here you can say
we have
the car manufacturer as audi and next up
we have the
model as
q7 and the price is
50 000.
okay so we have created a variable we
have passed the
values for the properties
and now
if you want to access this function if
we want to access this all wheel drive
function we can access this as well we
have to write here c1 dot all wheel
drive and
this is how you can call a function
if we save this program see here it says
this car comes with four wheel drive
so if you change anything here let's
suppose we are using here h2tech
if we save this program now see you can
see the change here so we are calling
this function here and this will be
printed on the browser so this string
will be printed on the browser
let's create another variable here let's
say we are using where c2 and the syntax
will be same for this as well we'll
write here new cars and we'll pass the
values here so let's say we are using
bmw
and next up we have the model as
x7
and the price of this car is let's say
40 000 okay 40 000 usd so
if we want to access any particular
property of any object like if we want
to access the car model or if we want to
access the car manufacturer so we can do
it the same way as we did previously as
we did in the literal object way so
to do so we have to write here
document.write
and it was quite simple so we have to
write here the object name dot
and whatever we want to print let's say
we are printing here car model so if we
save this now you can see here x7 is
printed on the browser because x7 is the
value of object c2 and let's suppose if
we want to
print here car manufacturer save it and
see here you can see we have bmw as the
output on a browser similarly we can
access the price as well let's save it
now and see here it says 40 000
so this is how we can create multiple
objects in javascript we'll continue
with the previous program we made so
today we will use the literal object way
because this method of creating objects
is a bit easier than the other one we
discussed which was the constructor
function method so here we created the
car object which has three properties
car manufacturer car model and the price
of the car we have a method here as all
wheel drive when we use this method here
we use this method with the dot operator
and we called that function we called
that method
with the help of the object
so the output was this car comes with
four wheel drive so this was something
we did in the previous video
if we talk about objects in javascript a
lot of things we know about in
javascript are basically objects like
the boolean values numbers strings and a
few more so
many of these things can be objects if
we define them with the new keyword
basically any of the data type other
than the null and undefined can be
converted to objects or they have their
equivalent object forms if we define
them with the new keyword
so we have a few predefined objects as
well we have the math object the date
object and the regular expression are
also considered objects in javascript a
lot of things are objects in javascript
we'll use objects in dom manipulation
which we will go through in further
videos so that's why it is pretty
essential to understand the whole
concept of objects right so next up
let's look at how we can use different
data types as objects in javascript
so the syntax for using the basic data
types as objects in javascript goes like
this we'll declare a variable first we
have a variable str1 and next up we'll
write here the new keyword and the data
type so stringer is a data type which we
will be using as objects for now so this
is the complete syntax of how to use a
data type as an object in javascript if
we'll write here str
one and we'll use the dot operator so
here we can see we have the object
methods as well right
so i hope you guys are aware of the
methods present in javascript like we
had the string and array methods right
we have methods for object as well like
the index of method we have seen the use
of index of method when we went through
the string methods in javascript so
similarly we have the font color and the
length property for object as well so
length here is the property and other
which we can see are the methods for
objects in javascript so here this str1
becomes the object by default when we
use the new keyword with the string
while declaring
so there are few ways to determine if a
variable is an object or a primary data
type
so the easiest way to do so is to use
the type of operator
so let's use it here and check the type
of variable str1 we'll write here
document.write
and we'll print the type of this
variable
so we'll use the type of operator and
the type of variable str1
so let me put it inside the h1 tag
so here we have written a type of
operator so let's print this value on
the browser if we save it see here you
can see it says object
if we write a string here in place of
this new string so if we
write here any string let's suppose we
are using a string here let's say we are
using
hello
okay let's save it now and here you can
see the type of this variable str1
changed from object to string so this is
the difference between a primitive data
type it was a string earlier but when we
use it with the new keyword along with
the string
and
this is the basic syntax of how to
define a primitive data type as an
object so if we save it now here you can
see it is converted to object
similarly we can use the other basic
data types as well and
the other predefined objects we talked
about like the date object and the math
object we'll go through each of them in
separate videos so moving on let's go
back to our car object after we declared
the whole object we defined all the
three properties and the method also
somewhere in the program we realized
that we had missed a particular property
and we realized it after we have written
150 lines of code after this car object
so here you can see we have written here
150 line of code so
i'm not writing 150 lines but let's do
it this way so we realized it after 150
lines
in javascript
we can add a particular property to an
object outside the definition also we
can add a property to an object anywhere
in a program the syntax for that goes
like this
we'll write the
object name
with the property name along with the
dot operator so we'll write here one
more property let's say we are using
car color
and the value of this
property will be let's say
black
right
what this line will do is it will add
one more property inside this existing
car object so initially we had three
properties now this line will add one
more property to this car object we are
using the same name that is the object's
name having three properties over here
we are using the same object name here
you can see here the object name is car
and here we have also used the car
object name now we have added one more
property to this object car we can check
it let's print it out on the browser
so what we will do we will write here
document
dot write
so here you can see we have used the
document.write method to print this car
color on our browser so we have used
here car dot car color let's save this
program now and see
here you can see the output is black so
this is the property of the object car
now and if we comment this line let's
say if we are commenting this line let's
save this now and see here you can see
it says undefined we can add more
properties similarly like if we want to
add another property here we can go like
car dot and the property name whatever
property we want to add let's say we
want to add fuel type
so it can be a petrol car or a diesel
car or an electric car it doesn't matter
so we can add properties as well in fact
we can add methods as well so the syntax
to add method goes like we can add a
method here we'll
see it will go like car dot let's say we
are adding a new function
let's say we are adding the function new
one
equals to and here we will write
function
so the
body of the function now whatever we
want to write inside the function let's
say this function return function
successfully
added
so if we try to call this function from
outside we can do it so let's try to
check out the output for this function
let's say we want to access this
particular function so save it now and
here you can see it says function
successfully added so the new method we
added is the new fun and we added this
method to our pre-existing object which
was the car object so i hope you guys
are aware of how to add a new property
or a new method to an existing object by
now what if we want to delete a
particular object
so it's pretty easy to do so in
javascript we can use the delete keyword
object name and the property name after
the dot operator let's suppose we want
to delete car model here we want to
delete this particular property of the
object car so we what we'll do we will
delete this car model
so the syntax for it is quite simple so
we'll remove this for now and we'll
delete a property let's say we are using
the delete keyword with
the object name dot method name or the
property name so we'll delete here
car model
right let's save it now
so this particular line will delete the
car model attribute of this car object
let's check it out and we will print
here the car model so
we'll write here car dot
car underscore model
and
save it now so here you can see it says
undefined and if we try to comment this
line and now if we try to save this
program so here you can see the car
model is q7
so this is how we can delete a
particular property or a particular
method from an object one more thing
before we wrap up this video is as we
all know javascript is a loosely typed
language right so we can change the data
type of these properties on the fly now
we will change the data type of this
property we had the price property right
so we'll change the data type of this
particular property now
we know that the value of the price
property is a number let's change this
number to a string data type what we
have to do is we have to write
so we have to write here car dot
price
and
update the value of here let's say we
are using 70 000 and
we have to put a semicolon it's the same
thing we do to update the value of a
particular variable right so if we try
to print the value of price now we'll
get the output as 70 000. let's try to
print it on the browser so we'll cut it
from here
we'll paste it here and we'll print
car price
save it now see here you can see it says
70 000.
if we want to check the type of this
property
what we can do is
we can use the type of operator so we'll
use the type of operator
so this is the syntax of how we can use
the type of operator let's save this now
and see here it says string
earlier it was a number but now it is a
string so all these things can be done
dynamically in a program wherever we
want to do them so that's the benefit of
having objects in javascript
we have been using the
document.getelementbyid method for the
past few videos right
we know it is used to access an html
element with the help of an id which is
uniquely provided to each element
so we use that method with text boxes
then with radio buttons and then with
select boxes as well
so today we are going to use a method
that is somewhat similar to
document.getelementbyid method
so we'll be using the
document.getelements by tag name method
in javascript
as the name suggests this method is used
to access a bunch of similar elements
with the same tag so we have tag name in
our method right so we can access a
bunch of tags with similar name like if
we have a few div tags present in our
program and we want to change each div
text style
we can do it with the help of this
method
so we'll look at the syntax first and
then we'll move on to the difference
between id and tag name method
so let's move on to the programming part
directly
what we'll do is we'll create a few div
tags first and then we'll change the
style of these div tags with specific
styling properties we are not going to
use css for that but in javascript we
have other styling properties as well so
we'll be using those styling properties
so let's create the div text first
we'll write here div
and then let's say we are
writing it this is section
one so we'll copy this line
and we'll create four similar div tags
right
we have section one two three and
four
save it and you can see over here we
have four different sections present
now this is a very basic example and
here we have different sections present
right next up we'll try to access these
div tags with the help of tag name
method so let's add a button over here
and then we'll move on to the javascript
part
so we'll write here
let's use the br tag and we'll write
here
input tag again we'll write a input type
is equals to
button and we'll use the on click method
as well so we'll write here on click
and let's say a function name is
fun2
and then we have the
value of this button as let's say submit
close the input tag and save it so here
you can see we have a button over here
submit button and you can see here
nothing is happening on clicking on the
submit button
so next up what we are going to do is we
are going to add functionality to this
submit button for that we have to move
to our javascript file and we have to
create a function over there
so we'll write here
in the javascript file we'll write here
function
fun2 and then we have the body of this
function right so the syntax is a bit
similar to that of the
document.getelementbyid method what
we'll do is we'll take a variable x and
then we'll write here
document dot
get elements by tag name and then we'll
write inside the brackets the name of
tag we want to access right so here we
have added four different div tags so
in this case we'll write here div and we
can similarly access any of the tags
present in our html document we can
access paragraph tags we can access
anchor text and any tag we want to
basically
so
save it and here now we have a variable
x that holds an html collection of all
the div text present inside the html
file
this means that we have an array of
references of all the div tags here
inside this variable x
so if we try to make changes in a single
area element just like we did in the
select box example wherein we use the
array index to access a particular
element present at a particular array
index right so we can do the same here
we'll write here x and then we'll write
the
index number so this particular
statement will access the element
present at number one
or this particular syntax will access
the
first div tag of html document because
we know arrays start from zero
and at zero the first element will be
present so this div tag will be present
at number zero
and then we are going to use the style
property so we know that
x here is not a variable only actually x
here acts as an object and we know that
different objects have certain
properties in javascript so style is one
of those properties and next up we'll
write here
let's say
font family so what we are doing is we
are doing the css part with properties
present in javascript so let's say we
are changing our font to
courier new all right so this is a font
name
and we can use any font name over here
so save it what will happen now is on
clicking the submit button
the font of this particular section the
font of div 1 will change to courier new
so let's try if it's happening or not on
clicking the submit button you can see
over here the change between this line
and other three div tags clearly the
font has changed the new font is courier
new and what we did here is we changed
the font family of this particular div
tag so similarly we can make more
styling changes to other div tags as
well so let's do it here
and we'll
make changes to each of the div tags we
have in a html file so let's say
here we are using the color property and
we want to change the font color to
blue fine then we'll do the same for
element present at number three for that
we'll write here x and the index number
will be two
so then again we'll use the style
property and then
let's say we are writing a
font
style
fine and the font style we want it to be
italic
and then finally we have one more
property
let's say for a
for the repeat so let's say for the last
div tag we are using the background
color
fine
and we'll write here the color name is
red
so we are good to go now save it and we
have four different properties over here
for section 4 we are changing the
background color so
3 will be the index number of the last
array variable so save it and on
pressing the submit button you can see
the change over here so for section 1
the font is changed to courier new for
section 2 the font color is blue let me
zoom it out a bit to show you guys you
can see over here the color is blue
and then we have italic text in section
3 and finally for section 4 we have the
background color as 4 right
so you can see how we are accessing any
particular element of the array now
why we are using these properties
separately for each array element
so if we try to make changes on each
element of the array we simply can't do
it in javascript at once so if we try to
write here so let's comment this out
first what we'll do is we'll write a x
dot style dot font family so basically
what we want to do is we want to change
the font family for all the div tags
present right because we know the
variable x is holding an array of all
the div text present in a html file
right so we'll save it and you can see
over here if we are clicking on the
submit button you can see nothing is
happening so if we go to our console
and you can see it over here that we
have an error here so it says it cannot
set property font family of undefined so
this is the problem with this get
elements by tag name method
to overcome this problem we have a
solution as well so the solution for
this problem is we have to use the for
loop
so how this for loop works
so we'll write here
for
and then we'll take a local variable i
and the initial value will be 0
then we'll write a i
less than
x dot length because we want to traverse
the whole array right and then we'll
write here the condition i plus plus
so we have to go then we have this body
of for loop and inside here we'll write
x and the index number will be i because
it will keep on changing and we are in a
loop
so
we'll write here dot style and then
let's say the style we want to
do is font
weight and what we want to do is we want
to make our font
bolder fine
so comment this line as well save it now
and you can see over here everything is
clean now what will happen is on
pressing the submit button the font will
change the font weight will change
basically so let me zoom this
and if we click on this submit button
you can see the font is more bolder
right
so if we are using another property here
let's say the font
we are using here
background color and we want the
background color to be yellow
fine so save it and on clicking the
submit button you can see the background
color for all the div tags for all the
four section is changed to yellow fine
so this is how we can access all the
elements of an array at once
now what we did is we started a loop and
traversed every element in the array and
applied the same property to each
element
so this is how we can do it with the
help of
tag name method in javascript now what
if we have hundreds of similar elements
like div tag present in our website and
all of them are present at different
locations so let's try to do it and what
we'll do is we'll insert certain
different elements in between these div
tags
fine so we'll include a form and then
we'll include some radio buttons and
anything we want to do we can do it so
we'll add some more elements in between
these div tags
so here you can see we have inserted
two three more elements and between
these div tags so save it and you can
see after each section we have something
else here we have a form with
two different text boxes we have name
and age and then we have a submit button
as well
then after that we have section two so
this is our section two
then after section 2 we have radio
button and the value is a then we have
another radio button b and in between we
have all the dev text present so
basically what we want to do is we want
to change the style for each of the div
tags right
so we will change the background color
here so let's say we'll write here red
and what will happen is on clicking the
submit button on clicking this submit
button what will happen is the
background color of each div tag
so the background color for section 1 2
3 and 4 will change to red so let's try
to do it and let's see if it's
working or not so we'll click on the
submit button and you can see it over
here we have all the div tags with
background color as
red so this is working totally fine
one more thing we'll discuss before
wrapping up this video is the uniqueness
of id attribute for each element
so we are saying this for a long time
that the id for each element should be
unique why so although we saw in the
past videos that we can use the same id
for two different elements when we did
the same for accessing a css styling
property using the id attribute but if
we try to do the same thing with
javascript we'll get an error for
example if we try to access the value of
any particular element with the id
attribute but we have two elements in a
html file with the same id so it will
throw an error in that case basically
and this is the reason why we use the
tag name method in javascript so that if
we want to access multiple elements of
the same name we can do it with this
method because it's not possible to use
the id method separately for each
element present in the html document
right
because we have certain same html tags
present within an html document like we
have the div tags here similarly a
website is long enough to have multiple
similar elements present within it so
that's why we use the
document.getelementsbytagname method in
javascript
so guys in the past few videos we use
two different methods of accessing an
element from an html file using
javascript properties so we know the
difference between the id method and the
tag name method right today we will use
another method to access a particular
element in javascript that is the class
name method or we can say the get
elements by class name method in
javascript so before discussing the
class name method in javascript let's
look at why accessing an element is
important in javascript
so we know that the document object
model is used to change
add or delete html elements we saw
earlier that we could change html
elements or the css style of any element
in the document with the help of
javascript properties
so to make specific changes to those
elements we need to access them using
particular methods so we discussed two
such methods before the id method and
the tag name method right so let's move
ahead and look at the class name method
of accessing an element in javascript as
the name suggests the main attribute in
this method will be the class name so we
know the difference between the class
and the id attribute used in html
we know that id has to be unique for
each element but we know that many
elements in an html document can have
the same class right so we used class to
access specific css properties in the
previous videos
and that is the only benefit of using
classes in javascript so we can say that
a single class can be used by many
elements within an html document so
let's dig a bit deeper into this concept
so let's say we have five elements
present on our website and we want to
make changes in three of these elements
right so let's write the code here and
it will be easier for you guys to
understand so
we'll write here in the html file will
add five different
elements
so let's say we are writing here
div and
then inside this div we'll write
this is
section one we'll copy this
we'll paste it here
so we'll use two div elements and two
paragraph element right so here in this
p tag we'll write
this is
section three
and then we'll copy this line
paste it again copy this one as well and
paste it here
so we have section one section two three
four and
five
so out of these five different
elements we have three div tags and we
have two paragraph text so we'll discuss
why we have taken two paragraph text in
between the
div tags
so we are done with it here you can see
we have five elements present in a html
document three of them are the div text
section one two and five are div text
and two texts in between are the
paragraph text so now
let's suppose we want to change the
style of three of these elements let's
say one four and five so we can do it in
two ways right either we can use the id
method or we can use the class method
however we can use the tag name method
as well but
we have to use two different variables
for that right that will be a lengthy
process why two different variables
because we have two different tags
present here right we have to create
separate variable for the div tag and
separate one for the paragraph text so
that will be a lengthy process so we'll
consider id method and the class name
method for here
so considering the id method the
document.getelementbyid method we have
to provide a unique id to each element
so we have to provide unique id to this
div tag then we have to provide to each
and every element here right because we
need to access
three of these elements so at least we
have to provide the id to those three
elements which we want to access right
so in such cases we can use the class
name method where we want to access more
than one element but not all the
elements in an html file
so we'll use the class attribute in each
element we want to access
so let's say we want to access section
one two and five
so we'll write a class let's say the
class name is cls1
we'll copy this paste it here and we are
accessing one two and four because one
two and five are
the div text so we can access these with
the help of tag name method as well so
we'll access one two and four
fine so we have used the class attribute
here
next up we'll create a button and then
we'll add functionality to a html
document so let's create a button here
we'll again use input type is equals to
button and then we have
on click
and on clicking it will call
funk one
and then we have the value as
submit fine
so save it
and here you can see
in the browser we have five sections
over here we have section one two three
four and five then we have a submit
button which will call the function
on clicking so we haven't added
functionality till now so let's move
ahead to our javascript file and we'll
add functionality to a
html document
so inside this javascript file we'll
write here
function and then we have the function
name as
function
then we have the body of this function
so the syntax remains a bit same
so we'll take a variable first and then
we'll use the document method to take
references of all the elements from a
html file
so we'll write here
where x is equals to
document dot
get elements by
class name right and then we'll write
the class name here so the class name is
cls1
till now what we did was we took the
references of all the required elements
and stored them inside a variable named
x in the form of an html collection
so now we can make changes to these
elements and what we'll do is we'll
again use the style property to make
styling changes in those three sections
so we have these three sections present
inside an array and we can access any
one or all the three elements right so
we'll write here x and then we'll
provide the index number so let's say we
want to access section 1 that is the
first div tag so we'll provide the index
number as 0
then we'll write dot
tile
and this style is a property dot
then let's say we want
to change the font style so we'll write
here
font
style
font style will be
italic
save it so this piece of code will
change the font style of the element
present at index 0. save it and on
clicking the submit button here on the
browser
we can see the change in this section
right so if it's not visible so let me
zoom it a bit for you here you can see
guys the font at section one is changed
to italic right so in this case we have
all the three elements present in our
array and we can make changes to each of
these elements so let's try to do it and
we'll use element present at index 1 now
we'll copy this line and we'll paste it
here again two times because we want to
make changes to all the elements right
we'll write it two and we'll write here
one
and let's say
we want to change the font color for
this one and the font color will be blue
for this we will change the font weight
let's say
and we want to make it
bolder
so we'll write here bolder
save it and on clicking the submit
button you can see we have all the three
sections with some minor changes the
first one is changed and we have italic
over here for the second one we have
blue color as font color and for the
third one which is section four we have
the
font weight as bolder so you can see the
change over here so this is how we can
make change to each element separately
and we can also make changes in all the
elements at once as well so for that we
have to use the for loop just like we
did for the tag name method right
so for that we'll write here so let's
comment these three statements first
and then we'll write here 4 and
it will take a local variable here we'll
write you where
i is equals to 0 i will start from index
and i will go till
x dot
length
and then we have the condition is i plus
plus
so inside the body of for loop we'll
write here
x and
instead of index number we'll write here
i because we want to traverse the whole
array then we'll write here style
dot
and let's say the style we want is
background color
we want the background color to be let's
say
yellow
fine
so this is how we can use the for loop
save it and we'll see on clicking the
submit button on our browser
the background color for all the three
sections that is 1 2 and 4 is changed to
yellow
this is how we can use the
document.getelementsbyclassname method
to access all the elements present in an
html file with a particular class next
up let's discuss the difference between
the id method tag name method and the
class name method
so we'll discuss when to use which
method so
let's start with the id method so the id
method is used when we want to access a
single element and we have to provide a
unique id to that element in order to
access it so the id method is quite
useful when we want to work on a single
element
apart from that if we want to work on
more than one element we have two other
methods
we can either use the class name method
or the tag name method for more than one
element
so the tag name method is also quite
useful when we want to access elements
with the same tag name
we can access all the similar tags
present within an html document with the
help of tag name method the only problem
is we can access similar types of tags
only at one time we can't access two
different types of tags with this method
so this is where the class name method
comes into play we can access more than
one element with this method and the
elements can be different just like we
did here we had
div tag and paragraph tag right so
the section 1 2 and 5 are from div text
and the section 4 and 3 are from the
paragraph text so we can access two
different tags with same class name with
the help of class name method in
javascript
so with this we came to the conclusion
that more than one element in the html
file can have the same class and can be
accessed with the class name method so
by now i hope you guys understood the
concept of all the three methods which
we have discussed
the
id method the tag name method and the
class name method in javascript we can
use any of these methods according to
our needs
so guys we came across several topics
till date right we have seen loops
operators then we came across document
object model and many more such topics
so we saw the usage of these topics we
know how to take users input in
javascript and how to use them so today
we will do something more interesting
and i hope today's topic of discussion
will make javascript more interesting
for you guys so let's start with the
topic
so we all know how a calculator works
right we can make a simple calculator
program in javascript with few operators
and the if else statement so let me show
you guys a simple program in javascript
with which we can calculate several
arithmetic expressions and get the
output so here is the code
so we have used the script tag within
the html document so you can see it on
the screen guys here we have four
variables where op that will take the
input from the user in the form of plus
minus
and then we have asterisk and divide and
then we have reminder as well so depends
upon which task the user wants to
perform it will take the user's input
next up we have two variables n1 and n2
for the numbers upon which the operation
will be performed
also we have used parse float here we
know the usage of this function right
whatever input given by the user will be
changed to a floating number with the
help of this function
then we have a variable output that will
hold the value returned after performing
the calculation so we have several
conditions here as well we have several
conditions for each operator like if the
input given by the user is plus then it
will perform
addition between n1 and n2 and the value
of n1 plus n2 will be assigned to
variable output right similarly we have
other conditions for other operators
like we have for minus then we have for
stress then we have for divide and for
remainder as well so
any choice the user will make will get
the output accordingly like if the user
chooses
to perform a division then it will
write slash and then it will perform n1
by n2 and the output will be saved in
the variable output then we can
show this output with the help of alert
method in javascript we already came
across this alert method it will give a
pop-up with the result
let's check the output once and then
we'll move on to the exciting part of
this video so this is a basic calculator
program with two variables n1 and n2
so let's open it with live server
and here you can see we have a pop-up
here and here what we have to do is we
have to enter the operator so here we
have to
write
either plus minus or any operator from
these operators so let's write here
asterisk so let's say we want to perform
multiplication between two numbers then
we press ok and here we have the pop-up
for the first number so let's say the
first number is
5 and
the second number is let's say 10
so
the moment we press ok you can see here
we have the output as a result is 50. so
we have a pop-up this pop-up is made
with the help of window.alert method
and the calculator is working totally
fine right so if we press ok and if we
refresh this let's use another operator
as well so let's say we are using the
division operator
click on ok and we'll enter the first
number let's say the first number is 45
and
the second number is let's say
okay the moment we press ok we have the
output as
5.625 the pop-up here says
result is 5.625
so this calculator is working totally
fine
now this is a basic javascript
calculator right
so we went through this program so that
you guys can revise what we have learned
till now let's move ahead to the central
part of today's video and we'll create a
calculator like the original one so we
use calculators on phones or laptops as
well so today we are going to make one
similar to them so let me show you guys
what we are going to create
so this is the calculator we are going
to create today so this looks like an
actual calculator right we use such
calculators daily either on our phones
or on laptops or sometimes physically as
well
so this looks like a calculator app so
let's try to use it let me zoom it for
you guys so if we click on 8 and then we
click on any number so it will be
printed on the display area then we'll
use any operator then let's say we are
using 86 minus 5 so this is the
expression we want to evaluate
so what we have to do is we have to
press this equals 2 button and we have
the output as 81. so this calculator is
also working fine so today we are going
to create one such calculator or we can
say we are going to create this
calculator only
now the question that arises here is how
difficult is it to create one such
calculator in javascript do we have to
write hundreds of lines of code for it
or do we have to write complex code for
it so in this video we will see how easy
it is to write code for such a
calculator
the code we saw earlier that is the one
where we used simple arithmetic
operators to find the output for simple
calculations for two numbers obviously
is not what we'll do in this one so
it will increase the code length like if
we use operators if we use if else
statement for each operator then
definitely it will increase the length
of the code so we'll try something
different and this next program for a
calculator app will let you know the
advantages provided by javascript in
terms of programming so let's start with
the programming part directly now we
don't need this file anymore so we'll
clear it next up we have three files
here right we have calculator.html and
then for styling we have style.css and
lastly we have script.js for adding
functionality to our calculator
right so today we will divide this code
into three different parts in the first
part we will work on the html file and
we'll create the layout of this
calculator then we'll move on to the css
part and there will add style to the
calculator and then finally we'll add
functionality to a calculator
so let's start with the html part then
now we have to keep a few things in mind
and we'll first add the simply code
image to our
web page so for that we have to write
here inside the body tag because we want
to make a webpage more attractive right
we'll write here div
we'll
use a division and then inside this div
tag
we'll use the img tag then
the src will be
simply
code.png so this is the file we have
already saved in our folder
now we'll use the alt attribute here and
alternate will be
simply code right
then next up this image size is quite
large so
if we save this program now
you can see the image size is large
right so what we'll do is we'll limit
the width of this image
so we'll write here width and then let's
say the width will be 300 pixel so this
will be the default width for
this image as well as for the calculator
right next up
we'll go back to the original calculator
and we can see here we have a heading
calculator right so we'll add this as
well so for that we have to write here
inside a html file
we'll add another tag
so
we'll write here
div
and then we'll
provide it with a class let's say the
class is title
and
then we'll use the p tag paragraph tag
we can say so inside this p tag we'll
write here calculator so save it
and
you can see here on the browser that we
have an image and over here we have a
heading as well right so the heading
here says calculator
will use css to style these elements
later for now we have just added them to
a web page next up we'll start working
on the body of this calculator so let me
show you guys this is the body of this
calculator this whole area represents
the body of this calculator this display
area and the buttons as well so this is
the whole calculator body so for that we
have to write here first
right here div and then we'll use the
class attribute
so the
class will be
let's say calculator
fine
now next up we have to work on the
display area as well so this div tag is
for the
whole calculator's body so the whole
calculator's body include the display
area as well as all the buttons and this
whole area basically so this falls
under the
calculator's body so for the display
area we have to use input tag again so
what we are going to do is we are going
to create a placeholder type of thing so
we will write here input we will use the
input tag we'll write it type is equals
to text
and then we'll
use the class attribute here so let's
say the class for this display area will
be
display and then we'll use a property
here will write here disabled
so
i'll tell you what this disabled is used
for so for now let's save it
and here you can see if it's visible or
not so here is the display so this is a
placeholder type of thing so if you can
see here we can't click on it we simply
can't do anything inside it so this is
what the disabled property does so it
won't let the user to enter something on
the on this text box now you can see
here that we have a display area on our
web page and we can't do anything over
here it's disabled right that's because
we don't want the user to write anything
on it we want to take the input when the
user presses a key on the calculator so
let's move ahead and we are going to add
keys to our web page so we have four
rows here in the calculator body you can
see we have four rows starting from 7 4
1 and c right so these are the four rows
the first row contains seven eight nine
and plus operator and then we have
second row that contains four five six
and minus then we have third row and
fourth row as well right so we'll use
div tags for all the rows and we'll keep
all these four div tags inside a single
div tag that's because we'll use the
class attribute again to add styling to
a bunch of elements together now
we have several different types of keys
in our calculator so we have 10 numeric
keys and four operator keys an equal key
and one for clearing the screen as well
right so this key here where we have
written c so what this will do is it
will clear the display area every time
the user presses it it will clear the
display area
now so we are going to create different
classes for them so let's do it here
let's go back to our html file and
here what we'll do is
we'll write here
again a div tag
and for this div tag the class will be
let's say keys fine
now inside this div tag we are going to
create another div tag for each row so
for this
div tag we'll write here div class is
equals to row
and inside this dev tag what we'll do is
we'll create buttons so today we are
going to use the button
element for it
so we'll write here
button and
the first button we want to add is
7 right because 7 is present at number 1
if we see the calculator from the start
we can see 7 is at number 1 so we'll
write here value 7
and then we'll write here 7
then we'll
copy this and we'll create all the four
buttons in the first row so we'll paste
it again for four times then we have
buttons as seven eight then we have nine
and then finally we have
plus right so here we'll also change the
values
we'll write here
seven eight nine in plus so save it and
if we move back to our calculator you
can see here we have four buttons here
we have seven eight nine and plus all
right so we'll style these buttons later
so for now what we'll do is we'll add
all the four rows
so we'll copy this
whole div tag
and we'll
paste it again
for all the rows so we'll paste it four
times and here what we'll do is we'll
create second row so the second row
contains 4 5 6 and minus right so we'll
write here 4 5 6 and minus we'll change
these values as well similarly for third
row
we'll write here 1
then
3 and then asterisk for multiplication
right then we have the fourth row so the
fourth row contains
c 0 division and equal right so we'll
write here
c
division
and equals right so we'll change the
values here as well we'll write here
the same
so save it
and here you can see we have the body
offer calculator we have a display area
we have all the four rows with all the
buttons so you can see nothing is
happening on clicking on these buttons
so we'll add functionality to them as
well
so for now we are done with our html
part next up we'll use the css for
styling these element and we'll style
these elements one by one so let's add
the link of our css file to html
document first we'll add it inside the
head tag
so we'll move to a head tag and we'll
add the link here so we'll write here
link and then we'll write here
rel is equals to
style sheet and we'll write it type is
equals to
text slash css
and then we'll write here htf is equals
to
style dot css
so we have already
created this style.css here so we have
linked
this css file to a html document save it
and then we'll move to a css file and
we'll
start styling these elements now
so first we'll apply padding and margin
to the whole html document so for the
whole html document we'll use the s
trick here
and inside this asterisk we'll
write here
padding
and we'll
keep the value as zero for margin also
we'll keep the value as zero so save it
so here you can see the padding and
margin are zero and you must have
noticed the change here the calculator
is now a little bit compressed right
you can check it through the inspect
elements option as well
next up we'll apply styling to the
heading so
we don't have to do anything with the
picture although we can use the on mouse
over and on mouse out events with the
picture as well but i'm not doing it for
now but you guys can do it as we came
across this topic in the previous video
so let's move ahead and now we'll apply
the style to heading
for that we have to use the class
attribute in a html file so if we go
back to our html file and you can see
here with the heading or we we can say
with the calculator or paragraph tag we
have the class attribute here and the
class is titled so we'll use this class
attribute here and we'll write here
dot
title so let me guys first make changes
to this particular element then we'll
discuss it so we'll write here
margin
bottom
is 10 pixel we want the distance between
the calculator and
the heading as 10 pixel and then we'll
write here text align
center
so this is pretty basic
then we have
font
weight as
bolder
and then we have
font size as well so we'll write here
extra
large then we have width
of this particular element and we know
the default width is 300 pixels so we'll
write here 300 pixel
and then we'll
use the color
so we want the color to be pure black
for this heading so we'll write here
black
and
we'll save it so here you can see we
have this heading in the center and till
now we haven't worked on the body of the
calculator so this calculator heading is
done we have the heading in the center
now these are the styling changes we
made in the heading part so we have used
the margin bottom as 10 pixel and it
will keep the heading 10 pixels away
from whatever is present on the bottom
side of the heading
then we have aligned the text in the
center of the division then we have the
font weight as bolder which will make
the font bold and the font size is extra
large the width of the section is also
equal to the width of the image we used
then the font color is black and we have
seen the changes
next up we'll make style changes to our
body tag and we'll put this calculator
in the middle of the screen also
we will make changes to the font family
as well of the whole calculator now we
are making changes to the body of this
html document right we want the
calculator to be present at the center
of the web page so for that
we'll write here body
so we don't have any class so we'll
write a body because we want to make
changes in the element so for body we'll
write your width
as
vw
height is
100 vh
display is
flex
then we have
justify content
as
center
then we have align items as
then we have background color so we can
change the background color of the whole
body so we'll write here
f
1 f1 f1
so this is a little bit different from
white so we'll check it then we have
font family
as
sense serif right
so this vw and vh in width and height is
the viewport width and viewport height
so this will take 100 percent of the
viewport width and the height as well
next up we have used the display as flex
and we have used the justify content and
align content as the center we did so in
order to keep the calculator in the
center of the web page
then we use the background color as
white we can change the background color
to any other color as well but let's
keep it simple this time and lastly we
use the font family is sense serif save
it and here we have a calculator in the
center of the web page so let me zoom it
for you guys you can see here we have
the calculator in the center of this web
page
now next up we'll work on the body of
this calculator so the border represents
the display area and the
buttons right not the buttons but this
whole div tag inside which the buttons
are present represents the calculator's
body
so we'll use the class calculator to
make changes here
for that we'll write here inside the css
file we'll write here dot
calculator and inside this will write
width so we want the width to be default
which is 300 pixels so we'll write here
then we'll write padding bottom
15 pixel
so save it
and you can't see any changes for now so
we'll see it
next up we'll write here
border radius and the border radius will
be
let's say 7 pixel
we want the background color to be
black for the calculator's body so we'll
write here background color
black
and then we have box
shadow so we'll define inside this box
shadow we'll write here 5
pixel
8 pixel
then
8 pixel and minus 2 pixel
so what we are doing is we are working
on the shadow of this box and then we'll
write here
rgba
for red it will be
zero for green it will be zero
and for blue as well it will be
zero and then for alpha
it will be
0.61
fine
so this color is a bit different from
black
save it and here you can see we have the
calculator's body
so let me zoom it out
a little bit
so here you can see we have the
calculator's body so this is the
calculator's body and we haven't worked
on the display area and the buttons till
now so it will be fine after we'll work
on the display area and buttons
now we have kept the width as 300 just
like we did for the image and heading
so the background color is black and the
box shadow is defined for this box as
well
next up we'll work on the display area
and then we'll move ahead to the keys so
let's work with the display area first
we'll
write here
display because we have used the
classes display for our display
so inside this will write
width as
of this
calculator's body
and then we'll write here height so
height will be let's say 80 pixels we
can't write here 100 because we don't
want the display area to be present
within the whole calculator so we want
it to be
this much only so we'll write here 80
pixels
save it and the display area you can see
here we have the display area is 100 of
this div tag the width is 100 and the
height is 80 pixels
and then we'll add another styling
properties as well so we don't want any
border so for border we'll write here
none
and then for
box sizing we'll write here
border box
and then padding will be
10 pixels so we want the text to be 10
pixel above the calculator's black part
and then we'll write here
font size as double excel so we'll write
a extra extra large
then we'll use the background color so
the background color is little bit
grayish so
the code for that is
c c c e
cc
so this is the color of a display area
then we have the font color as
black
and the text will be aligned we want the
text to be aligned at the right
so we'll write here right
so
next up what we want to do is we want
the display to be a little bit curved
from the top left and right corners
right so for that we'll write here order
top
left radius will be
7 pixel
and
border top right radius will be 7 pixel
right
save it and you can see here we have a
display area perfect now
we have curves from left and right side
from the top and left and top and right
side
with this we are done with the display
area as well next up we'll move on to
the button part here we have a class
named row for all the buttons and then
we have a class as operators for all the
operators button
and then we have class as equals for the
equal to button as well right so if we
go back to our html file
what we'll do is
we'll define two more classes so for
operators like
for addition subtraction multiplication
and division the class will be
operators
so we'll copy it from here
and we'll give it to almost each
operator as well as the clear screen
button
so we'll give it here as well
we'll give it to minus
we'll give give it to addition as well
save it
and for equals to we have another class
as
equals fine
save it let's move back to our css file
and firstly we'll
use the class row for styling all the
buttons similarly then we'll use class
operators and equals for
making minor changes to those particular
buttons right
so first we'll use the button tag
so we'll write here button
so we'll make changes to each and every
button with the help of this button
element
we'll write here
width as
50 pixel
and height will also be 50
so we'll write here for height 50 pixel
and then we have
border radius as
50 because we want our buttons to be
circular right so we'll write here 50
border radius then we'll write here for
border we don't want any border so for
border we'll write here
none
and for outline also we don't want any
outline as well so we'll write in none
for
font size so let's say the font size we
want is extra large
fine
the background color for all the buttons
will be
white
and the
font color for all the buttons will be
black
so we'll write a white and black and the
font weight
will be
bold
and lastly the margin
for each button will be 10 pixel
so save it
and here you can see a calculator
information right
so we can see here we have all the
buttons
circular in shape we have four rows and
all the buttons are circular in shape if
we compare this calculator to the
original one to the one which we are
going to achieve later in this video so
you can see here both of them looks
almost similar right we have all the
buttons here
and
next up what we'll do is we'll add some
more styling to these buttons so
let's move ahead and we'll add hover
effect to the buttons to help us change
the mouse pointer when the user takes
the cursor over any button so if we go
here inside this calculator and you can
see here on taking the mouse cursor over
any button the mouse cursor is changing
here right but if we go back to this
calculator you can see there is no
change in this particular calculator
right so for that we have to write here
button
and then we'll write here hover
so
inside this
we'll write here
cursor as pointer
so save it and if we take our cursor to
any of these buttons you can see the
cursor is changing to pointer right
so
we are done with it
next up we'll use two more properties
for each row and our buttons are almost
done with some part left like the color
and all so we'll write a row because we
have defined the class as row for each
row
so we'll write here
display and the display will be flex
and we'll justify content as space
between
so save it and here you can see both the
calculators are now of similar size
there's no difference in these two
calculators now we'll make changes to
the colors of operator buttons and the
equal to button
so for that we have two more classes
operator class and equals class
so we'll write here for the operator
class so we'll write here dot operator
and inside this we'll write here
background color is so we want the
background color to be a little bit
golden or we can say it's different from
yellow and golden so we'll write here we
have particular code for this color so
we'll write here
hash
ff9500 so this is the code for this
particular color we'll save it
and the mistake is the class name is
operators save it and we have all the
operators with this color
next up we'll write here
font weight as
bold
save it and then we have
color font color as black so it will be
default as well because these properties
we have already defined in the button
tag
next up we have another class for the
equal to button so we'll write here dot
equals and
inside this we want the background color
to be a little bit on the grayish side
so for that the rgb code is 85 84 and
84. so save it and here you can see we
have the equal to button in gray color
next up we'll copy these two properties
from here
and we'll paste them here save it and
here you can see with this we are done
with our calculator
and we have the calculator almost same
suppose we compare this calculator with
the final one we can see we have the
exact same calculator here and html and
css part is done
now we are left with only one thing the
next thing we have to do is we have to
add functionality to this calculator
so we have the body of a calculator but
if we try to click on these buttons you
can see nothing is happening over here
that's because we haven't added any
functionality to a calculator yet so
let's move on to the javascript part and
we'll create certain functions here to
add functionality to a calculator
talking about the functioning of a
calculator we need three functions one
for the display area one for the
calculation part and the last one is for
the clear screen that will be used when
the user presses the clear screen button
this particular button when the user
will press the screen will get cleared
the idea behind the working of the
calculator is whatever button the user
will press will be displayed on the
display screen
then we'll use the eval function to
evaluate the expression we get from the
display
and then the estimated value will be
printed on the screen so the last
function will clear the screen again and
can be used again for another
calculation so the concept is simple
let's start with the programming part
directly
and
before that what we'll do is
we'll add this javascript file to a html
document so we'll write here
script src is equals to
script.js type is equals to text slash
javascript save it and we have connected
the js file to our html document now we
are inside a javascript file so the
concept is simple let's start with the
programming part directly so we'll
create a function for the display first
and that function will take the input
from whatever will be there on the
display screen so we'll write here
function display and it will take a
parameter as well
and then we have the body of this
function so
here we are and we have a function
display with parameter value and then
we'll update the value present in the
display box so we'll use the on click
event first and we'll display the value
of these buttons on
display so for this we'll go back to our
html file and we'll use the on click
event
there
so what we'll do is
will write here
on click
and on clicking button 7 will call
display function and it will display
something on the screen so we'll write
here
7 and similarly what we'll do is we'll
copy this and we'll paste it for each
button right so let me do it for you
guys
we'll paste it here
then we'll paste it again and again for
each button except the clear screen and
equal button
right
so we'll write here 8
then for 9 it will display 9 and for
plus it will display
plus
then we'll again
paste it here for all the buttons
what we have to do is we have to keep
one thing in mind it won't work for
equal and clear screen button apart from
that all the buttons will call this
function on clicking so
we'll write here minus for minus
operator
for six we'll write here six for five
will write your five and for four we'll
write here four
we'll do this
okay we forgot to change the values here
so we'll change the values as well
so we'll write a 1 2 3
and then we'll paste the on click event
here
and we'll change the values here as well
so we'll write a one
for two we'll write here two for three
we'll write a three
and for operators
we'll write here
s trick
then we'll
do the same for on click
display 0 it will display 0
for division it will
display
division
save it and you can see nothing is
displaying on the display area yet
because we haven't added the
functionality to the function display
so
before moving on to the javascript file
let's add the id attribute as well to
the display area because we are
accessing the display area and will
access that area with
the id attribute so we'll write here id
and id let's say will be id1
so save it and we'll move back to a
javascript file now
here inside this display function will
write here
document dot
get element by id and id is
id1
so we'll write here dot value
plus is equals to
well so
we'll discuss it what we did just now so
save it first and if we click on any
button now you can see we have all the
values in the display area now
right
so other buttons are not working yet so
if we click on this clear screen button
it won't work or the equal to button
either won't work now because till now
we haven't defined these functions
so this statement here this
document.getelementbyid
id1 dot value plus equals to well this
particular statement will use the id
attribute and we have written here plus
equals to so basically what we are doing
is we are appending any new value to the
previous value present in the display
area
so if we remove this plus here
and save it now
so if we click on a button let's say we
are clicking on a button and we want to
print 89 on the display area but if we
click on nine you can see it's not
appending right the values are
overriding because we are using the
equal to operator only and the value
will be assigned to display screen again
and again
but if we want to append the value with
the previous one so we have to add plus
here and if we save it now you can see
now we can add
as many numbers as we want to the
display area
right now we have the expression present
over here in the display area so if we
refresh it and let's say the expression
is 87 plus 3 the next thing we want to
do is to calculate the value of this
expression
for that we can either use the if else
statements but then the code will go so
long and complex right in order to solve
this problem javascript provides its
user with a single function that can
compute complex calculation in the blink
of an eye so today we'll use a function
named eval
so this eval function will take any
argument as a string and it will execute
it
the string can be an expression it can
be a variable it can be a statement or a
sequence of statements as well so we'll
call a function solve on clicking the
equal button to solve the expression
written over the display area so for
that we'll move back to our html file
and
here on the equal button what we'll do
is
we'll write here
on click and on clicking it will call
the solve function
so save it and we'll move back to a
javascript file
and we'll declare a function here we'll
define a function so we'll write your
function
solve
and then we have the body of this
function so let me cross check it yeah
it's solve
so inside this function solve we'll take
two variables so let's say we have two
variables
let x and y
so
inside the x will take whatever value
present in the display screen so we'll
write here document dot
get element by id we'll write here
id1 so we are taking the value present
at the display screen so we'll write
here dot well
and what we'll do is now we have a
variable x which holds the reference of
the value present at the display screen
so we'll write here a single function
we'll write here eval and then inside
this evil will write x
so with this we are done with the
calculation part next up what we have to
do is we have to assign this display
screen the value present at y because
now we have the
answer right we have the answer to a
particular calculation so what we'll do
is we'll write here document dot
get element by id the id is id1
and we'll write a dot value we are
updating the value so we'll write here
dot value is equals to y so the value
present at y will be assigned to the
display screen to the element with ids
id1 basically so save it
and if we write a 86
plus 4
and if we click on this equal button
okay
so we have to write here dot value
save it now and if we
write here 86 plus 4 you can see the
answer is 90. the mistake was here we
have written val here instead of value
so it's working fine now next up what we
have to do is we have to clear the
display screen on clicking this
c button right
so first we'll use this function we'll
create another function for
function clear screen and then we'll use
this function with the on click event
inside the button c
right so we'll go back to our html file
we'll write here on
click
and inside this we will write let's say
clr a function name is clr
so what we'll do is we'll
define another function here we'll write
your function clr
and what we'll do is
to clear the display area we have to
provide empty space to this area right
so for that we have to write here
we have to again
use document.getelementbyid
the id is id1 for the display area dot
value
is equals to
the value will be empty space right so
this single statement will clear the
display area and calculator is finally
ready
so save it
and
if you can see here we'll write here 89
and then we'll press c
so you can see on clicking the c the
display area is going blank again and if
we write here let's say 58 plus 2 is
equals to 60 so we have the correct
answer as well and on clicking the c
button the display area goes blank again
right so let's start using this
calculator any expression will write
inside the display area will get
evaluated and will have the answer in
the same display as well
so let's try so we'll write a bit
complex equation here so we'll write
here let's say 74 into 3 plus
divided by 5
so the answer will be first it will
divide 55 by 5 then it will multiply 74
and 3 and then it will show the answer
so if we press this equal button so you
can see the answer is 233 right
so this calculator is working totally
fine you can check the answer by
yourself as well so this is how we can
create a basic calculator in javascript
and you guys saw it in today's video the
benefits of using javascript is
javascript provides the user with so
many such functions like the eval
function making the daily life of a
programmer easy and exciting
we have been discussing specific methods
of accessing an element for the past few
videos
now today we are going to discuss
something different before going deep
into this topic let's recall events in
javascript so the simple definition of
an event states that something that
happens so when we manipulate an html
document in javascript we try to do
something on the web page right so
several events take place on a website
like the user hovers over a specific
element or clicks on an element
or pressing a key in the website can
also refer to events
or we can say submitting a form or
playing a video also refers to the same
thing so we are using the on click event
for the past few videos wherein we
discussed that a specific task would be
performed on clicking a particular
button what we did was we were just
calling a function by clicking a button
in html so clicking a button is also an
event right and the function that will
be called upon clicking the button is
known as event handler because that
function is basically asking the
computer to perform a particular task on
clicking the button
so like the on click event we have some
more exciting events present in html
which helps us make a web page more
interactive and responsive as well so we
can do it with the help of javascript so
we'll go through two such events today
the on mouse over event and the on mouse
out event so the on mouse over event
will perform a task when the user takes
the mouse cursor on that element
similarly the onmouseout event also
performs a task when the user takes the
mouse cursor away from that element so
for example let's suppose we have an
image present in our web page and we
want to change the size of that image
when the user takes the mouse cursor
over that image and the image should get
back to its previous size when the user
takes away the cursor so what's
basically happening is when the user is
taking its mouse over the image or
picture the picture size will increase
and on taking the mouse cursor away from
the image the size will get back to its
default
size so let's do it once and we'll see
how these events work within an html
document
so first of all let's add an image to
the html file we'll use the img tag for
that and we'll have to provide the path
for the image right so
we'll write here
in a html file we'll add an image here
so we'll write here img and then we have
to provide the source
and the images are stored inside the
images folder in this system so we'll
write here
the image name so we have provided the
path here next up what we'll do is we'll
use the alt attribute so we'll write
here in the alt we'll write it simply
code
fine
save it
and here you can see we have an image
over a browser but the image size is
quite large right so we'll limit the
size of this image using the width
property so what we'll do is we'll write
here
width
and let's say the width of the image
will be 250 pixel
save it and now you can see we have an
image over here the image is in its
normal size so this is the image so we
have this image over here and next thing
what we are going to do is we are going
to increase the size of this picture on
taking the mouse cursor over this image
so what will happen is when we take our
mouse cursor here the picture size will
increase so for that we have to use the
on mouse over property
or we can say the on mouse over event so
what we'll do is we'll write here on
mouse
over
and we'll call a function on taking the
mouse cursor over this image so we'll
write here change size
so we'll declare it in a javascript file
and we'll call this function on taking
the mouse cursor over this picture
so next thing we are going to do is
we are going to
move to a javascript file and we will
define this change size function there
so lets
go to the javascript part we will go to
a js file and weill write here weill
declare a function first so we'll write
here function change size
and then we have the body of this
function so
we can do it without taking any variable
like in the previous videos we were
taking a variable to store the reference
of
the id attribute so this time we are
going to use the document.getelementbyid
but we are not going to use a separate
variable for storing the reference so
we'll write here
document dot get element by id and we
haven't provided the id so let's do one
thing let's move back to a
html file and we'll use the id attribute
here as well inside the img tag we'll
write a id
let's say the id is
img-1 right
save it and
we'll
right here inside the js file we'll give
the id here as well so we have the ids
img1
save it and the next thing we are going
to do is we are going to use the style
property with this
document.getelementbyid method so we'll
write here dot style
and then we'll write a dot width
and then we'll specify the width so
we'll write here the width as let's say
500 pixels the default width is
250 pixels right so save it and let's
see if it's working fine or not so here
is the image on the browser and we'll
take the mouse cursor over the image and
you can see the change in the size of
this picture so javascript makes it easy
to do such tasks now you might have
noticed that the images size remains the
same once the user takes the mouse
cursor away from the image right so the
image size is changed let me zoom out a
little bit so it will be easy for you
guys so what we'll do is we'll refresh
this page and here you can see on taking
the mouse cursor over this image the
change in the size of this particular
picture
so now the image size is 500 pixel
now the image size is not getting back
to its original size like what we did
was we use the on mouse over event and
the image size is changing and that's
working totally fine so the next thing
we are going to do is we are going to
use the on mouse out event and what will
happen is
the image size will get back to its
default size like which is the 250 pixel
so we'll for that we'll use another
function so first we have to use the on
mouseout event here
so we'll write here on mouse out and
we have to create another function so
we'll write a change size 2
so this will be a function name save it
and here we have to create another
function in the javascript file so we'll
write here function change size and the
function name is change size 2
then we have the body of this function
and we'll use the
document.getelementbyid method
the id is same which is img1 and then we
are going to use the style property
again and this time we'll
specify the width as
250 pixel so this is the default size of
our image save it so what we did is we
created a function that will be called
when the user takes away the mouse
cursor from the picture and the image
size will be changed to 250 pixels which
was the initial size of the image
so save it
and now you can see here on the browser
the image size is changing on taking the
mouse cursor over the image the image
size is 500 pixel now and on taking the
mouse cursor away from the image the
image is getting back to its default
size right so you can see the change
here so this is how we can use these
events to make our web page more
interactive and attractive as well next
up we'll go through another example
wherein we will change the image on the
mouse over event and the default image
will be shown on taking the cursor away
from the image so this image will change
on taking the mouse cursor over it and
again it will get back to the default
image on taking the mouse cursor away
from the image so guys here's the code
for the same and what will happen is the
image will change on taking the mouse
cursor over it and gets back to the
default on taking the cursor away so
guys the html part will remain the same
wherein we use the img tag to add an
image and then we have two functions one
for the on mouse over and another for
the on mouse out event so in the
javascript file we defined the two
functions here so you can see the
function one is change image and the
function two is change image two so
what's happening is we are using the get
element by id method again and this time
we are using the src attribute and what
we are doing is we are changing the
source of image like we are using here
the simplylearn.png
so this is our image saved in the
particular folder inside the images
folder and in the next function what we
are doing is we are again changing the
image to the default image so we have
used the
simplico.png image here so what will
happen is the default image will be
replaced by this image when this
function is called and the other
function here will again replace the new
image with the default one so let's take
a look at the output and
save it
so
here you can see on taking
mouse cursor over this image you can see
the change so this is the image we want
to change so on taking the mouse cursor
away from this image you can see the
image gets back to the default one you
can see the image is changing and it's
quite responsive and attractive
so this is how we can use these events
in javascript
functions in javascript are a block of
code that is used to perform a specific
task we use functions for different
purposes right whether it be a button
click or we want to zoom out our image
by taking the mouse cursor over it we
use functions for all these tasks
in javascript we can use functions as
objects at the same time we can pass
objects to functions as parameters right
so similarly we can also pass a function
inside another function
if i take you through the programming
part of this concept the syntax will be
like we'll go to a javascript file and
the syntax will be like will
declare a function let's say the
function is function abc
then
here we'll pass a parameter let's say we
are passing call as parameter for this
function abc next up what we'll do is
we'll call this function inside this
function abc
now what we did here is really simple we
created a function abc right next up we
passed a function called as a parameter
to this function and then we also call
this function inside the function abc so
this syntax is valid in javascript and
also this particular code here is known
as the callback function in javascript
so if we talk about the definition of
callback function it states that a
callback function is a function that is
passed to another function as an
argument
and that particular function will get
executed later in the program
now you guys might have heard in the
previous videos that javascript is a
single threaded language or javascript
works over a single statement at a time
or we can say javascript works in a
particular top to bottom order
so if we talk about the sequence in
which javascript actually works while
coding so let's take an example for this
and we'll see the sequence in which
javascript will work so what we'll do is
we'll comment this code and we'll start
writing our new code here so let's
suppose we have three functions in a
single program so let's say we have a
function as function1
and then we have two more functions so
let's say the second function is
function2
and then we have
function 3 as well
now if we write something inside these
functions so we'll execute the program
and what will happen is all the three
functions will be executed sequentially
so let's try to do it first
so what we'll do is we'll
right here inside the body of function
one so let's say we are using console
dot
log and
inside this will print
function one on calling this particular
function
so we'll do the same for other two
functions as well so we'll copy it from
here
we'll paste it here and here as well so
for function two it will print function
and for function 3 it will print
function 3.
so let's save it and before checking the
output so what we'll do is we'll call
these functions as well so let's say we
are calling function one then function
two
and then finally function
three
right everything we have done till now
is quite understandable and we have
three functions here and all the three
functions will get executed in the
sequence in which we call them so here
in this case we have called function one
first followed by function two and
function three
so let's check the output
save it and will open the console in the
browser so we'll right click here go to
inspect elements
and here you can see we have a console
here so here you can see we have the
output as function one function two and
function three so we have the output in
sequence we call function1 first so we
have the output as function1 but if we
call function3 before function2
so we'll cut this from here and we'll
paste function2 after function3
save it and here you can see we have the
output as function 1 then function 3 and
then function 2.
so javascript will execute these
functions in the order in which we call
them right now what if we use the set
timeout function with function1 so let's
try to do it first
so instead of calling function1 alone
here we'll write here set timeout
then we have to pass two parameters here
one is the function name so one is the
function name here
and we'll write here the time so time
here will be in milliseconds so 2000
milliseconds here represents two seconds
this means that the function will be
called after two seconds
right
so this set timeout function will call
function one after a specific period of
time that is in this case two seconds
what will happen is javascript will
start executing all the functions and
the system will find out that there is a
timer with function1 so in this case the
system will leave this particular
function on execution
and will move ahead and execute other
function so function1 will be executed
automatically after 2 seconds so let's
check the output save it and you can see
here we have function three and two over
here and function one will be executed
after some time so i hope you guys got
this here we have used the set timeout
method and function one will be executed
after two seconds
now let's consider a scenario where we
have only two functions let's say we
have function one and function two
so let's remove this function three
and we are left with only two functions
so let's say we have function one and
function two now
now what we want is we want to execute
these two functions but we have certain
conditions
so the first condition is function
function1 will use the settimeout method
and it will be executed after 3 seconds
and the second condition is function2
will get executed only after function1
executes so till now what we have seen
is if we are using these two functions
and if we are using the settimeout
method with function1 what is happening
is
javascript will keep this function on
execution and it will execute this
function till then so what we want is we
want to execute function 2 only after
the execution of function 1. this is
where the concept of callback functions
comes into play so we have to ask the
computer to execute function2 only after
function1 is done
so let me write the same code in another
way we'll use the settimeout method
within function1 so what we have to do
is we have to change
it here
to one we'll call function1 from here
and inside this function one what we'll
do is we'll write here set
timeout then we'll pass the first
argument as function
and then inside the body of this
function we'll write this console log
fine and we have to pass two parameters
here right so the next parameter will be
in the time so time here will be
3000 seconds so here we are and we are
done with our set timeout function now
this is another way of using the set
timeout method in javascript so what we
did here is we have passed the function
here as an argument and then we have the
body of function1 inside the set timeout
function
what we want to do next is we want to
execute function2 once function1 is
completed so before that let's do one
thing let's check if it is working fine
or not so we'll save it
and here you can see we have function2
executed before function1 right so it's
working totally fine now what we want to
do is we want function 2 to execute only
after function 1 is done right so let me
tell you a shortcut for that guys it's
not call back functions but it's kind of
same thing it will do the same thing as
the callback functions but it is a
different concept
so what we have to do is we have to cut
this function to from here
and we have to call this function inside
here
inside the set timeout method
so we'll paste it here and we have to
call function2 inside the settimeout
method so save it
and now if we wait for three seconds and
here you can see we have both the
functions function one and two executed
on time so both the functions are
executed after three seconds
and this is not callback functions but
this is a shortcut for that what
happened here is
when function1 is being executed the
system came to know that the function2
is called inside the settimeout method
so what will happen is it will first
execute the settimeout method and then
it will execute the function 2.
so what we did just now is not callback
functions but the functioning of a
callback function is also the same this
is the same thing we'll do with callback
functions but the syntax will be
different
now by the definition of the callback
function that we came across earlier it
states that a callback function is a
function that is passed to another
function
as an argument so keep your focus on
this word argument and that particular
function will be executed later that
function which we passed as argument
will be executed later
so here in this definition later means
once the system is done with the first
function or we can say the primary
function
it is now free to perform function 2 or
the secondary function or the callback
function we can say
so we have kept it on hold till now so
let's take an example of that as well
what we'll do is we'll create a function
and we'll pass an argument inside this
function
the value will be provided while calling
the function so
let's do one thing first let's comment
this code
and we'll write a new code here
so we'll create a function let's say a
function is function
person and we'll pass an argument here
so let's say the argument is friend
fine
next up we'll work on the body of this
function what we'll do is we'll again
use
console.log and we'll print something so
let's say we'll
write here
my
friend's name is
and then we'll use the plus operator
with the
value of friend
we'll write your friend
and with this we are done with our
function person next up what we'll do is
we'll write here
function
person
2 and we don't have to pass any argument
here so inside the body of this function
will again use console.log and we'll
write here
my name is
caution
fine
so
next up what we have to do is we have to
call these functions right so we'll
write a person
and inside this we have to pass the
value so let's say the value here is
simply good it's fine next up we'll call
person2
and we'll save this program so on saving
this program you can see we have the
output is my friend's name is simply
code so if you want me to zoom it you
can see here now
here it says my friend's name is simply
code and the second function says my
name is caution
right so this program is working totally
fine this is a basic program wherein we
created two function
and now what we want to do is we want
the function person2
will get executed after function person
so for that we have to pass function2 as
an argument in the function person
so we'll change the code
we'll pass this
function person2 as an argument so we'll
write here
person 2. we don't have to use brackets
here so because we are passing it as an
argument
now
we did it we passed this function as an
argument the next step is to tell the
function person about it right
we have to pass another argument in the
function so
we have to tell this first function that
we also have another function which will
get executed after this particular
function
so we'll write here
we can use any name we can use another
name for that or we can use the same
name as of function person2 so we'll
write here
person2
and then what we have to do is we have
to call this person2 function after this
right
now we are done with this code now we
are done with a callback function here
in this case this function person2 is
known as the callback function
so save it now
and
okay
what we have to do is we have to remove
this line from here so save it now here
you can see we have the output totally
correct we have the output as my
friend's name is simply code and my name
is caution
now we are done with almost everything
we are done with our callback functions
but
you might not see any change in the
output right to witness the change what
we have to do is we have to use the
settimeout method again because we want
this function to execute only after
function person so what we have to do is
we have to write here
inside function person we'll write here
set
timeout and
then we have
to write a function
and then
inside the body we'll do the same we'll
cut these two brackets from here and
we'll paste them here
and inside here we have to write the
time so let's say the time is
3000 fine
now what we did is we use the settimeout
method with function person and
inside the body it will print my
friend's name is and the friend's name
is simply good and it will be executed
after three seconds right
so let's save it and we'll count for
three one two and three so here is the
code you can see here the output says my
friend's name is simply code
and my name is kaushal so
this is working totally fine
so this is how the concept of callback
functions in javascript works we'll see
more about callback functions in the
upcoming videos
the word promise seems a bit familiar we
make promises regularly right if i say i
promise you that will cover everything
on promises in this video now this
promise that i made can only have two
possible outcomes either the promise
will be fulfilled or resolved or we can
say the promise can be failed or
rejected the promise will be resolved if
we'll cover everything on promises in
this video but if i left out some topic
or there is any subtopic within promises
which we forgot to cover in this video
that will be a failed promise or we can
say a rejected one
now there is another term in between
these terms that is pending
pending is the time in which the system
works on the promise
so just remember these terms as you may
hear them during an interview
so let's move on talking about a proper
definition of promises we can say that a
promise is an object which will produce
value sometimes it either gives us a
value or an error with the proper reason
there is no specific definition for
promises in javascript you will
understand the topic much better while
working on the syntax
so let's move ahead and we'll go through
a simple example first to understand a
promise in javascript
as we mentioned earlier that a promise
is an object so what we have to do first
is to take a variable and declare an
object so for that we'll go to a
javascript file and we'll write here
we'll take a variable let's say a
variable name is prom and we'll write
here new
promise so this statement here is a
promise we have an object named prom
next up this promise will take a
callback function we have already
discussed the concept of callback
functions in the previous video so if
you haven't watched that video yet i
recommend you to watch it so a callback
function is a function passed to another
function as an argument remember so
we'll write here
inside this
object we'll write here
function
and
now this callback function here will
have two arguments one to resolve and
another for the reject that's because we
can have only two possibilities in a
promise right either it can be rejected
or it can be resolved so we'll write
here
resolve and then after a comma we'll
write here reject fine then we'll have
the body of this function
so this is how
a promise will look like you can change
the name of these arguments instead of
resolve or reject you can write here
anything but we have kept it simple for
now so that it will be easy to
understand next up let's use a simple
condition here let's take the example of
driving a car fine
what we'll do is we'll take a variable
drive and we'll check if the user
learned how to drive a car if yes then
the promise is fulfilled otherwise the
promise is rejected
so let's do it here we'll write here
where
drive and let's set the value of this
drive as true for now let's say the user
learned how to drive a car
so next up what we'll do is we'll use
the if else conditional statement to
call any one of the two functions we can
either call resolve or reject right so
we'll write here if
and the condition will be
drive so if we left it with drive here
it will check for if drive is equals to
true right so we'll
call the function resolve if the
condition holds true
and then we'll use the else statement
for else we'll write it else and then
we'll write here
reject
fine
any value other than true will call the
reject function here so what we did here
was an easy task we know that the value
for the variable drive is true so in
this case the resolve function will be
called if we set this value of variable
drive to false
then the function reject will be called
the next part of the program is to
execute this promise so this will be the
longer part as we have to use two
methods here so for that the syntax will
start with the promise name and then
we'll use the dot operator so let me do
it here we'll write here
prom and then we'll use the dot operator
next up we'll use the then keyword so
this then keyword or
it is a method actually
it is called when the method is resolved
or when the promise is resolved so we
have another method for the rejection of
promises that we'll discuss afterwards
so we'll write here
prompt dot then
now this is a method so we will use
brackets here
when this method is called it means that
the promise is resolved we'll use a
callback function within this method so
we'll write here
function and
then we'll use
the resolve function here so we'll write
here
resolve fine
and then we'll have the body for resolve
so this is how the execution will look
like for promises
and on filling the promise there will be
a statement printed on the console
so it will be like we'll write here
console.log and we'll write here
something so let's say we are writing
here
resolve
and
let's say
the user
knows how to
drive
fine so we'll write here this
now we are done with the part in which
the promise will be fulfilled one thing
i forgot to mention here is we have to
pass
this resolve here so whatever value
we'll write here will be shown in
console so let's say we are writing here
for true value we'll write here yes
fine now if we save this program and
check for the output we'll get the
output as yes the user knows how to
drive we can check it so let's save it
and here you can see in the console we
have the output as yes the user knows
how to type let me put a space here so
let's save it now now it's clearly
visible so it says yes the user knows
how to try
so this is working fine now the next
part will be for the condition if the
promise gets rejected so just like we
had
the then method for resolving the
promise similarly we have one more
method for the rejection part
so for the rejection part we have the
catch method so we have to change this
method here only after the then method
so we'll come here and we'll write dot
catch
and the rest of the syntax will remain
same so we'll write here function
and then we'll
call
reject
then we'll have the body of this reject
part and we'll write here inside this
console.log
and we'll write here reject
plus
the user
does not
know
how
to drive
fine the catch method uses the reject
function and the output will be no the
user does not know how to drag
so before that will have to pass an
argument here so we'll write here
no
and save it now so for now it says yes
the user knows how to drive
to check for the reject method we have
to set the value of variable drive as
false so let's change the value here
let's say we are using
false here
now save it and you can see here the
output says no the user does not know
how to drive fine so this is working
totally fine now you guys might be
thinking that this program we just did
is so easy we could have done it with if
else conditional statements then why are
we using promises for this the syntax is
extended and we have to remember a lot
of terms and methods for a promise right
the good part is this was just an
example to make you understand the
syntax of promises in javascript
next up we'll go through an example
wherein we'll discuss the dependency of
promises as well so let's move ahead and
in this example what we'll do is we'll
create three separate functions
let's suppose we want to learn promises
in javascript but for that we must know
about the concept of functions and
callback functions in javascript then
only we can go through promises so what
we'll do is we'll create three functions
in which the current function will
depend upon the
previous function if the user knows
about functions he can go through
callback functions and if the user knows
both functions and callback functions he
is good to go for promises
so let me take you through the code guys
so here is the code we have three
functions the first one is for functions
topic so this functions is the topic
similarly we have callback and promises
as well so the first function is for the
functions topic and
if the user is done with functions in
javascript then he can move on to
callback functions and then to promises
so we have three different promises for
each function right so each function
here like the first function returns a
promise
right similarly all the three functions
are returning a promise here we are
directly resolving it we don't need to
wait for the user to learn functions
completely otherwise we can use here the
reject function as well
for now we are just resolving it which
means that the user learned functions in
javascript already the same goes for
callback functions and promises as well
next up what we have to do is we have to
execute the promise that once the user
is done with functions he can move on to
callback functions and then to promises
so for that we have to execute promise
like this only
but the syntax will be different so let
me show you guys
so here is the code for that as well
what we did here is we use the first
function here
so functions is our first function and
on resolving we call the function
callback with the result and we did the
same thing again for a callback on
resolving the callback function it will
call the promises function and finally
it will print this good to go message on
the console with the previous messages
returned by the resolve method
so we are basically working on the
dependency of promises in javascript
now let's save this program and we'll
check the output on the console so
save it and here you can see it on the
console it says
good to go and then it says learned
functions learnt callback functions good
to go for promises in javascript
now this same program can be done with
the help of callback functions as well
but the code will be so confusing
because we have to nest all these
functions inside a single function and
then it will be a mess right the code
with promises is clean you can see here
the code is clean all we had to do here
was to create functions then return
promises on call and then we can execute
those promises with their dependency
so this is how promises in javascript
actually works
now we have been using functions in
almost every video since we came across
this topic whether it be
dom manipulation or using an event in
javascript functions are everywhere
right
so this concept of arrow functions
is just a change in the syntax of
declaring and defining a function
so let's go through the concept of
functions in javascript quickly so that
it will be easy to change the syntax
later what we'll do is we'll create a
function with multiple parameters and
then we'll create another function with
no parameter at all
so we know these concepts already so
let's write the code here
so we'll go to a javascript file
and we'll write code here so we'll write
a function
let's say the function name is
function
and then this function have two
parameters a and b
now this function will return something
so we'll write here return
let's say this returns a plus
b
fine now the code we wrote here is to
find the sum of two numbers right we'll
pass the two numbers as arguments while
calling the function so let's check on
the console once if the code is working
fine or not so we'll save it
go back to the browser go to inspect
and then we'll go to a console and we'll
write here
function name and then we'll pass
certain parameters right so let's say
the parameters we are passing are 15 and
so the output we are expecting is 40 and
the output is correct we have the output
as 40. you can see here we have the
output as 40 here
so this function is working totally fine
next up we'll create another function
first and then we'll move to the arrow
function syntax
so for the second function we'll write a
function let's say the function name is
functo
and this function will have no
parameters at all right so let's say
this function prints something on the
console right so we'll write a
console.log and then
let's say this
function prints
welcome
to simply code
we are done with it so let's do one
thing we'll call this function here
we'll write a function calling the
function is pretty easy we can do the
same thing here as well so
let's save it and check the output here
you can see we have the output as
welcome to simply code in our console
so this is how we were using functions
till now the simple syntax for functions
right so let's move on to the concept of
arrow functions
now this function over here has two
parameters right this function has
parameters a and b and what we'll do is
we'll change the syntax of this function
and the new syntax will be more simple
once you get used to it so let's write
the newer syntax just below the previous
one we don't need the function keyword
with arrow functions so all we have to
do is we have to take a variable so
let's do it first so let's say we have a
variable
where
arrow one fine so this is a variable
this statement is simple we have a
variable named arrow
and this will be the function name so
arrow 1 will be the function name as
well right when we use the function
keyword in traditional syntax of
functions it automatically creates a
variable with the function name here we
have to declare the variable by
ourselves next up we have two parameters
here a and b as you can see here we have
a and b
we'll write the parameters within
parenthesis now so what we have to do is
we have to write
parameters so let's say the parameters
are a and b for this function as well
so these are the parameters we have to
write them within parenthesis
now we'll use an arrow that actually
makes this variable a function now this
is the main concept to create an arrow
what we have to do is we have to write
equals to and
then we have to write this so this is
the arrow mark which makes this whole
statement a function
and then we'll write the body of the
function so the body of function will
remain same so we'll copy the body from
here
and we'll paste it here so this function
here this function arrow one here is the
same as function function
and the output will be the same
this arrow function here has only one
line here so the advantage provided by
arrow functions in this case is quite
help
what we can do is we can make this
function a one liner if we remove this
return keyword and the curly braces here
so we can remove these curly braces as
well what we have to do is we have to
make this function a one-liner right so
there will be no difference now so this
is how the arrow function for this
traditional function looks like now both
the functions will return the sum of two
numbers the only difference is in syntax
let's check the output for the arrow
function as well so what we'll do here
is
we'll save this program and we'll
go to a console so let's do one thing
we'll call func one first and the
parameters let's say are
5 and 15
and then we'll call the arrow function
with the same parameters so we'll write
a arrow
comma
now
we have the output as 20 in both the
cases right so these two functions are
working similarly these two functions
are same the only difference is in the
syntax
next up we have another simple function
here and what we want to do here is to
convert this traditional function into
an arrow function right now we are
talking about function function so let
me comment this first function here what
we'll do is we'll comment this and now
we are good to go
so we have function function here now
what we'll do is we'll create an arrow
function for this function
so we'll write here
let's say we are writing here where
arrow two
and then we have no parameters so empty
parenthesis and then we have
the arrow
operator so the body will remain the
same we'll copy the body from this
function
and we'll paste it here
now we have used empty parenthesis here
because we don't have any arguments here
let's try to run this code we'll call
the function here only so
for this we have to write here
arrow two and we are good to so save it
and the output we are expecting is
welcome to simply code twice because we
are calling func 2 as well right so save
it
and here you can see the output is
welcome to simply code let's change
something here so what we'll do is for
arrow function we'll write here
simply learn
fine
so save it now and here you can see we
have the output as welcome to simply
code and welcome to simplylearn let me
zoom it for you if it's not visible so
here you can see the first output for
func 2 it says welcome to simply code
and for arrow 2 it says welcome to
simply learn
that's working fine
now before we wrap up this video let me
tell you another benefit of using arrow
functions so we already discussed that
we don't need to use the return keyword
if we are writing a one-liner function
similarly if we have a single parameter
we don't need any parenthesis we'll
create another function here so let's
say we are writing here
where
arrow 3
and let's say it has only a single
parameter as new name
fine
then we'll
use the arrow operator and then inside
the body of this we'll write here
console.log
and then we'll write here
here there
plus the name provided by us in the
argument so
now we are good to go this function here
will give us the output as hey there and
then whatever name will pass while
calling the function so let's check it
let's call this function as well so
let's say
we are writing here arrow 3 and
the name let's say will be
caution
save it and here you can see it says hey
there caution for arrow function 3 so
this is also working fine
and i hope you guys are now clear with
the arrow functions in javascript it's
not essential to use arrow functions
everywhere but now that we are clear
with promises and callback functions it
will be good to write minimum code and
the arrow function will help you with
that
now have you guys ever heard about
validation or pattern matching in
javascript we come across these terms
when we hear about passwords mostly
right
so we say that we can use the if else
statement to match if the user's
password matches with the one we already
have for that we write if password is
equal to is equals to some sort of
string or characters
and then we see if the password matches
will let the user enter otherwise the
entry will be denied so we are
discussing all that because regular
expressions are objects used to perform
pattern matching or if we want to search
for something in a string or even if we
want to replace something from a string
we can do it all with regular
expressions
so we'll go through the syntax for
regular expressions and some more
important things about regular
expressions in javascript so regular
expressions are present in almost every
programming language it's not limited to
javascript only and the concept remains
the same everywhere the syntax may
differ a bit between different languages
but the logic behind them will always be
the same the name might be a little bit
confusing but
the reality is entirely different they
are pretty easy to use and if you
understand the basics clearly you will
face no problem while working on
advanced topics so let's go through the
regular expressions before we move on to
validations using regular expressions in
javascript so let's understand the
concept
entirely so that it will be easy for you
guys in further videos so consider a
scenario where we have a string and we
want to find a particular word in that
string or we can say we are in a static
website i hope you guys are aware of the
term static where we have the search
option to find some word in the entire
html document we have to write the word
in the search box and it will return as
the location of that word in the html
file or in the website
right what we'll do now is we'll use a
word and we'll find that word in a
string will make some changes to that
word with the help of several functions
used along with regular expressions in
javascript so the syntax for regular
expressions goes like this we'll move to
a javascript file and we'll take a
variable here so let's say the variable
is where
rejects
and we use two forward slashes for it
generally we use the double slash for
comments but it will be recognized as a
regular expression in javascript if we
write something inside these double
slashes so let's say we are writing
something here let's say we write here
hello now
this word hello is present inside the
variable rejects and this word needs to
be searched in a string
so let's use a string as well so for
that we'll write here
where let's say the string name is str1
let's say we are writing here
welcome
to
youtube
channel
full stop
say hello
if
you are new here
fine so let's say this is the string we
have
now this string contains the word hello
in it all we have to keep in mind is to
add the main keyword in the string for
now
moving ahead what we want to do is we
want to find this word in the string
right we want to find this hello word in
this string so next up we'll go through
certain essential functions which we use
with regular expressions and we'll see
the functioning of these essential
functions the first function is the
exact function so let me write here guys
this is the first function exec
function
now this function returns an array if
the word is present in this string
otherwise it will return null if the
word is not present in the string the
syntax is pretty straightforward all we
have to do is to use the exact function
with the variable that contains the
regular expression now in this case the
word rejects contains the regular
expression we have to use it with the
function and the string name will be
passed as a parameter to this function
so let's write the syntax here and it
will be easy for you guys so let's
comment it out
and we'll write here let's say we are
taking another variable where output
will write here the
variable name
dot function name we'll write here exec
and the string will be passed as a
parameter fine
so this is the syntax now this output
variable over here will have an array
and the array will return the index
number of the word hello industry
fine so let's print this array on the
console and we'll write here
console.log
output fine
save it and open the console so we will
move to a browser and we'll open console
here
see here we have an array and if we
click on this array we can see that we
have
the word hello at index 36 so if we
count from here and the counting should
start from 0 because error index always
starts from 0 so at index 36 we can find
that hello is over here and so it will
return the index of this particular word
now
if we write here something else other
than hello let's say we are writing here
2 save it now and you can see here we
have 2 present at index 8 so if we count
from here we can see that 2 is present
at index 8 so this is working totally
fine now another scenario is if we write
here 2 with a capital t save it now and
you can see here the output is null
why so because regular expressions in
javascript are case sensitive case
sensitive means it differentiates
between the capital letters and small
letters fine
but the good part is we can make them in
case sensitive as well so all we have to
do is we have to use a modifier a
modifier is actually used to make
modifications in the search so what we
have to do is we have to write here in
the beginning we have to write a single
letter and in this case we'll write here
i because this modifier will tell the
system that there will be no problem
with the case sensitivity of the word
now
it will work fine and if we save this
program
we can see we have the output as index 8
now if we change this string and we'll
write here something other than this so
we'll write here h e
l o but
the three letters of this word are
capital letters
so save it now and you can see we have
the output as
index 36 so this is working fine now one
last situation is if we write here more
than one hello in a single string so if
we write here hello and welcome to our
youtube channel now there are two hello
words present in a single string save it
and you can see we have the word hello
at index 0. so it will return the first
hello world in the string now if we want
to get access of the second hello and
for if we write here this piece of code
again
what we are expecting is we are
expecting it
to give us the index of second hello as
well but it will not happen save it and
you can see it will give the index of
first hello twice you can see here we
have index as zero in both the areas
right so it will not work
now the solution to this problem is
modifiers again what we have to do is we
have to use another modifier here now we
have to write here the letter g and save
it
now this is returning null because we
have
the string wrong here so we have to
write here hello because we have removed
the in case sensitive modifier save it
now and you can see we have both the
hello words with indexes as 0 and 46
respectively so this global modifier
tells the system that the word is now
global and if you find the word once and
the user tries the exact function again
then the second time you should return
the index value of the second word
so this is how it actually works now the
following function we are going to
discuss is a pretty simple one the test
function
now this function returns either true or
false nothing else this function checks
for a particular word that if the word
exists in a string then it will return
true otherwise false
it will not return the index value or
some sort of other things
it deals with the boolean value only
that is true or false so that's it for
the function let's see how this function
works actually so what we'll do is we'll
mention here this test function
and will
comment this piece of code
so that there will be no
confusion
we'll comment it out
now we'll go through the syntax of this
test function the syntax is pretty easy
we'll use the output variable again
and we'll write here
variable name dot function name and the
string name will be passed as a
parameter
now the next thing we'll do is we'll
write here console.log
and we'll print this on a
console
fine so this is the syntax for test
function
save it
and here you can see in the console that
for the word hello it returns true if we
change this word here to something else
like if we write here hi instead of
hello
save it and you can see the output is
changed to false because high is not
there inside a string right because
height does not exist according to this
history
so this is how the test function
actually work now one more thing i want
to mention here about the test function
is if we write here some part of a word
not the whole word but some part so
let's say if we write here
e l
now this is the part of hello world now
what if we save this you can see the
output here is true that's because the
test function checks for every letter
and if it finds these three letters in
any word it will return true in that
case as well fine next up we have
another function to use with the regular
expressions in javascript now the next
function's name is match function
i'll write it here
first i'll comment these two statements
and then i'll write here the name of
this function so the name is match
now this match function returns an array
of results otherwise null the syntax for
this function is exactly opposite from
the previous functions
because we'll pass the regular
expression as a parameter to this
function now and the function will be
used along with the string
so
it is completely opposite to
the syntax we used for the previous two
functions so we'll write here for this
we'll use the output variable again
we'll write here where
output and
instead of regex we'll use it with this
string so we'll write here
str1.match
and
the variable name will be passed as a
parameter
fine so this is how the syntax for match
function looks like it's exactly
opposite to the syntax we used for
previous two functions the next line
will remain the same we'll write here
console.log and we'll print
output on a screen fine now we have to
do one more thing here what's that is we
have to remove this modifier from here
and we have to write here
hello
so save it and you can see we have an
array over here now what if we want to
find both the words in a string if we
have if we want to check if there's more
than one word with the similar name so
what we have to do is we have to write
here g and if you save it now you can
see the output is completely changed and
now we have an array with two similar
words what if we add another hello here
so let's say we have another hello here
save it and you can see here the array
size is increased to three now now we
are left with one more method and the
method we are going to discuss now is
pretty important because we'll use this
method in future as well so the last
method is the replace method which is
used to replace something from a string
we can either replace the first matching
word or all the matching words from a
string if we are using the global
modifier then all the words will be
replaced otherwise the first matching
word will be replaced
so the syntax for this method goes like
this
what we have to do is so let's comment
it out first and we'll go through the
syntax of final method so the final
method is
replace method
fine
so the syntax goes like this we'll use
the output variable again
and we'll write here
str1
dot replace because we want to replace
something in that particular string the
first parameter will be the
variable name we'll write here regex
comma and then we'll pass
the word we want to change so hello will
be changed with let's say in this case
hi
fine
now check over here that if we are using
any modifier so we are using global
modifier here
now if we print this on our console if
we write a console.log and
we are writing here output
if we save it now we'll get to know that
all the hello words in the string are
replaced with the word hi
save it and you can see over here that
hi and welcome to a youtube channel say
hi if you are new here and then we have
a hi you can see that all the hello
words are replaced with the word hi
now if we remove this global modifier
from here and if we save it now you can
see only the first hello world is
replaced the other hello words are here
and there will be no change in them
because we are not using the global
modifier now in the previous video where
we came across regular expressions in
javascript we saw different predefined
functions that we use for finding a
particular expression present inside a
string right like the predefined
functions we also have some javascript
characters that make the searching part
easy
so these characters are used within the
expressions and help us in different
ways for example let's consider a
scenario where we have a regular
expression and we want to find a
particular word within the string
but we don't remember the whole word
let's say we forgot the word with time
and now we remember only a part of that
word so let's do the same side by side
and what we'll do is we'll go to our
javascript file
and we'll take three variables
we'll write here let regex is equals to
then we'll write here let str1 is equals
to
and then finally we will write
where output is equals to
fine
now here we have three variables the
variable rejects will store a regular
expression within it we haven't returned
the word yet next up we have a variable
str1 to store the string and a variable
output to store the output returned by a
function the function we'll use will be
any one of the ones we used in the
previous video so let's do it here
the word let's say
the word will be
welcome fine
you can take any word you want now
moving on to the string let's write the
string as well we'll write here welcome
to our youtube
channel and then we'll write another
welcome here
fine
we'll discuss the reason why we wrote
welcome twice now if you guys remember
from the previous video where we have
used the test function to check the
availability of a word present in a
string or not we'll use the same
function again so we'll write
here variable name
dot
function name so the function name is
test and then we'll pass the string name
as the parameter so we'll write here
str1
that's
fine and finally what we'll do is we'll
print this on our console so we'll write
a console.log
output fine now we already know the
output for this piece of code right the
output will be true that's obvious
because we have the word welcome present
in our string not once but twice
the output will remain true if we remove
the first welcome from the string let's
do it here let's save the program first
and then we'll move to the console
and you can see here the output says
true for the word welcome present in the
string str1 that's true right
and now if we remove this welcome word
from here and if we save it you can see
the output still remains true because we
have another welcome word present in the
string right
so this is how the test function
actually works we'll put the welcome
word here again we already know the
functioning of this test function the
main point of discussion here is the
meta characters so meta characters are
characters with special meanings
like the dot character if we write this
regular expression like we can remove
any one character from this word and put
a dot in its place let's do it
we'll remove a random character and
write dot here so let's say
we are removing
l
fine and instead of l we are putting a
dot here
now the dot character here will replace
this character and the system will not
throw any error
it will still find the word we can also
use exact function here to check the
index number of the word so what we'll
do is we'll take another variable
and we'll do the same we'll write here
regex dot
exec
and then we'll pass the string name as
parameters
fine
we will copy this console.log from here
and we'll paste it here
the variable name is op
save it
and here you can see
we have the output as true for the test
function and for the exact function it
returns the index number 0 of the word
in the string now the system
automatically puts a l in place of the
dot character similarly if you want to
do the same thing for more than one
character we have another meta character
for that it's not that we can't use this
dot operator but we can use it for a
limited time like we can use it for a
single character but if we want to put
more than one character and we don't
know the number of the characters so
then we have another meta character for
that the meta character is asterisk
now this asterisk allows us to put
multiple characters within a particular
expression for example if we write here
let's remove all this
and we'll put
star or asterisk in place of all the
characters in between so save it and you
can see the output returns true
for
test function and for the exact function
the index is
0.
now if we write here something like that
and we don't know what it is but let's
assume it so if we save it now you can
still see the output returns true for
this as well
because
now we can put any number of characters
in between w and e the only thing that
matters is the first and the last
character of the word welcome
now
the next character we'll be looking at
does not work the same way as these
characters the carrot character works
upon a whole string let's go through the
syntax and what we'll do is
we'll remove this
unwanted piece of code and then we'll
come here we'll write here
welcome again
and now we'll put this carrot character
now the carrot character is this
character so
what this character returns is this
character returns true only if the whole
string starts with the word welcome the
second welcome word does not even exist
for this meta character if we save this
program now it will return true because
welcome is present at the start of this
string right so save it
and you can see the output is true now
if we remove this welcome from here
and if we save this program now we know
that we have another welcome present in
the string but this character does not
work
that way
and it will return false because the
string starts with 2 now right
save it and here you can see the output
is false for test function and for exact
function the output is null it will not
return any index number of the second
welcome or some sort of thing so this is
how the carrot character works in
javascript
the next meta character does the same
thing but for the end of the string the
symbol is dollar and it checks for the
end part of the string this meta
character is placed at the end of a
regular expression and it checks if the
string ends with characters present in
the expression the syntax goes like this
what we'll do is we'll remove this
carrot character and we'll put a dollar
sign you
now this statement now will check if the
string ends with the word welcome or not
in this case the last word of the string
is
back right not welcome so the output
will be false save it
save it and you can see here the output
is false and null
suppose we write here back in place of
welcome now what we'll do is we'll write
here
back in place of welcome and if we save
this program now the output will change
to true because back is the last word
present in a string right so this
character checks for the end of the
string
save it and you can see the output is
changed to true and the index number is
find the exact function will return the
index number of the word back the last
meta character we will discuss in this
video is the optional meta character
the question mark symbol represents this
meta character and the functioning be
like
any character before the symbol is
treated as optional
this means that it doesn't matter if the
character is present in the string or
not for example
if we write here let's say
we'll
write here welcome again because welcome
has more characters than back and we'll
write here
welcome as well
fine
now let's make some changes in this
particular regex expression
so what we'll do is we'll put a question
mark here
and let's say we'll put another question
mark here fine now if we remove c and e
from the string or any one of them then
also the function will work fine and the
output will be true let's do it and what
we'll do is we'll make some changes in
this particular string and we are going
to remove some characters from this
string so we have two welcome words
there and what we'll do is we'll remove
c from this one and we have two optional
characters right both c and e are
optional but for now we are removing c
only so the string looks like this we
have the word vellum it doesn't mean
anything but for understanding purposes
we have done it so save it and you can
see the output remains true for vellum
now what if we put any other word in
place of this character
let's say we are writing here b
fine
the output will change we have to put an
o as
because o is not an optional character
now the output
will change
as we were discussing if we save this
program you can see it is true for now
but it is saying true because of this
welcome now if we remove this welcome
from here and if we save it now you can
see the output is changed to null
yes these characters are optional but we
can't put any character in place of them
we have two options only either we can
put c in its place or we can leave it
so there's no other option with the
optional characters so these are the few
meta characters present in regular
expressions which helps in validation a
lot we came across meta characters in
regex in the previous video where we saw
how to check the availability of a
particular word or expression within a
string we know about functions as well
so today we will combine all these
things to some extent and we'll see how
basic validation actually works in
javascript we'll see an example wherein
we'll go through the character sets and
ranges and check for some specific type
of validation in this video
now the topic character sets and ranges
itself is a pretty explanatory topic and
we can get an idea of what's coming just
by going through the words characters in
layman term refers to alphabets and
numbers right we see a character on a
daily basis and we know a lot about them
now if i write here a
we can say that this is a character in
javascript now we can use one single
character or a group of characters at a
time with regular expressions in
javascript we have a particular syntax
for it we'll go through the syntax first
and the syntax is like we have to use
square brackets and we have to write
characters in between these brackets or
inside these brackets
here we have three characters a b and c
what we can do is we can give
instructions to the system to use any
one of them in a regular expression
so let's take a small example of how
this actually works with regular
expressions and what we'll do is we'll
do the same thing we have been doing
till now we'll search a word within a
string will check that if a word exists
within a string or not so we'll do it
like we'll take a variable regex
that will contain the regular expression
so this is
the syntax for regular expression and
this is a regular expression which says
d e f so in actual this is not a word
but assume it as a word for now and what
we have to do is we have to include
character sets with this regular
expression right so we'll write here
inside square brackets abc
now the next thing is we'll define the
string let's say the string name is tr1
and the string says
this string contains adef
so def
or we can say adf is what matters the
most for now so anything else you can
write on the string the next thing we
are going to do is we are going to
use the test function
to check if this particular regular
expression
is available in the string or not so
we'll write here regex dot
test and inside this will pass the
string as a parameter
now the last thing we'll do is we'll
write here console.log and
we'll print this on our console fine
we are done with it so what we are doing
here is we want to search the string for
a word which contains the letter def
compulsory but before def we can have a
character that character can either be a
b or c no other character will be taken
in front of def because we have defined
a character set as well right and that
character set contains only three
characters a b and c
so
here you can see we have adef present in
the string and we have a along with def
so
what we are expecting is this test
function should return true right so
save it and check for the output in the
console so we'll go to a console
and here you can see the output says
true because we have adef only
now if we write here anything else like
if we replace this a with the character
r
save it and you can see the output is
false because r is not present inside
this character set now
what if we write here something like
let's say we are writing here
caution def now this will check for this
letter only for this l only other
letters don't actually matters in this
case in the case of character sets the
only character that matters is the
character right before the regular
expression
so if we save it you can see the output
is changed to false and if we write here
let's say
caution adef save it and you can see the
output is true because it checks for
this character only fine
talking about ranges let's say we want
to add any character in the string
between a to z now we have two options
to do so first one is we can write a b c
till z here like we'll write here d e f
g h i and so on and so forth tills it
but this task is a little bit lengthy
right and we have to spend a lot of time
in that process so the alternate to this
process is to define a range of
characters to define a range of
characters it's quite an easy task all
you have to do is write a
hyphen z so this is how you can define a
range of characters now this range will
consist every character from a till z a
and z will also be included keep this
thing in mind if we write here caution
df again so we have seen in in the
previous example that it returned false
for this right save it now and you can
see the output is still true
that's because now we have a range from
a till z
if we write here 5 now now it will
return false because 5 does not lies in
between this range in between a to z so
it will return true for any character
between a till z fine
now let's say we want to exclude some
particular characters from this range
like we don't want the user to include
def again no character from d e or f so
the syntax for that is also pretty easy
we have to use the carrot operator and
we have to write here but we don't want
to include so let's say in this case we
don't want to include def fine so if we
write here ddef now and save it you can
see
it will return false because we have
included ddef and if we write here adef
save it and you can see the output is
true
now we can't include characters
d e and f in front of this regular
expression because we have defined this
character set to not include these
characters in the regular expression
so these are characters and ranges in
regular expressions so the next thing
we'll be doing is we'll be going through
a basic validation example and we'll see
how actually basic validation works in
javascript
what we'll do is we'll create a small
html form that will take the employee id
from the user and it will check if the
employee belongs to the organization or
not
so let's say the employee id of the
organization has some unique characters
present in it
and the character remains there in each
employee id
the idea is simple we'll take the id
from the user and we'll use if else
control statement to check if it belongs
to the organization or not so let's move
on to the html file and we'll create a
placeholder and a button so
let's do it
we'll write here
form
and inside this form tag
let input
id is equals to
eid
and
placeholder is equals to
employee id
and
type is equals to
text fine
the next thing we are going to do is we
are going to include a button as well
button and we are going to call a
function on clicking so we'll use the on
click event so we'll write your own
click and let's say the function name is
employee
and the button name is let's say submit
save it and you can see over the browser
that we have a placeholder along with
the button so let me give a space here
save it now and you can see we have a
placeholder and a button so that's all
what we have to do in html part now the
rest of the thing will be doing in the
javascript file so let's move to a
javascript file
and comment
this piece of code first
now what we want is we want to call a
function employee on clicking the submit
button fine so what we'll do is we'll
define a function employee
and inside the body of this function the
first thing we will be doing is we'll be
taking
the user's id right so we need a
variable for that so let's say the
variable is
mpid and we'll write here
document
dot
get element by id the id is
eid
dot
value fine now this empid variable will
hold the value entered by the user right
so like if we write here something like
d2386 so let's say this is the id this
will be stored the value for this id
will be stored inside this empid
variable fine
now we'll use the regular expression to
check for some special characters so
we'll write here
inside the function we'll write here
where
check is equals to
inside the regular expression we'll
write something so let's say we want to
start the employee id for the
development team with the alphabets dnd
and each id will have a similar numeric
code like 253 which represents the code
for a particular team fine
so we'll write here inside the character
sets
we want de to be there before a similar
numeric code right so
253 is the numeric code and we want to
include either d or e
before that right
and
after 253 let's say we have a range of
numbers that each employee id has a
unique two digit number the id should
look like
either
d
2 5 3
1 1 or either
e
2 5 3
6 1
something like that right
now so for that what we have to do is we
have to include here another range and
this range will be from 11
oh so this range will be from 10 till 99
fine
this looks a bit complex now but if you
try to do it by yourself believe me guys
you'll find it out that this is an easy
task but a little lengthy we can say now
the next part is we have to validate the
id entered for that we have to use the
if else control statement along with the
test function
so we have to write here
if
check
dot test and inside this we'll write
amp id because empid is the variable
which is holding the value entered by
the user right so if it's true then it
will return
an alert box with the message that says
valid
employee id
fine
else
it will
return a message in the pop-up
which will say
invalid
id fine
so this if else statement will check the
value returned by the test function if
the value returned is true it will
return a message valid employee id
otherwise the else statement will run
and the user will get a pop-up with the
message invalid email id fine
let's check the output and in the
browser here we'll write the employee id
in the
given placeholder so let's say the
employee id is d
2 5 3
1 9
submit it and you can see it says valid
employee id we can do it for some mode
like if we write here e
2 5 3
9 8
submit it and you can see it still says
valid employee id now what if we want to
include any character between this range
and the unique number right so let's try
to do it we'll write here d
k
89 fine so let's say this is the id we
want to enter submit it and you can see
it says invalid employee id
now one more thing we want to do here is
like if we write yet
d 253
okay 8 9
in this case it will return
false or invalid employee id why because
we haven't included any modifier here
and it will differentiate between
uppercase and lowercase character so to
overcome this problem what we can do is
we can include the in case sensitive
modifier and we are clearly good to go
now if we write here d25398
and save it if we write here now d
2 5 3
9 8
submit it
and you can see here the output says
valid employee id
so this is how we can use validation
along with regular expressions
in the last video we came across
character sets and ranges we saw how we
could use them with regular expressions
and we also saw how to validate a user's
input with the help of character sets
and ranges along with regular
expressions now in this video we'll look
at the shorthand character classes
present within regular expressions and
we'll see how they are helpful in
javascript
if you guys remember the regular
expression we used became a bit
confusing and lengthy because we have
used so many ranges and character sets
all in one right a character class can
be used to overcome this particular
problem and we have several character
classes present in javascript so today
we will go through them in this
particular video now the syntax is not
too much complicated all we have to do
is to write a single character with the
backslash and we are good to
for example
if we go to a javascript file and if we
write here
backslash d
now if we write this character before
any regular expression in javascript it
means that we have added a character
class to a regular expression this
backslash d is a character class used
for finding a digit within a string
let's go through an example for this
character class
and we'll do the same thing we'll take a
string and try to find a regular
expression within that string so
what we'll do is
we'll write here
where
regex is equals to
and here we'll write a regular
expression
first we'll take up a string and use
some functions to check the output so
let's do it here what we'll do is we'll
take another variable let's say the
variable name is str1 and
the string says
users
phone number
is
9876543210
now let's say this is the string we are
using for today's program
the next thing we'll do is we'll use the
exact function to find the regular
expression within the string so we have
already gone through this exact function
in javascript today we'll use that
function only
now we'll write here where
output is equals to
rejects dot exec
and inside this will pass a string as a
parameter
the next thing we'll do is we'll write
here console.log
and we'll print this output on a console
now we are good to go
so we are done with it and the next
thing we want to do is to find a
particular pattern along
with the number present before that
pattern in the string so let's suppose
if we write here inside these slashes if
we write here let's say 3 to 1
now
this statement here asks the computer to
find a pattern three to one in the
string
save it
and go to the console so we'll move to a
browser and we'll press ctrl shift plus
i and here you can see we have a console
here and here we have an array as well
so here you can see it says
let me zoom it out a bit here you can
see it says
321 is present at index 28.
now
the system finds out that this
particular string or this particular
regular expression is present here in
the string at index number 28 obviously
the indexes will start from 0 and the
moment it will find this three to one
regular expression it will show
the index number in an array
in a console
now if we add
backslash d here let's say we are adding
here backslash d
in front of this expression and check
the output here save it you will notice
that we have a number present here right
before that expression
right we have 4 3 2 1 here instead of
just three two one the output here gives
us the number four this means that this
backslash d represents this number
four in this string now what if we put
an alphabet before this expression now
let's do it what we'll do is we'll write
here a
and let's say we are adding only a
single alphabet here let's say we are
adding a before 321 now the expected
output is a321 but the moment we'll save
it you can see it says null that's
because this particular character class
works for digits only if it finds
anything other than a numeric digit it
will return an error or it will return
null in that case now if we want to find
all the numbers before this pattern then
we have to add a plus operator in the
regular expression all we have to do is
we have to write here plus and we are
good to now it will return everything
until it finds a space or any character
other than a digit now let's suppose if
we are writing here a after 987
now this particular statement will
return all the numbers till 6 the moment
it will encounter a here it will return
all the numbers after a it will stop at
a and it will not go further now save it
and you can see it says six five four
three two one
that's because
this backslash d works for digits only
now if we write here nothing like we
have a number nine eight seven six five
four three two one zero save it and it
will return the whole number 987654321
not 0 because we haven't included any
number here
now if we write here again
backslash d after this as well save it
and here you can see we have the output
as
0 as well we have the whole number here
fine
so this is how this backslash d actually
works in javascript so this is a
character class
now
the next thing is what if we want to
find a non-digit character before a
particular pattern
if we write here
before 321 let's say we are writing here
a
and we want the system to return the
non-digit character before 3 to 1 in
that case we use capital d instead of
small d always remember guys every
shorthand character class in rejects
have an inverse that does
precisely the opposite of that
particular class like if we have small d
here that works for digits only we also
have an inverse which is denoted by
backslash capital d and it does exactly
opposite of this small d here
now if we write here
capital d in place of small d
what will happen is it will return the
character here it will return true for
everything other than a digit
now if we remove this small d from here
and save it
here you can see it says null because we
haven't included the backslash sign here
save it
and here you can see it says a321
it will return true for anything except
for a digit even if we put a symbol over
here then also it will return the output
as true for example if we write here
let's say we are including dollar sign
here let's say we are including two
dollar sign here save it and it will
return two dollar signs that's because
we are using the plus operator here
obviously let's include as many signs as
we can save it and here you can see we
have all the symbols present over here
on our output
so this is how capital d character class
works or we can say inverse character
class of small d this is how it works
now the next class we'll be going
through is the wordly character denoted
by the letter w small w and is used in
place of any character that can be an
alphabet a number or an underscore sign
we can use this character over d if we
are unsure about the character present
before the pattern for example if we
write here
let's say backslash w
ber
now here we have used the ber pattern
which is present at the end of
number right here ber is present at the
end of number now this statement will
return m only because we are not using
any plus operator here if we use any
plus operator then it will return the
whole number because it will return
everything until it encounters a space
or something like that
so for now we are not using any plus
operator so we'll be writing here this
only now here it will return m because
it can take up a number an alphabet or
an underscore sign it will return false
if it finds any space or something other
than these three these three means a
number an alphabet or an underscore sign
fine
now save it and you can see on the
console that the output says mber let me
zoom it a bit so here you can see the
output says mber right present at index
14.
it will return null if we put a space
before the pattern like if we write here
num space b er save it you can see it
says null for this now we can use the
plus operator as well here for this
particular character class now what will
happen is it will return every character
present before the pattern until it
encounters a space or something like a
symbol or any sort of thing so let's try
it what we'll do is we'll write here w
plus ber and we'll remove this space
from here
save it and here you can see it says
number what if we remove this space from
here remove it save it and here you can
see it says phone number it will return
every character before the pattern until
it finds any space or any other let's
say
symbol so let's say we are including
here dollar percentage
and carrot sign
save it and here you can see it says an
e number so it's returning it from here
because it will not return true for any
of the symbols here
save it and here you can see we have the
output as phone number again so that's
working totally fine
like the inverse character class for
digits we have the inverse character
class for this also and it returns true
for everything other than an alphabet
number or any underscore sign now if we
write here
instead of small w let's say we are
writing here capital w
and let's do something with the string
as well so let's put a space here again
and we are good to go we are not doing
anything more than that so it will
return null because before ber we have m
here right if we remove this m with us
sign let's say if you are removing this
with a dollar sign or with an empty one
like we are writing here space nothing
then it will return the index number and
the pattern
so let's do it save it
and here you can see it says dollar then
it says ber and index number is 14. you
can count the index number so 0 for u
and then similarly 1 for s 2 for e 3 4 r
4 for s up to 14 for dollar so dollar is
present at index 14 it will return the
index number here now the plus operator
also works for this inverse character
class as well right here plus ber and we
can insert as many characters or as many
symbols as we want so like here we have
inserted so many symbols this doesn't
mean anything but we are inserting them
for
example purposes or for practical
purpose so save it and here you can see
we have all the symbols present over
here in a array and the index number is
still 14. if we remove
these n and u from here now save it the
index number will change to 11
that's quite easy
now
the next class we have is the simplest
of all this class works for white spaces
only it means that it will return true
or give us the index number of the
expression
from the string only if a white space
exists before the pattern
it is denoted by small s and works for
spaces only now if we write here
let's say
backslash s
okay we have made a mistake we'll write
a backslashes
and we'll write your phone so
this is the pattern and this is the
character class backslash s is the
character class now what we'll do is
we'll
remove it from here and we'll
write the string
as this again we'll write a user's phone
number is this and this
now for this regular expression it will
return the index number of this space
the space is present at index 5
0 for u
1 for s 2 for e 3 for r 4 for s and this
space is present at index number 5 so it
will return index as 5 for this
particular space now don't get confused
guys for this index number as 5 the
index number is for the space present in
the screen before the pattern phone
right
now if we try to do the same for users
as well
let's suppose if we write here
users it will return null in this case
because there's no space present before
users in the string right save it and
here you can see the output says null in
this case
fine
now we can also use the plus operator
here for more than one spaces present in
the string it will return all the spaces
until it finds a character or something
other than the spaces like if it finds
any symbol or any character then only it
will return false otherwise for spaces
it will return true so if we write here
too many spaces if we put too many
spaces before the word
phone or let's say we are changing this
word to
phone
save it and here you can see we have all
the spaces here it's denoted by a single
space but the index numbers is changed
to 19. now we have so many spaces
present here before the pattern phone or
before the word phone so this is how we
can use
space character class in javascript
now we have also the inverse class for
this character class as well it returns
true for everything other than empty
spaces
if we write here
let's say we are removing this and let's
say we are right okay and let's say we
are
writing here users
and we are
giving so many spaces here before the
word users now it will return null in
this case because there are spaces
present in front of the word users
if we include a character or something
in front of this word then only the
output will change and return the index
number along with the string so save it
first and here you can see
okay we have used the smallest in place
of smallest we will write here capital s
save it and you can see here the output
says null for capital s because this
capital s will return true for
everything other than spaces only now if
we put here any symbol let's say we have
these symbols here
save it and here you can see now we have
a hash symbol present before the word
users that's because we have used
capital s only now if we use a plus
operator save it and here you can see we
have all the symbols present in a array
we have the index number as 11 we have
dollar percentage caret and hash present
over here right so this is how the
inverse of character spaces in
javascript actually work so these are
the character classes we have in
javascript choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
plus hours of video content for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
if you guys see we have two text boxes
over here one is for the username and
other one is for the password creating
such text boxes in html is quite an easy
task we have to use the input tag which
we discussed a few sessions back
and we are using some more properties
here
so you can see we have type as text for
username and for password the type is
password
so before we move on to validation with
javascript let me tell you guys that we
can do certain things with html as well
like if we want that none of the two
text boxes over here remains blank
we can write here inside these input
tags so if we write here required
save it and now if you try to click on
the submit button you can see it says
please fill out this field it will not
allow the user to submit the form until
there is any value present for the name
so if we write here any random name and
submit it now you can see the form is
getting refreshed that's because we have
used the form tag over here now if we
try to submit without writing anything
we'll get the pop-up as please fill out
this field and we can do the same for
password as well like if we write here
required and save it
now if you write any name over here for
the username and if we leave this
password field blank submit it you can
see it says please fill out this field
for password as well
so html can let you do all this stuff
but when it comes to actual validation
like if you want the user to enter only
if the name or password matches the one
present in the backend or maybe we can
say in the server
we have to use something more than html
now the case with javascript is a bit
different
if we talk about validation in
javascript we can use javascript for
client-side verification
the scenario here will be the one we'll
discuss in today's video what we'll do
today is we'll create a basic signup
form with three text boxes one is for
the username the other one is for the
password and we'll add one more box for
each
half of the work is already done and we
have to add one more box now for the age
so edge is just a number right so we can
add a text box over here what we have to
do is we have to write here
before the submit button will write here
input
type is equals to number
and we'll provided the id as well so
let's say the id is h we'll use the id
attribute later
and inside this placeholder will write
here h
save it and here you can see we have
three text boxes over here
inside the h we can't write any
character or alphabet because we have
defined the type as number for this so
we can write numbers here only now the
next part is to link this page to
another web page such that if the
credentials are correct the user will
enter the home page of our website for
that we have to use the action attribute
in html now the question here is when do
we want the user to enter the home page
only if the credentials are correct
right we have to use the action
attribute with the form tag so you can
see over here we have already mentioned
the form tag now what we'll do is we'll
write here action and what we want is we
wanted to redirect the user to another
page or another web page the home page
of our website after checking the
credentials and if the credentials are
correct the user will move on to the
home page so we have already a file
named homepage.html
so we'll write here homepage.ht
and save it now on clicking the submit
button okay we have to fill something
for
name and for password as well so we'll
write random values over here submit it
and you can see we have been redirected
to another page and this is the home
page of our website
however it doesn't look like a home page
still we can assume it right so now we
know what should be done if the user has
correct credentials to enter the home
page we are almost done with the html
part we'll make some more changes to
this file later the next thing we have
to do is to validate the credentials
entered by the user right for validation
purposes we'll use the if else control
statements in a javascript file will
create a function in a javascript file
and call that function when the user
clicks the submit button
but there is a difference will not call
the function on clicking the submit
button instead we'll call the function
on
submission of the form so instead of
writing here on click and then calling
that function what we'll do is
we'll write here inside the form tag
we'll write on submit so this is an
event and on submit what will happen is
it will call a function named validate
we'll create this validate function in
our javascript file now
so you can see here we have already used
the id attribute with all the input tags
in order to get the values entered by
the user so let's move on to the
javascript file and what we'll do here
is we'll first declare a function named
validate so we'll write here function
and the function name is validate
and then we have the body of this
function
now we'll take three variables to get
all the values entered by the user
because we need to check for all the
values right so we need to check if the
user's name and password match the one
we want and the user should be aged
above 13 to enter our website
for all these we need the values entered
by the user so we'll use the get element
by id method to get all the values now
for that we'll take three variables so
let's say the first variable is
unnamed it will hold the value entered
in the username text box
let me go to the form again
and here you can see we have three text
boxes username password each so we'll
take three variables
for username we'll write here
document.getelementbyid
and the id is unname
let me confirm it once so you can see
here
the id for username is
uni
for password it is pass and for h it's h
so we'll write here dot
value
the next thing we'll do is we'll create
another variable for password we'll
write here again document.getelementbyid
and the id is pass
we'll again write here dot value
and the third variable will be where age
it will hold the age of the user
so we'll again write a
document.getelementbyid
and id for ages h
we'll again use the dot value property
now we are done with the values
we have three variables holding all the
values entered by the user next up we'll
use these values to validate the data
entered by the user
now the first condition we can have here
is that we don't want the user to leave
any of the text boxes empty right
if we click on this submit button you
can see it says please fill out this
field now we can do it with the help of
html as well but for now we are using
javascript so we will remove these
required keywords
so that we can do it with javascript
only
save it
and submit it now you can see it is
redirecting us to the home page of our
website so it's working totally fine now
what we'll do is we'll write a condition
if the user leaves any of these fields
empty so we'll write here if
you name
is equals to is equals to blank
or
pass is equals to is equals to blank
okay
or
age
is equals to is equals to
blank
now what will happen is it will give the
user a pop-up with the message
let's say
the message is
missing
credentials fine
save it
and if we leave any of these fields
empty now a pop-up will appear with the
message missing credentials so the first
condition is done but there is a
loophole in this condition so let's
check it out first we'll
leave username and password empty submit
it you can see it says missing
credentials right now the next thing is
if we write here let's say a random name
and password as well but we are leaving
this age text box empty submit it it
still says missing credentials because
we haven't entered the h and it's
working totally fine
now there's a loophole in this condition
the exciting part is it will work fine
if the user enters more than one space
in all the fields like
if you are giving here spaces for more
than once and similarly for password as
well submit it
and you can see it says missing
credentials because we haven't filled
the h
so let's
do one thing we'll
write some spaces for username and
password and for h we'll say the age is
4. submit it and you can see we have no
error over here now to overcome this
problem we have a predefined javascript
method that treats all the spaces the
same
no matter the number of spaces whether
it be one or more than one it will treat
all the same we have to include the trim
method within the if else statement so
what we'll do is we'll write here dot
trim
for username and similarly for password
as well we'll write here trim
and for age as well let's say
dot trim
and save it now
move back to a sign up form and if we
try to give more than one spaces here
and let's say the age is four submit it
you can see it says missing credentials
for more than one spaces as well so this
is working totally fine now the
following condition will be for
validating the name
let's say the required name is caution
or anything else
the required password is let's say one
two three four five and the age should
be more than 13.
then only the user can enter the website
so for that we have to use the else if
statement and what we'll do is we'll
write here
elsif and inside this will give our
conditions so let's say the conditions
are you name
is equals to is equals to caution
and
pass
is equals to is equals to one two three
four five
and
h
should be
greater than or is equals to
13.
then
it will give the user a pop-up and
which states that will write here alert
will write here
sign up
successful
fine
save it
now the user can enter the website with
these credentials only otherwise a
pop-up will appear
so let's give the else condition as well
what we'll do is we'll write here else
and we'll use another alert
inside this we'll write
wrong id and
password
fine
now we have all the conditions here save
it and now we'll check for different
inputs
so let's move back to a form
and what we'll do is we'll write the
username is let's say ravi
and the password is let's say any random
numbers and age is let's say 6 submit it
and you can see it says wrong id and
password now what we'll do is we'll give
it the correct credentials we'll write
here
caution and the password will be one two
three four five
and age is let's say 21 fine the age
should be greater than or equals to 13
so submit it and you can see it says
sign up successful
now we have different conditions over
here
like if we write here any random name
and
if we write here any random password now
it will return wrong id and password but
if we write here correct id and password
and correct username as well let's say
we are writing here caution and let's
say the age will be changed to
11. submit it and you can see it still
says wrong id and password we can add
one more condition over here like we'll
write here elsif age is less than 12 it
will give an alert that
you are underage or some sort of that so
we'll write here else if
h
is less than 13
an alert
which states under aged fine
save it
and what we'll do is we'll move back to
our form and we'll write a caution
password is one two three four five and
age is let's say
11 submit it and you can see it says
under aged now so it is working totally
fine now one thing that seems a bit
irritating as well is it redirects us to
the home page every time right it
doesn't matter if the credentials are
correct or not it redirects to overcome
this issue we have
to make some minor changes in the html
file and include the return keyword in a
if else conditional statements
so let's go back to our html file and
what we'll do is
we'll write here inside the form tag now
we have on submit over here so what
we'll do is we'll write return
before validate so save it and we'll
move back to a javascript file
now this return keyword will let the
form perform any action only if the
value returned by the function validate
is true otherwise it will not allow the
form tag
to perform any action the action here is
redirecting the user to the home page
right so
let's do it here we know that the
function should return true only if all
the credentials are valid so we'll write
here
for all other
conditions we'll write
return
false
fine
for this one we'll write
return true because this is the
condition when all the credentials are
correct and for all other conditions
we'll write return
false
similarly for else as well we'll write
here
return false
now save it and we'll move back to
sign up form
save the html file as well once
and what we'll do is we'll write here
caution password is one two three and
age is let's say four submit it you can
see it says underaged click on ok and
now it is not redirecting us to the home
page right
now if the credentials are correct what
we'll do is we'll write here the
password is one two three four five and
the age is let's say
submit it
now you can see it says sign up
successful click on ok and you can see
we are in the home page it is working
totally fine
so if all the credentials are valid then
it is redirecting us to the home page
exactly what we wanted so these are the
basics of validation in javascript
obviously we can't validate a form with
javascript in the real world because we
don't have to deal with one user only we
need the backend to do all the
validation and all but simple validation
can be done with the help of javascript
we did it just now
we have many things to do with
validation in javascript like adding
some more conditions or using regular
expressions to validate forms in
javascript using regular expressions for
validation in javascript is what we
already saw in the previous videos so we
have gone through it already
here is the signup form we created in
the last video you can see we have a
username password and age
and we have used certain conditions
to validate this form we have used if
else if and so many more things in that
video so if you haven't watched it yet
please go through it once and it will be
easy for you to understand
now
today we'll add another text box here
wherein the user will enter the mobile
number and then we'll validate it in two
different ways so let's add another text
box here what we'll do is
we'll write here input
type is equals to
number and let's give it the id as well
so let's say the id is mobile
and the placeholder will say
enter your
mobile number
fine save it
so you can see we have another text box
here what we'll do is we'll
add a break tag here we'll write here br
save it now so this is our form
and here we have username password age
and mobile number one thing to notice
here is we can use the type as text as
well
as we are using
mobile number that consists of digits
only so we are using type as numbers
here so let's move on to the javascript
file
and we'll do the rest of the part there
so we'll take the user's input and store
it inside a variable to compare it right
so
let's add another variable here here you
can see we already have three variables
for username password and h we'll add
one more so let's say the variable name
is
where mob is equals to we'll use the
document.getelementbyid attribute
so we'll write here getelementbyid and
the id we used is mobile so let's cross
check it once so here is the id mobile
and will take the value we'll write here
dot value so this variable mob holds the
user's mobile number and will make
certain changes to this existing if else
statement
so the first thing we'll be doing is
we'll check if the user is writing
something inside the text box or not so
we'll add another condition here we'll
write here mob dot
trim
is equals to is equals to space if the
user leaves this box empty
so this will
pop up in his screen and it will say
missing credentials right next up we'll
change this condition as well we'll
write here
and then so let's say the mobile number
is zero nine eight seven six five four
three two one
some sort of this and we'll write here
mob is equals to is equals to
zero to one
now the last thing we are doing here is
we'll be adding one more elsif to check
if user enters any other mobile number
than this one
so like we did for h similarly we'll do
it for mobile number as well so we'll
write here else if
mob
not is equals to
09876 54321
then it will return
wrong mobile number
and it will also return
false
save it
now we have made three changes here
first one is we added the mob dot trim
so that the user won't leave this space
empty the next one is we checked if the
number entered by the user matches the
one we have in our system
and last one is for the number entered
by the user doesn't match then it will
return wrong mobile number fine
so we are done with it you can check it
here we have a condition here if the
mobile number does not matches it will
return wrong mobile number so let's do
it here we know the username is caution
the password is one two three four five
and the a should be above 13 right so
let's say we are writing here 15. now
here we are in the mobile number so
let's
add a random number here what we'll do
is we'll write this
and submit it you can see it says wrong
mobile number
fine
now the next thing is we'll write here
zero nine eight seven six five four
three two one let's suppose this is the
mobile number submit it and you can see
it says sign up successful and it will
redirect us to the home page
now this is working totally fine and
this is the traditional way of checking
the phone number of a user only if we
already know what the user has to put in
the text box to enter the website
now the next thing we'll be doing is
pretty simple as well but for that
method one should have a clear
understanding of regular expressions in
javascript
now we'll use rejects to validate the
user's phone number
and if you haven't watched the previous
videos on regular expressions yet i
suggest you to go through it before
mobile number validation in javascript
and this task of validation will be so
easy for you guys so what we'll do is
we'll move on to another html file let's
create one here first so we'll create
another html file let's say the html
file name is
mobile
dot html
and here what we'll do is
we'll create another text box
so let me connect it to another
javascript file first and we'll create
another javascript file as well fine so
we'll write here
mobile.js
so this is a javascript file
and the next thing we'll be doing is
we'll write a heading here so let's say
we are writing mobile number validation
in javascript
fine save it and open it with live
server so here is a new html file
and this is the javascript file so the
next thing we will be doing here is will
create another text box right we'll
create a single text box so we'll write
here
input
type is equals to text we can either use
numbers here as well
and then we'll use the id attribute
so we have to do it later but we are
doing it right now placeholder as
mobile
number fine
now we'll create a submit button as well
we'll write here input
type is equals to button
and value is equals to
submit
what we'll do is we'll call a function
on clicking the submit button so we'll
use the on click event here as well so
we'll write here on click
and let's say the function name is well
fine
go to save it
and here you can see we have a text box
for mobile number and a submit button
over here
so what we'll do next is we'll move on
to the javascript file to create this
val function now we'll create a function
and that function will check if the
number entered by the user is in the
proper format or not so let's create a
function first we'll go to a javascript
file and we'll write here
function well so this is the name of our
function and then we have the body as
well now the next thing we'll be doing
is we'll be
writing a program here so what we'll do
is we'll first take a variable let's say
the variable name is where mobile and
this variable will hold the value
entered by the user right so we'll write
here document
dot get element by id so his id is
i guess mobile so let's check it once so
here you can see we have the ids mobile
now what we'll do is we'll write a dot
value to get the value entered by the
user and now what we are doing is we are
using regular expressions for this
purpose right so we'll create another
variable
for the regular expression and
we'll leave it empty for now because
we'll change it later first we'll write
the whole program so what we'll do is
we'll again use the if else control
statement so the first condition will
remain the same we will write here
mobile dot trim
to check if the user is leaving the
place empty or not
and
in this condition
here we'll write
alert and then inside alert we'll write
please
enter a mobile number fine
i hope you guys got it so you can see
here we are getting an error here in the
if statement that's because we haven't
written something over here so if we
write something inside a regular
expression
so the error will go
but for now we are not using any regular
expression because i'll explain it to
you after this so leave it here only for
now the next
condition will be
writing here using the elsif so we'll
write here elsif
and we'll use this rejects variable with
the test function to validate the user's
mobile number so we'll write here
rejects
dot
test and we'll pass this mobile number
as a parameter to check right to compare
between rejects variable and the mobile
variable so we'll write here mobile fine
now this elseif will return something so
we'll use the alert method again
we'll write here mobile number
submitted
successfully
now you might be thinking why we are
doing so because we know that this test
function is used to compare the values
and if this test function will return
true then only a pop-up will appear with
the message mobile number submitted
successfully i hope you guys
already know about this test function we
already discussed it a few sessions back
when we came across regular expressions
in javascript
so i think it might be easy for you guys
and and at last we'll write here else
for any other input
so we'll again use the alert method and
we'll write here
wrong mobile number fine
here we have written everything inside
this function even the conditions as
well we have three cases over here
the first one is if the user leaves the
field empty and tries to submit the next
one is for checking the number entered
by the user and the last one is for
everything else
so we haven't written the regular
expression yet because let's discuss it
before writing
so guys what we want is
we want a 10 digit mobile number and the
number should start from either 7 8 or 9
because we know mobile numbers generally
starts with these digits either 7 or 8
or 9 fine
then it has 10 digits only now for
checking the length of the mobile number
we could have used the mobile.length
property right but the regular
expression gives us a simple and easy
method to do so we discussed the
shorthand character classes in rejects a
few sessions back right so now we want
all the inputs to be digits only so what
we'll do is we'll write here inside this
regular expression
backslash d
so this is the shorthand character class
and
we'll use
these curly braces and we'll write here
10 inside this so this statement over
here will check the length of the string
but we have to do some more things here
the next thing we need to do is the
initial digit of a mobile number that
can be
7 8 or 9.
so for that what we'll do is we'll
define a range for initial number
and we'll write here before this
character class
what we'll do is we'll define a range
over here so we'll use square brackets
and we'll write here 7
to 9. now this particular statement
defines a range that consists of only
three numbers 7 8 or 9.
now this regular expression is sort of
complete we can say now one thing we
have to keep in mind that we have to
write here 9 now instead of 10
that's because we have already defined
the first number right and we need 9
more digits apart from that particular
digit
so let's check it out save it
and we'll write a mobile number here so
let's say the mobile number is this one
two three four five six seven eight and
what will happen is it will return wrong
mobile number that's because the number
here starts from 1 instead of 7 8 or 9
so submit it and you can see it says
wrong mobile number
now we'll try for another condition
we'll leave this field blank and submit
it you can see it says please enter a
mobile number so this is also working
fine now the next thing we'll be doing
is
we'll be starting the number from 9
and let's say the number is this
so this is a 10 digit mobile number
submit it
and you can see it says mobile number
submitted successfully
so this is also working fine
now the only problem here is if we write
anything before this particular phone
number like if we write here before
9 if we let's say we are writing here
abcde
any character or alphabet as well submit
it you can see it still says mobile
number submitted successfully
now it will not give any error because
it finds the expression present in the
string
right we have to mention the static and
the end points of a regular expression
for this purpose
we have two meta characters one denotes
the start that is the carrot character
and the other one denotes the end of the
string that is the dollar sign so we'll
add both of them in our expression what
we'll do is we'll write here
carrot
this will denote the start of the string
and here we'll write dollar this will
denote the end of the string save it
and now it will work fine
and one more thing guys don't
misunderstand this character with the
one we use inside the brackets to
exclude any particular string
like if we remove this from here and if
we insert this carrot character inside
this bracket what will happen is it will
exclude this particular range it will
exclude 7 8 or 9. we have already
discussed the use of this carrot
character now if we write it here it
will denote the start of a string so you
will not get confused if the concept of
meta characters and character sets are
clear to you so let's check the output
save it
and we'll check for certain phone
numbers now we'll check for that
particular condition only we'll write
here 9876543210
so this is a correct mobile number if
you submit it it will say mobile number
submitted successfully
but now if you write here something
before this 9876 now if we write here
any
characters or alphabets and submit it
you can see it says wrong mobile number
because we have used the carrot
character and we want at the start of
the string either 7 8 or 9. now similar
thing will happen at the end as well if
you write here anything
and submit it you can see it says wrong
mobile number because we have added
dollar sign as well fine
remove it and if you are adding any
numbers here as well save it and you can
see it still says wrong mobile number
because the length is more than 10 and
the end will be
denoted after nine digits so these are
the nine digits and this is the end of
the string according to a regular
expression
so these are the ways how we can
validate a user's phone number in
javascript obviously we can do so many
things in validation i want you guys to
do something exceptional on this topic
and let us know in the comment box what
you did
in the previous video where we came
across mobile number validation in
javascript we saw two different methods
of validating a user's phone number
right the first method is used when we
know what the user has to enter if the
user enters something else then it will
give an error
the other method is with the help of
rejects in javascript wherein we
validated the format of the mobile
number entered by the user
and today we will do something similar
to what we did in the previous video so
we'll use regular expressions again to
validate the email id entered by the
user
so let's move on to the programming part
directly and we'll create a text box
here to take the user's input so what
we'll do is we'll create a text box
we'll write here
input
type is equals to
email id here as let's say mail
fine the next thing will be a
placeholder and
the placeholder will say
enter
email id here fine
we'll close this input tag and the next
thing we'll be doing is we'll be
creating a submit button we'll write
here type is equals to
button
value will be
submit
and we'll use the on click event
so we'll write here on click so we'll
call a function on clicking this button
we'll write here validate we'll create
this validate function in a javascript
file
now save this piece of code and you can
see we have a text box and submit button
here now if you write here something
you can see nothing is happening over
here
now the next task we have to do is the
one we already know we'll move on to the
javascript file we'll create a function
there and use the if else control
statements to check if the email id
entered by the user is in accordance
with the pattern or not
quite a simple task because we have been
doing it for quite some time right so
let's do it quickly what we'll do is
we'll move to a javascript file i forgot
to create one here so let me create one
and the name will be email.js
so this is a javascript file
we'll create a function here so we'll
write here function
validate
the next thing is the body of this
function
so we'll write here everything other
than the regular expression because the
rest will remain the same as mobile
number validation so we'll try it here
we'll create a variable here we'll write
here where
email is equals to
we'll write here
document.getelementbyid and the id is
mail
now we'll use the dot value attribute
the next thing is we'll again take a
variable for regular expression and
we'll
leave it for now we'll move on to the
next part
what we'll do here is we'll use the if
else control statement again so the
first condition will remain the same
we'll write here if email dot
trim is equals to is equals to null
then what it will do is it will give a
pop-up so we'll use the alert keyword
and inside this will write
please enter a valid
email id fine the next thing we'll do is
we'll use the test function in regular
expressions so we'll write here elsif
regex dot
test
and we'll pass this email variable as a
parameter
here it will check if the input given by
the user matches the pattern of the
regular expression will check for it so
we'll
write here alert and inside this will
write email submitted successfully
fine
and at the last we'll use the else
statement
and we'll write here alert
wrong
email id
fine
save it
now we are almost done with everything
apart from the regular expression we
didn't define the rejects until now
because we'll discuss it first
because you know guys using a regular
expression for email validation is
slightly different from other things
like we have several parts for a regular
expression let's discuss it first
so let's take an email id first so let
me write
let's say we have an email id
as caution
at the rate simply learn
dot
com
fine we can't write here two dots so
this is what a primary email id looks
like an email id consists of four parts
the first part is the name that can be
anything it can have alphabets digits or
sometimes dot and underscore as well so
we can have the name as like if we write
here
let's say caution
one one or if we write here caution dot
one one or we can say we can write here
caution
underscore 011
right so these names are allowed in an
email id the next part is the at the
rate symbol it's mandatory to add the
symbol in each email id as you know so
the third part is the domain name that
can be the name of any particular
organization like here simply learn is
the domain name
or it can be gmail or yahoo or hotmail
or any of these so that depends on the
user where they have their email id
now the last part is the extension which
comes after a dot so after this dot we
have an extension over here this com is
an extension
fine
an extension can be dot com it can be
dot in or dot net or it can be dot co
dot in
so now that we have an idea about how an
email id looks like the next thing we'll
be doing is working here on the regular
expression to create a particular format
of this type
right so we have four parts but we have
to compulsorily add and add the rate
symbol and
dot before the extension
so what we'll do is we'll take three
pairs of parentheses or round brackets
we can say for defining the rest three
parts so what we'll do is we'll write
here
so we need
three parentheses right now we have to
mention at the rate and dot compulsorily
here fine the rest will define but we
have to add these two symbols
compulsorily in each email id
the caret and the dollar signs are meta
characters used to define the regular
expressions starting and the end points
right so i hope you guys are clear with
regular expressions till now as this is
the last video on this topic and still
if you have any doubts about rejects
feel free to comment your doubts and
we'll get back to you so let's define
the first part here the first part is
the name consisting of alphabets digits
or some specific symbols like dot and
underscore right we'll define a range
here so we'll use square brackets to
define the range so what we'll do is
we'll write here
a to z
or
or zero to nine
fine here we have defined three ranges
arrange for small letter alphabets
capital letter alphabets and a range of
numbers from 0 to 9. now we could have
used the global modifier at the end of
this regular expression instead of
defining a range of capital letter
alphabets we have already discussed the
concept of modifiers a few sessions back
now the next thing is to add specific
symbols like dot and underscore we can't
write them simply because if we write
here dot or underscore the meaning will
change
and it will return true for any
character in place of dot
the concept of meta characters remember
so we have to put a backslash before
writing the symbols what we'll do is
we'll put a backslash over here
now we have added the special symbols as
well the next part is the length of this
name
now it can be either 10 or maybe 20 or
we can say in some cases let's suppose
it can go more than 20. now what we can
do is we can either define the length
inside curly braces like this we can
write here
2 comma 20 so this is the range for
length but we can't do it here because
we are keeping this thing in mind that
the username might go above 20
characters so what we'll do is we'll use
the plus operator the plus operator will
let the user enter the name as long as
they want instead of using these curly
braces over here what we'll do is we'll
use the plus operator here
fine
now the next part is for the domain name
after this add the rate symbol over here
what we'll do is we'll write the domain
name
that has to be there in each email id
right the domain name can be the name of
any organization as we have already
discussed we don't need digits in the
domain name right so what we'll do is
we'll simply write here
a to z and
a to z so we have defined two ranges for
domain name one for the small letters
and the other one is for the capital
letter alphabets
fine we did it almost the same as name
now again the domain name can be of any
length so we have to use the plus
operator here what we'll do is
we'll first put them inside square
brackets i forgot to mention them here
and then we'll use the plus operator now
the regular expression looks a bit
complicated right but we don't have to
worry about it because these all are
easy things just a little bit lengthy we
can say
so the next thing we'll be doing here is
we'll be going through the last part of
a email id after this dot symbol what we
have to do is we have to define another
range for the extension
right the extension can be any alphabet
with a length not more than 6 to 7 right
so what we'll do is we'll write here
a to z only consist of small letters
or we can include capital letters as
well so what we'll do is we'll write
here
a to z as well
now the next thing we'll do is we'll
define the
length of this extension
so we don't need the plus operator here
because the length of any extension
can't be more than four five or six
maybe right so what we'll do is we'll
define a range of
length we'll write here 2
and 6 so 2 is the minimum length of
extension and 6 is the maximum length
now save it
and let's check the output so we'll
check for several email ids now what
we'll do is we'll write here abc at the
rate
gmail.com
fine
submit it you can see it says email
submitted successfully
let me zoom it out a bit the next thing
we'll do here is we'll write here abc
underscore
1 1 at the rate
gmail.com
so one thing we have forgotten here is
to include the carat character and the
dollar character so we have to specify
the starting and the end point here so
what we did is we have included the
carrot character and the dollar sign
here
now we'll write here abc underscore one
one at the rate
gmail.com
submit it and you can see it says email
submitted successfully so this is a
valid email id now the next thing we'll
be doing here is we'll be using any
random symbol so let's say we are using
abc star at the rate gmail.com submit it
and you can see it says wrong email id
now the next thing we'll be doing here
is
we'll write any number here let's say
and we'll write here caution
112.3
fine so
this will return wrong email id because
we have included
numbers in domain name and we haven't
defined any range of numbers for the
domain name submit it and you can see it
says wrong email id now remove these
numbers from here
and submit it you can see it says email
submitted successfully so this is
working totally fine
now the last thing is what if we have an
email like caution 112.3 at the rate
gmail dot
co dot in
submit it and you can see it says wrong
email id in this case we have to define
another range in the regular expression
that can be optional so we have the
question mark symbol that acts as an
optional character it means that any
range or anything return before this
meta character will be optional
so we'll use this symbol
and we'll write here
before this dollar sign
will again use parenthesis and we'll
write here dot
a to z
and then we'll define the range as 2
comma 6
and we'll use the question mark sign
here or we can say this optional meta
character here save it
and now what if we write here
caution at the rate gmail dot co dot in
now submit it and you can see it says
email submitted successfully and this is
totally optional if we write here
caution
gmail.com submit it and you can see it
still works fine so this is how we can
validate a user's email id in javascript
we have been using the console for a
long time now we have seen how we can
use it to print the output of a program
in the console
that's quite simple
now debugging refers to finding and
fixing errors in our program now to
remove those errors we need to identify
them and analyze the solution for them
as well so in this video we will see how
to identify an error in a program with
chrome developer tools and what we'll do
today is we'll create a simple html
program and we'll try to understand the
concept of debugging in javascript with
the help of that program
so let's do something here
now we'll create two text boxes over
here so
what we'll do is we'll take the user's
input to add two values entered by the
user in those text boxes so what we'll
do is we'll write here
input
type is equals to
number because we want to perform
addition of two numbers
and then we'll write here id as let's
say the id for number one is n1 and then
we'll write here placeholder
right here let's say
number one fine
now we'll do the same for
second number as well we'll write here
number
id is equals to n2
placeholder is equals to
number two fine the last thing we have
to do is we have to insert a submit
button so we will write here input type
is equals to button
and we'll write the value as
submit and
we'll use an event over here so we'll
write here
on double click we'll call the function
add on clicking
fine
now save it and you can see we have two
text boxes over here and a submit button
fine
we tried a new on click event here
instead of using the regular on click
event we have used the double click
event now the functioning will remain
the same the only change is that we have
to double click on the submit button to
call the add function
now we are done with the html part the
next task is to create a function that
can perform addition over the values
entered by the user
so let's move on to the javascript file
and we'll create a function here
so we'll write here
function the function name is add and
then we have the body of this function
we'll take three variables
we'll write here where number one
will use the document
dot get element by id
and the id for number one is n1 we'll
write here dot
value
and we'll do the same for number two as
well so we'll copy it from here and
we'll paste it here instead of number
one we'll write here number two
and id will be number two
and then we'll take another variable
where number three
that will hold the value after edition
so we'll write here
number one plus
number two fine
let's give some space between them
and the last thing we'll be doing here
is we'll be using the alert keyword and
will be printing the output on a browser
so
we'll write here the sum is
plus
number
three fine
now save it
and here we have created a simple
function to add two numbers the value of
the first number will be stored inside
variable number one and the second value
will be held inside variable number two
for instance if the user enters 10 in
box 1 and 20 in box 2 the expected
output will be 30 right
let's check it out so save it again and
we'll write here 10 in box 1
and 20 in box 2 and we'll double click
on the submit button
and here you can see the output is
different from what we have expected the
output is 1 0 2 0 instead of 30.
now what's happening here is the system
is taking the numbers as strings and
then the plus operator is used to append
those values so the solution is simple
what we have to do is we have to use the
parseint method and it will take care of
the rest we have already discussed this
parsing method in the previous sessions
right
so we'll write here
before this
document.getelementbyid we'll write here
parseint
and we'll keep this
inside brackets fine
we'll do the same for
number two as well
we'll write here percent and we're good
to save it now and we'll write here 10
and 20 again we'll write 10 inside the
first box and 20 inside the second one
and double click on this submit button
and you can see the output is 30 now it
says the sum is 30.
now we have used the alert keyword here
to print the output but we could have
used the console.log to print the same
right
so let me just take you through the
developer tools first and then we'll
discuss about it
so we'll maximize this chrome we'll go
to the chrome browser
and we will press f12 here so on
clicking the f12 key from our keyboard
we have this over here so we have the
elements tab
the elements tab consists of the
structure of the document if you hover
on anything over the elements page you
will see that we are getting the output
of what that particular statement did on
the web page you can see if we hover on
the body tag
we are getting the whole area occupied
by the body tag inside the web page now
the next part is the console we already
know what the console can do for us
we know that we can print the output
over our console and perform some
temporary logic building here the
benefit of using a console is that it
can get you all the errors that the vs
code can't for example if we move back
to our vs code and let's say when we
were writing our program we made a small
typing mistake and we wrote here var b
instead of where you can see vs code
will let us know that there is something
wrong in this statement there is a red
line over here so we have to fix this
problem and the console will also let us
know about it
but there are some errors which the vs
code can't detect
what we'll do is we'll comment these two
lines for now
so we'll
correct it first and then we'll comment
these two lines
fine
what we'll do is
we'll write here
console.log
and
inside this will write here
the sum is and we'll write here
number one
plus
number two
fine
now this is also the same thing we just
did instead of using the alert box to
print the output we have used the
console for it so let's check the
outcome first we'll save it first and
then we'll
open the console here
so here you can see on writing the
numbers inside these text boxes and on
double clicking this submit button you
can see we have the output as one zero
two zero now
one thing we have to keep in mind is we
have to write here parse int
so we'll write here percent again and
we'll put these two numbers inside
brackets save it now and we'll go back
to our chrome browser we'll write here
10 and 20 again now double click on the
submit button and you can see it says
sum is 30. it's working totally fine
now imagine a situation where we forgot
to put the plus sign here
right what i am saying is imagine a
scenario so let me just do one thing let
me put this console here
and
what we'll do is let's say we forgot to
put this plus sign over here
fine the vs code is not giving us any
hint about the mistake we just made we
have no idea about it and we came to
know about it during execution save it
and write here
10 and
20 fine
now we are expecting the output as 30
but we don't have any idea about the
mistake double click on the submit
button and you can see we have an error
message over here in the console so the
console helps us in finding those hidden
errors in our program you can see we
have the information about the mistake
we made in the console here
so we have the exact location of the
error the error is present on line 5 of
this file so here is the error
it will let us know everything about the
error
now another way to find the error in a
program is by going through the sources
tab
so
what we'll do is we'll move this console
to the side again
and we'll go to the sources tab and you
will notice that this particular line is
highlighted in a red color we can change
it here but the change will not be
visible in our main javascript file so
we have to change it there in our main
javascript file let's correct the error
over there
what we'll do is we'll zoom this vs code
as well so we'll put the plus sign here
again now save it
and we are good to go now the sources
tab is used to find the errors as well
as we can go through the execution of
the program step by step
now we have the navigator here on the
left hand side so this is the navigation
part and on the right hand side we have
the debugger
here you can see we have so many options
over here we have certain breakpoints we
have breakpoints we have scope calls tag
dom breakpoints global listeners event
listener breakpoints so breakpoint
refers to the point of place where we
intentionally stop the program so that
we can review the further execution
process for example we have an event
listener in our program right the on
double click event what we can do is we
can stop the execution process when the
system reaches there
now what we have to do is we have to go
to the event listener breakpoints
and we have to select the mouse option
over here now inside this mouse option
we have certain events right you can see
we have click double click mouse down
mouse up and we'll click on this double
click event
now write any numbers over here inside
the text boxes so let's say we are
writing here 20
and 30 double click on the submit button
and you can see the screen turned grey
now this code looks a little bit long
because we are using the live server so
let me just pause the live server and
then i'll come back to you guys
now we'll open this page and inside here
what we'll do is
we'll
choose the mouse option we'll choose the
double click option inside
mouse so here is the mouse and we'll
choose the double click option
so we are doing the same thing
let me just increase the size a bit
now we'll write here 20 and 30 inside
number two
double click on the submit button and
you can see the rest of the browser
screen turning gray and execution is
stopped at this particular line
because we have a double click event
over here now what we can do is we can
go further step by step in our program
we have four options over here you can
see we have one two three and four
options
now the first option is
the resume script execution the resume
script execution will execute the entire
script and give us the output the next
option is the step or next function call
and it will take us to the next function
call present in the program then we have
the step into the next function call and
it will do the same as the step over
next function call and then we have step
out of the current function it will take
us back to the initial function from
wherever we are now the last option is
the step option and it takes us a step
forward in the program
fine now click on this step function
again and again so when you click it
once you can see we are in the next part
so this is the next line which will be
executed in the program click on the
step again and you can see we are going
further step by step right and then you
can see
the javascript file is executed and it
will move back to this double click
event and the final step it will print
the output on the console so if we go
here on the console you can see we have
the output is 50. fine so this is how we
can review our program step by step
and one more thing is it will show us
the error as well now let's try to
create an error in our program what
we'll do is we'll move to a javascript
file and we'll remove this
i from here
fine so save it now
and move back to
chrome and what we'll do is we'll
refresh this file and we'll write here
two numbers we'll write here 20
and 30. double click on the submit
button you can see the program is
stopped at this particular breakpoint
now click on the step button
and you can see we are going for the
step by step
the moment it will execute this line it
will give us an error and you can see
the moment it executed this particular
line the line turned red fine if we go
to a console you can see here we have
the error over here it says parseint is
not defined or percent is not defined so
this is a reference error and this is
how the chrome developer tools help us
in finding those errors and fixing them
now a big question here is why we are
using the developer tools the program is
small and we can find the error by
ourselves so guys
this was just an example to illustrate
how we can find those minor hidden
errors in a program the scenario can be
different at times suppose we have a
program that has over 1000 lines of code
and in that case we simply can't go
through each line to find that
particular error we need something with
which we can see the error quickly and
more efficiently so that's where the
developer tools come into picture and
help us
almost all the browsers these days
support developer tools so there's no
such problem that you can't use the
developer tool
with any particular browser so try it in
the browser you are using and let us
know about your experience in the
comment box
you can see we have an image slider over
here the images present inside this box
keep on changing we can also click on
these radio buttons to go over a
specific image if we click on this last
radio button you can see we are moving
to that particular image
now suppose you go through the home page
of any website like amazon or flipkart
you will notice that these websites
contain such image sliders at the top
for different type of sales and offers
going on right that looks quite nice so
we'll do something interesting in
today's video we'll go over some
specific animations like fading of an
image on several events we'll see how
easy it is to make those style changes
in javascript which we can't do with css
or html we are particularly talking
about style changes during events so
talking about style changes we have done
it in the past using css and html and
javascript of course so guys we
generally say that javascript is used to
make a webpage more interactive right to
make a webpage more interactive or
engaging we have to do something nice to
it so adding fade in and fade out
animations to a picture makes the
webpage more engaging to the user
so what we'll do today is we'll take an
image and use specific javascript
properties to make changes in that image
let's move on to the vs code and you
will understand it much better
now let's add an image to the webpage
first so we have a picture on our
computer and we'll add it so what we'll
do is we'll write here img src source
will be
html.png
and the next thing we'll be using the
alt attribute we'll write here
let's say javascript so we can take any
random image we are doing this for
experimental purpose only so what we'll
do next is we'll close this img tag
we'll save it and here you can see we
have an image over here will reduce the
size
and so this is the perfect size i guess
now what we'll do next is we'll use the
id attribute as well because we need to
access this particular image so let's
say the id is
img fine
now here we have an image and we have
two possibilities to perform those
animations either we can add two buttons
and add functionality to them or we can
use the on mouse over and on mouse out
events so we'll use two buttons for now
and then we'll use the on mouse over and
on mouse out events to do the same task
now let's add two buttons here what
we'll do is we'll write here
input
type is equals to button
and then we'll write here value value
will be let's say
fade in for
first button and we'll use the on click
event fine so we'll write here on click
and will call a function on clicking
this particular button so this will be a
function name fade in
now we'll do similar thing again
we'll copy paste it and we'll change
certain
values here we'll write your fade out
and we'll call a different function so
we'll write here fade out fine
now save it and you can see we have two
buttons over here
faded and fade out so nothing is
happening on clicking over these buttons
we can change the size of this image
using css right so we'll use css here
only we'll write here
class is equals to
let's say size
and
we'll use the style tag here
we'll write here dot
size
and inside this will
write
width is equals to
50 pixels let's say
and the height will be
50 pixels as well fine save it and you
can see the image is
pretty small right now so what we'll do
is we'll write here
250 instead of 50
save it now and you can see it's working
fine i guess
the size is decent
let's change it to 300
right
so we have to keep these things in mind
like what size we want for our image and
we can use css for that right that's
quite easy what we did is we defined the
class we use the class attribute here
inside the img tag and we have defined
it using the style tag over here we are
not using any separate css file for that
so save it and you can see we have a
image over here with decent size and
then we have two buttons fade in and
fade up now the next task for us is to
add functionality to these buttons we'll
move on to the javascript file and
creator functions there so this is a
javascript file we'll create a function
here let's say
the function name is
fadein so this is the first function and
then we have the body of this function
now the next thing is to use the style
property to fade this image let's talk
about it in detail we need to access
this image right so we'll use the
document.getelementbyid method to access
the image we have already used the id
attribute in the html file so what we'll
do here is we'll write here
document dot get element by id
and the id is
img fine
now we have to use the style property
the style property is used to add
styling to any particular element or
event with the help of javascript we can
do it with css but we want to add
styling as a functionality right this
means that we want to style our element
or image by clicking a button
for that we have to use the style
property here in our javascript file
so we'll write here style now the next
and the last thing is fading the image
now we have a term named opacity in
programming
opacity refers to the fact of being
opaque in programming if the value of
opacity is 1 then we can't see through
the image like making an image
transparent and if the value is 0 we can
see through that image or we can say
that the image will totally disappear if
the value is 0. so let's try it out here
and you will understand it so what we'll
do is we'll write here style dot opacity
is equals to
zero now save it
and click on this fade in button click
on this fade in button and you can see
the image disappears by clicking the
fade in but
now we will add functionality to this
fade out button as well
for that what we have to do is we have
to create another function here so the
function name will be
fade
out then we have the body of this
function the
working will remain the same we'll again
use the
document.getelementbyid method
we'll again use the img as id we'll
write here dot style dot
opacity now what we want is we want to
bring back our image right so we'll
write here one
now here the values are zero and one
respectively for fade in and fade out
functions let's check the output here
save it
click on this fade in button and you can
see the image totally disappears and on
clicking the fade out button you can see
the image is here again now to actually
make the image a slight fade
let's say we don't want the image to be
disappeared completely what we want is a
slight fade in our image now what we
have to do is we have to choose a value
between 0 and 1 like for 0 it totally
disappears
right if we write here 0.5 save it now
and click on fade in you can see the
image fades slightly so this is how we
can use the fade in and fade out
animations in javascript and it will be
totally fine if we write here 0.1 as
well save it
and if you click on this fade in button
you can see we have this image over here
still but we can say it's almost
transparent or disappearing you can see
it's over here maybe it's visible or
maybe not but if you write here 0.3 or
something like that and now click on
this fade in button you can see we can
see this image but the image is faded
right so this is how we can use the fade
in and fade out animations in javascript
now we can do the same thing using on
mouse over and on mouse out events in
javascript we have to make some more
minor changes in a html file only
instead of using these buttons we'll use
the on mouse over and on mouse out
events
inside the img tag so what we'll do is
let's do it as well
we'll move to our html file and we'll
comment these two lines so we are done
with it now the next thing we'll do is
we'll use the on mouse over and on mouse
out event right so we'll write here on
mouse
over first
and we'll call the fade in function on
taking the mouse cursor over the image
and the second event will be on mouse
out
so we'll write here on mouse out and
we'll call the fade out function fine on
taking the mouse cursor away from the
image save it and you can see we don't
have any buttons over here now now on
taking the mouse cursor over this image
you can see the image fades a bit and on
taking the mouse cursor away from the
image you can see we have the original
image here
so this is how we can make fade in and
fade out animations work in javascript
you might hear that browsers do not
support this method of using fade in and
fade out animations in javascript in my
case i have checked with 3-4 different
browsers like microsoft edge firefox
chrome and internet explorer
so it is working totally fine i want you
guys to check if it is working or not
with the browsers you have on your
computer if not then do let us know in
the comments and we'll figure it out
make sure that you have the latest
version of whichever browser you are
using the fade in and fade out effect in
javascript was easy to use all we have
to do is to use the style property with
opacity in between 0 and 1 quite a
simple task right now in this video
we'll see another animation effect in
which we'll change the size of an image
by hovering over that
we see such animations in many ecommerce
websites where if we take the mouse
cursor over any product the size
increases
so let's do it here it's a simple task
we'll add an image to our html file
first so
we'll write here
img and the source will be we have an
image named as
in a system
and then we have the id attribute the id
will be let's say img and then we'll use
the alt
attribute here we'll write here
coffee
let's assume that this is a product of
any e-commerce website and we want to
increase the size of this product on
hovering over that
so the next thing we'll be doing here is
we'll be defining the width so let's say
the width will be
200 pixels for this particular image and
then we'll use
certain events here so we'll use the on
mouse over so on taking the mouse cursor
over we want to increase the size of
this image right and on taking the mouse
cursor away we want to decrease the size
right
so we have used these two functions
we'll define these functions in a
javascript file
so we are done with this img tag
save it and you can see we have an image
over here in a browser so we are done
with it we have the default size of this
image as 200 pixels we can change it
here we can make it 300 or 400
or any size we want so you can see the
image size change if we write here 300
instead of 200 so for now we'll be using
200 that's fine i guess
so what we want is we want to increase
the size of this image by taking the
mouse cursor over it right and the size
will be back to normal if we take the
cursor away from the image
so for that we have to define these two
functions increase and degrees so let's
define them in a javascript file what
we'll do is we'll first write here
function and we'll define function
increase
then we have the body of this function
and we'll write here
document dot get element by id the id is
img
and we'll write here dot style dot
width
is equals to we can't write here 400
pixels simply it will throw an error you
can see a red line over here so what we
have to do is we have to write this
inside single inverted commas
right
save it and on taking the mouse cursor
over the image you can see the image
size increases but it's not getting back
to its original size because we haven't
declared the decrease function yet let's
declare the decrease function as well so
what we'll do is we'll again use the
same logic we'll write here function
decrease
and inside the body we'll write
document dot get element by id
we'll write here img
dot style
dot width
is equals to the width let's say will be
default so the width will be 200 pixels
we'll write here 200 pixels
and the decrease function will make the
picture get back to its original size
that is 200 pixels so save it and you
can see here on the browser that the
image is zooming in and out on specific
mouse events
that is one of the most easiest tasks to
do in javascript all we had to do is we
had to define two functions a function
increase and the other one for
decreasing the size so the function
increase will increase the size by 200
pixels and the function decrease will
get the image back to its original form
fine
now there is an older method of changing
the size of an image using the set
interval method
html5 documents no longer support this
method so suppose that we want the size
of the image to grow gradually like
after every 10 milliseconds the size
should increase up to a certain level
all we have to do is to use the set
interval method we are all aware of this
concept in javascript so let's take a
look at the html part so here's the html
part which is the same as we used for
the previous program not even a single
change here you can see we have the
image sources coffee.png then we have
the ids img one
then we have used two mouse over events
one to increase the size and the other
one to decrease the size and then we
have the width as hundred we have
changed the width here the initial width
will be 100 and we'll notice that the
initial image size is smaller than the
one we used in the previous program
now the javascript file will look
different let's move there first so here
is the javascript part and we have three
variables here width addition and
interval id now the initial value of
width is the same as that of image
which is 100 and then we have the
variable addition which will be
responsible for the increment of the
size as we want the size to be increment
by 2 pixels after every 10 milliseconds
right the following variable is interval
id which we'll need later on while using
the set interval method now we have two
functions over here the increase
function and the decrease function so
these are the two functions we have in a
javascript file inside the increase
function we have used the set interval
method you can see here we have the set
interval method
and we have called the zoom in function
after every 10 milliseconds so it will
call the zooming functions again and
again after 10 milliseconds so if we
want to make it one second we have to
write here 1000 right we are already
aware of this concept so we are using
milliseconds for now now if we remove
this clear interval method from here
then the zoom in and zoom out effect
will not work correctly in between we'll
try it later so same as the case for
decrease function as well and it will
call the zoom out function after every
10 milliseconds right so we have to
define these two functions as well so
here are the functions zoom in and zoom
out so let's take a look at the zoom in
function first the zoom in function is
actually responsible for the increment
in the size of the image if the width is
less than 200 let's suppose the initial
width is 100 which is less than 200
right then what will happen is
the value of width will be increased by
width plus addition it will be increased
by 2. so it will check if the width is
less than 100 the value will be 102 then
1046810 up to 200 and then the value
will be assigned to the style property
to increase the size so this statement
is we are using for a long time now
so what we are doing is we are assigning
the value of this width to this style
property and then we have used the
console.log to check the increase in
width
now the else statement will stop the set
interval function
and the increment in image size will be
stopped as soon as it reaches the 200
mark
for the value of width as 200 the set
interval function will stop
same as the case for zoom out function
which will decrease the size of the
image until the size reaches 0.
the size will be reduced by 2 after
every 10 milliseconds the logic remains
the same what we are doing is we are
using here minus instead of plus and we
are checking if the value of width is
greater than hundred fine so let's check
the output of this program save it and
we'll open this file with live server
we'll click on live server
now here we are on the browser and take
the mouse cursor over the image oh it's
not working the reason behind it is this
method is not supported by the current
version of html to make this program
work we have to put our browser in quark
mode
now for that we have to do a simple task
we have to go to html file and we have
to remove this particular statement we
have to remove this doctype as html
remove it now this quark mode is used to
make older websites compatible with the
browser if your program doesn't work
sometimes do check this out by removing
doctype from your html file sometimes it
happens that a particular method or a
particular type of program doesn't
supports in your browser so do check
this method out try running your program
in quirk mode and maybe it will work
so let's check the output now see on
taking the mouse cursor over here the
image size increases gradually and on
taking the mouse cursor away the size
decreases it looks nice right
now imagine you are working on an
ecommerce website and you want to make
your website more interactive
then you can put this effect over
products and it will look nicer right
so we have already mentioned it that
what if we remove this clear interval
method so we'll move to a javascript
file and we'll see what if we remove
this particular clear interval method
from it so we'll remove these clear
interval methods we'll remove this one
and
this one
save it now and you can see there is
something wrong on taking the mouse
cursor over this image so you can see
the image is shaking slightly right now
this is because the clear interval
method does not stop the set interval
method on calling the increase and
decrease function every time
so this is how we can make our web pages
more beautiful and interactive in
javascript
we have come across almost every
important topic in javascript whether it
is an important one like regular
expressions in javascript or the one
mainly asked in interviews like promises
in javascript each topic has its own
value in javascript and every topic is
important
so in today's video we'll come across
two different types of games the first
one will be the one wherein we'll
recreate flappy words using javascript
now many of you guys must have heard
about this game already if not
we have to take a bird through a space
between two walls in this particular
game so let me just take you through the
game once
and
here we are so this is our game you can
see we have a bird over here and we have
to take this bird through this yellow
hole present in between the blue color
right the yellow holes are random and if
the bird strikes the blue wall or maybe
at the bottom of the screen
then the game will over fine so i hope
you guys understood what we have to do
in this particular game now we have to
press a key from the keyboard to make
the bird jump repeatedly and we have to
make the bird jump so that the bird will
go through the hole between the walls
without touching the boundaries of the
hole
so i hope you guys must have understood
the task here
now
let's try to recreate this game again
from scratch and we'll do everything by
ourselves we'll go through the html part
we'll go through the javascript and will
go through the css as well both html and
css will play a vital role in making
this game along with the javascript part
obviously
so let's start with the code now we'll
go back to vs code and here you can see
we have a html file named
flappybird.html so we'll change the
title of this as well we'll write here
instead of document we'll write here
flappy bird fine save it
now first of all we'll take a container
for the game to run so
as you can see here we have a container
over here fine so this is our container
now we have to create this whole
container
now what we'll do for that is we'll go
to the body tag and we'll write here
div
id is let's say
game
and we'll close this day now inside this
particular div we'll create three more
div tags so we'll write here div
id is equals to
block or we can write here pipe as well
for the wall or for the pipe we can say
the next we'll write here div
id is equals to whole that is for the
whole
and the last one is for the
bird fine so we'll write it diff
id is equals to
bird
we'll close this div and a fundamental
task is done here
now we have a container for the game
we'll put the game inside one single
container
the next thing we need in a game is a
block which we'll use to create the
walls in the game followed by the hole
in the block for the bird to go through
it right and the last thing is the bird
itself so we'll add an image here for
the bird so let's do some styling for
all this that we have written over here
so what we'll do is we'll move to a css
file so this is a css file
and we'll write here
for the whole document the margin will
be
zero by default
okay so we'll write here zero
and
the padding will be
zero as well fine
are good to go that's a common thing the
margin and the padding will remain zero
for the whole html document
the next thing is to create the
background of whole document
so we'll do something creative here
something different from what we did
till now
so what we'll do is we'll create the
background with two different colors
now you might be thinking of what these
two different colors are so what we'll
do is we'll write here
body and then we'll write here
background color we'll take any
background color
let's say we are taking cadet blue
fine
now save it
save this part as well and open this on
live server
so here you can see we have a background
we have the background of html document
as cadet blue color
now the next thing we'll do is we'll use
two different colors over this
background right so we'll write here
background
image
and we'll write here
webkit
linear gradient and we'll write here
rgb
comma 75 comma 75
then we'll write here
rgb so these are three particular colors
we'll write here
31 comma 31 comma 31
and the last one will be
rgb
59 comma
153 comma
1 4 8
fine
so here we are
and the next thing we'll do is we'll
write here
min height will be
800 pixels
now save it
and you can see here we have three
different colors over here we'll go to
our css file
and you can see this webkit linear
gradient over here is unknown to us
right so css gradients let us display
smooth transitions between two or more
specified colors so we can do it
radially or linearly
now let's see the difference
and you can spot the difference here in
the output
we have three different colors over here
we have red black and a little bit of
gray in between right so let's move on
to the first container and we'll create
the game area now
now what we have to do is we have to
create the game area
so what we'll do is we'll access the div
tag with ids game
and let's start working on this div tag
and we'll understand it much better
so we will write here
game
and we'll write here next up
height of this container will be let's
say 500 pixels
width
is let's say 400 pixels so guys remember
this height and width we'll need them
later
now the next thing we'll do is we'll
write here
border
and the border will be 1 pixel
solid
black in color fine
and we'll add a background image as well
we'll write a background image
or we'll write a background only
we'll write a url and inside this will
write
fine
save it now and
you can see here we have a container
over here
now it's not working it
says there's no such image present in a
folder so what we'll do is we'll check
it from here
here we are
we have bg2 over here not bg1 so we'll
write here bg2.jpg save it now
and move back to the browser and here
you can see we have an image over here
so it's not quite visible till now
so what we'll do is
we'll write here
background size as
cover fine save it now
and here you can see we have an image
over here now the image looks fine
the next thing we'll do is we'll write
margin
and we'll write here
and the margin will be
one ram
and
auto fine save it now
you can see we have the block in between
now the next thing we'll do is we'll use
the overflow property here and it will
not show the bird going out of the box
so we'll see it in a moment but this
overflow property will do so what we'll
do is we'll write here overflow
is equals
to hidden
save it now
you can see it's not making any
difference as of now but we'll
understand it later
now we have a box over here on the
browser and the game will be played
inside this particular box now we have
to work on the div for the block
so we have to create a block
and that block will move again and again
through the screen with holes present at
a random place every time
fine i hope you guys got it so let's
style the block now what we'll do is
we'll go to a css file and we'll write
here
hash
block fine so this is the id for the
block
now inside this will use
width
as
50 pixels
then we have
height
so the height will be
500 pixels equal to the height of the
whole container
the next thing we'll write here is
background
color and the background color will be
let's say
blue
fine
we will write
position is
relative
and then we'll write here
left
400 pixels
fine
now we know that after saving this piece
of code the block will not be visible
anymore so why is it not visible it's a
question right
it arises in every person's mind save it
and here you can see the block is yet
not visible now what we have to do is we
have to set the left property as 200
let's try to do it 200 once so what
we'll do is we'll write here
200 pixels save it now
and here you can see we have a block or
a screen now the value of left property
is 200 means the block is present
to 200 pixels from the right most corner
of the container
if we write here 400
and save it
you can see we don't have any block here
it means that the block is present right
after this entire container the block
starts here and goes still here it's a
50 pixels wide block and it's not
visible because we have set the left
property as 400
so
now the next thing we have to do is we
need some animation over this box right
or we can say we need some animation
over this block right so what we'll do
is
we'll write here animation
and we'll
write here block we have
to perform it on a block
and the animation time will be two
seconds we'll write here
linear and
it will go to infinite fine
now this animation property will help us
in moving the box again and again after
every two seconds
and the moving points we have to define
here
so for that what we have to do is we
have to write here
at the rate
keyframes
after this we'll write here block
and inside this will write zero percent
left will be
pixels
and at 100 animation
what we'll do is we'll set the left
property as
minus 50 pixels
fine
now you guys might be wondering what we
are doing here but this keyframe here is
a rule that specifies the animation code
and it will help the block move again
and again from 400 pixel in the right to
minus 50 pixels in the left
fine save it
and we'll go to the browser
you can see the box is moving again and
again after every two seconds or two
milliseconds now the next thing we have
to do is with the hole in the block so
we have to put a hole here in the block
and for that we have to access another
div with ids whole
fine so we'll move to a css file and
we'll access that particular
element with ids whole so we'll write
here hash
hole
and inside this will write
height of the hole will be
150 pixels less than that of the block
width will be
50 pixels same as the block
and then we'll write here
background
color
and so let's say the background color is
yellow
this is for
practical purpose you can change it by
yourself
the next thing we'll write here is
position position will be
relative
left will be
400 pixels
and
top will be
minus 5 double zero pixels fine
then we'll write a animation
again we'll write a block
we'll write here two seconds we'll write
a linear
and we'll write here
infinite fine
now this hole will also go with the same
animations as the block
save it
and open the
browser and here you can see the hole is
not properly over the block they are
both at different locations so we can
try to refresh this code and here you
can see
the hole is now present at the top of
the block so here is the hole this
yellow part represents the hole for this
particular game
now it is working totally fine
and this is an empty space to make this
hole randomly come anywhere in the block
we have to do some magic with javascript
for that so we'll do it later in this
video
now if the hole is not placed over the
block in your code don't worry just
refresh the code or we can say just
refresh the home page it will be fine or
if not it will get fine once we go
through the javascript part that's not a
major deal
so let's move on to the bird now what
we'll do is we'll add an image to our
html file for the board
so we'll write here
inside the html file we'll write here
where the ids board will write here img
okay we have
we will write here src is equals to
bird
one dot
png
so let me check if this file exists in a
system or not
so here we are we have bird dot png not
bird one dot png
save it and what we'll do is we'll write
here
alt is
but we'll close this img tag save it
open the browser and you can see the
bird is not visible as of now to make
this image visible we have to work on
the styling so we'll access this image
with the id board
what we'll do is we'll go to the css
file again
and we'll write here
hash
board
the next thing we'll write here is
position
so position will be
fixed
and
top of bird will be
100 pixels
then we have
height
as
50 pixels and
width will also be
50 pixels fine
we'll do the same for image tag as well
so we'll write here
bird
img
and inside this will write
height
as 50 pixels and we'll write a width
fine
is
50 pixels
right
now save it
and if we open the browser now
you can see we have a bird in our game
now we are halfway done in making a game
and we haven't used any javascript until
now right that's quite funny so we'll
use javascript now
let's move on to the javascript part
we'll go to the javascript file first
now first of all we'll access every
element of a javascript file that we can
access
so we'll use the getelementbyid method
to access every element of our html file
what we'll do is we'll write here where
hole so
whole
is the id of whole present in the block
so we can access that div tag here we'll
write here
document dot
get element by id and we'll write here
whole fine
the next thing is we'll write here where
game
is equal to document dot
get element by id the id will be
the id will be game fine
so for now we need to access these two
elements only we'll add some more
elements later and then we'll access
them so for now let's focus on these two
only
next up we need the hole to be placed in
random places in the block every time
for that we need an event listener so
we'll create a function that will change
the location of this hole every time
it will change the location on every
iteration of the block fine
so
we'll write here whole dot
ad event listener
and we'll write here
animation iteration so this is a event
listener and we'll write here a function
name so let's say we are writing here
ran whole fine so this is a function
it's random hole so we'll write here
rain hole now we'll declare this
function as well we'll write you
function renhol and
inside of this function we'll take a
variable
random let's say so this is a variable
we'll write here
minus
math dot
random
so this is a function and we'll
multiply this value by
so this means that it will take any
random value between 0 and 350. fine and
then what we'll do is we'll add 150 to
that particular value and the whole
value will be changed to minus
we'll see it in a moment why we are
doing so so the next thing we'll write
here is
whole dot style dot
left
now whole dot style dot
top
is equals
to random
plus
pixels fine i hope you guys got it till
now
so this math dot random function will
pick any random value between 0 to 350
and 150 will be added to that particular
value because we don't want the value to
go down as low as 10 and the whole will
go out of the containers borders so the
initial value of the whole was let's
check it out
so here we are in a css file so you can
see the initial value of whole
was
minus 500 pixels for top fine
so the new value will be random plus
pixels
the value was 500 because we wanted the
hole at the top of the block and now it
will take any random value and the whole
will be placed according to that
particular random value
so let's save it
open the browser and here you can see
the hole is moving randomly now you can
see it was initially present at the top
now it is at the bottom here
so it will change the location randomly
according to the random number picked up
by the math dot random function so let's
get back to the javascript part now
before we move on to the fall and game
over function let's discuss the game
over scenario first and will finish out
all the necessary html and css tasks for
the game over
so the game will be over when the bird
strikes the pole or either the bird
falls down to the ground
on game over the score will be shown on
the screen with a restart button right
so the score will be counted on the
basis of blocks passed by the boots now
the number of blocks passed will be the
final score
so we'll take a variable score and
increase the value of this score
variable with each random block coming
through
so we'll take a variable score and we'll
write here
where
score
is equals to 0 the initial value will be
0. so let's do the html part wherein
we'll use a div tag to print the result
on the screen
what we'll do is we'll go to the html
file
and here what we'll do is we'll write
here after this particular div tag
we'll write
div
id is equals
to result
and here we have another div tag present
over here now inside this div tag
we'll use
h1 tag and we'll write here
game over
fine
next thing we'll do here is we'll use
p tag with ids
let's say text fine
we'll close the p tag here or the
paragraph tag we can say now we need a
button
so we'll write a button
id is equals to btn
we'll write here on click
is equals to location
dot
reload
and we'll write here
restart
fine
now the html part is done the paragraph
tag with ids text will be used to print
the score on the scoreboard
now this
location.reload method is used to reload
the whole web page on clicking the start
button the entire page will be reloaded
and the game will start again
fine we'll use css to style all of this
game over part
so we'll go to the css file and here's
the css file
now we'll write here
hash
result we are accessing the div tag with
id as a result
so the height will be
let's say 200 pixels for result
and the width
is let's say
500 pixels fine
so
if i show you once again so here is the
block for game over scenario so the
height is 200 pixels and the width is
500 pixels basically we need to create a
card right or we can say a rectangle
so we'll move back to the css file and
we'll write here
background color is
let's say
down
margin will be
five frame or two
so
margin top will be five rep and then it
will do it automatically
then we'll write here
border
so border will be 2 pixels
solid
and the color will be white fine
we'll write here
border radius
so the border radius will be let's say
20 pixels
we want rounded borders
and the display will be
none
fine
the last thing we'll do is we'll write
here text
align
as center it will align the text in the
center
and the next thing we are left with is
the
button fine so we'll write here
hash btn
because the id of button element is btn
so we'll write here
padding
0.5
ram
and 1 ram
fine the border
will be
none
because we don't need any border for
this button
we of course want the button to be round
from the corners so we'll write your
border radius is 11 pixels
background color is
green
color is
white
font size is
1.5 ram
we'll write it text
transform
upper case
we'll write here margin top
one rim
so guys you can see we are using this
ram again and again so i might wonder
that if any one of you knows the exact
definition of this word ram if yes then
do let us know in the comments below and
let's see how many of you guys know the
actual definition of this term
so the last thing we'll do is we'll
write here cursor is equals to pointer
and we are good to go fine the next
thing is
we'll write here
hash
text margin
top will be
1 ram
and
font size will be
2 ram
fine we'll do one more thing
we'll write here
color is
c shell so this will be the color of our
text so we are now totally done with the
html and css part the only thing
remaining now is the javascript part and
we have to work on that only
so just a few more files statements and
all and we are done with the game
now moving back to the javascript part
but before we go there let me just
show you how this works
save it and go to the browser so this is
our game
and you can't see any
game over scenario here right so for
that what we have to do is we have
to go here in result and we have to
comment this
particular statement fine
display has none we have to comment out
this statement save it now
and it's not working
now as well okay here's a mistake in
this div tag
what we did wrong here is
so this was a mistake save it now
and now here you can see we have a card
for game over over here and if you click
on this restart button you can see the
page is reloading again and again
so it's working totally fine we'll move
back to the css file
and we'll
remove this fine
save it now
and let's go back to the javascript part
now we'll access two more html elements
that we just created so what we'll do is
we'll
write here where
result is equals
document.getelementbyid
and the id is
a result fine and then finally we will
write here where text is equals to
document.getelementbyid
and id is
text
fine
so the next thing we'll do is we'll
write here where
jumping
is equals to zero we'll take another
variable for the bird to jump
now we'll need all these elements
further in the video now we have to
create functions for falling and we have
to mention the conditions for game over
as well so what we'll do is we'll write
here after this renault function
we'll write here where fall
is equals to
set interval will set an interval so
we'll write here
function
and
then we have the body of this function
so
the next thing we'll do is we'll write
here where
bird top
is equals to percent
we'll write your window
dot
get computed style
and we'll pass bird here
then we'll write here dot
get
property value and the property value
will be
top
fine
now the next thing we'll do is
we'll write here if
jumping
is equals 2 is equals to 0
the body of if statement will write here
bird dot style
dot top
is equals to bird top
plus
two
after this will
make them in pixels fine
now
we have to mention the time in
milliseconds here so we'll write here 10
and we are good to go so here in this
function we are using the top value
provided to the bird so we have used
these two functions window dot get
computed style and get property value to
get the elements style property with ids
bird and the top value we need will be
passed to the following function the
value of jumping is 0 so the style dot
top will be set to bird top plus 2
pixels
now the initial value was 100 pixels
from the top
and two pixels will be added to the
value after every 10 milliseconds now
save it
and here you can see a bird will fall
eventually fine so what's happening here
is
2 pixels will be added to this value of
top after every 10 milliseconds now
fine
now we have to define those conditions
here wherein we'll check if the bird
touches the ground then game over for
that we have to write inside the same
function only so we'll move back to a
function
and we'll write inside this particular
function only
we'll write here where block
left
we'll take the left value of block
and we'll write here percent window dot
get computed style so we need the
computed style
for block now
and we'll write here dot get
property value
fine
so we'll write here
left because we need the left value
and the value will be stored inside
block left and then we have where
whole top
fine we'll write here percent window dot
get computed style we'll write here
whole and then we'll write here get
property value and we'll write here
top
fine
now what we'll do is we'll write here
where
h top
so this is another variable
so the value of h top will be
plus
whole top
so any value returned to the whole top
variable will be added to 500 and that
value will be assigned to h top variable
fine
now we have to write your conditions so
the conditions will be
if bur top is greater than 450 or block
left
so we've made a mistake here
we have to put one more bracket over
here and then we'll write here block
left
is
less than 50.
and then
we'll write here block left
greater than minus 50
then we have
bert top
is less than h top or
but top
is
greater than h top
plus hundred
fine
i'll explain it to you in a moment
now what we have to do is we have to
write here
result dot style
dot display we have to change this style
to
block now which was done till now so
then we'll write here
text dot
inner text
is equals to
your
finals queries
colon will use rear dollar and then
we'll print the
score here fine now the next thing we'll
do is we'll write here
game
dot style dot
display is equals to
none which was block until now
now the last thing we have to do is we
have to change the value of score to
zero again so that the game will restart
from zero
now let me explain this to you guys
so we have to write here bird top first
not birdie up
so now if bird top is greater than 450
means that the bird is touching the
ground or we can say the bottom part of
the container
now you can get all these values correct
by going through the inspect elements
and i hope you guys already know how to
use it in javascript to get the exact
values in pixels so i want you guys to
check it to cross check it once if it's
fine or not
now if the block left is less than 50
and greater than minus 50 means if the
bird is colloiding with the block or not
and the bird top is less than h stop
means the bird is hitting with the top
of the block or the bottom of the hole
we can see
the last one is for the bird to collide
from the upper part of the block
now in all these cases the result box
will appear and the style of the result
box will be blocked
the paragraph tag with ids text will
show the score here and the game dot
style will change to none
now the game will disappear and the
game over scenario will come forward now
score will be again zero as if the user
wants to restart the game then he can
restart it from zero again
so save it once and let's see if it's
working or not
save it
and go to the browser
close it
okay
you can see it's working totally fine
but it says your final score is dollar
score so we have made a mistake over
here
now what we'll do is we'll go back here
and we'll check
what's wrong here fine okay the mistake
here is of single inverted comma instead
of single inverted comma we have to put
this sign over here
now save it
go back to the browser
restart the game and you can see it's
working totally fine it says your final
score is zero
restart it again and here you can see
it's working totally fine now we are
left with only one thing
and that thing is
quite easy so what we have to do now is
we have to make the bird jump on button
press so we have to create one last
function for this event so what we'll do
is we'll write here after this
window
dot add event listener
will add an event key down
and then we'll write here
hop so hop will be a function
op is basically a synonym for jump as
well
so we'll define this hop function now
we'll write here
function hop and then we have the body
of this function
so jumping
will set to 1
on calling this function and we'll write
here where
bird top
is equals
to
percent will again write here
window dot
get computed style
and the style will get from bird
and the property we want is
top
fine
now i will write here if
top
is greater than six
then we'll write here
bird
dot style
dot
top
minus
fine
okay so we'll write here
is equals to
word
top
minus 60
so we'll put all this inside a bracket
and we'll convert it to
pixels so for that we have to write here
pixels inside double inverted comma
fine
now what we have to do next is
we have to write here
set
timeout
and we have to create
an anonymous function over here
so we'll write here
function and we'll again set the value
of jumping to
0 after every
100 milliseconds fine so every time a
key is pressed the hop function will be
called and the value of jumping will
change to 1. it will again take the
birth top value and check if the value
of birth top is greater than 6
and if yes then subtract 60 from it and
save it inside the top of
the bird then again the bird will try to
go down after every 100 milliseconds but
the bird will also go up by 60 pixels
on each button press right now save it
and our game is ready so we are done
with creating the game now what we'll do
is we'll go to the browser and we'll
restart the game
so here you can see our bird is jumping
and
we can take the bird
from the holes so
here you can see
we have a bird and it's working
fine
so we have to take the word through
these holes so here you can see it says
your final score is zero every time
fine so let's check out for this ones
okay so we have forgot to mention here
score plus plus now save it
go back to the browser
now
we'll play this game again once
so we have to take this bird through
these gaps in between the blocks
see how long it
goes so here you can see it says your
final score is 5 and then again the
value of score is set to 0 after some
time
that's because if the person want to
restart the game then the value of score
will be zero for that restart
now here you guys just saw me playing
this exciting game and i want you guys
to try it it's fun and you'll enjoy the
game more after creating it by yourself
today we'll create a car game in which
we have to save a car from obstacles
coming towards our vehicle
i don't know the exact name for this
game but let me give you an overview of
this game real quick so here is the game
you can see over the screen wherein we
have a red car on the road and we have
to protect this car by moving to the
left or right
all we have to do is to protect this red
car from collision with the blue one
now i know the graphics for these games
are not too much appealing but if you
want to make a high-end graphics game
then javascript is not the only language
you can use
we have to use many different js
libraries and maybe several other
programming languages along with
javascript to achieve this task
so let's focus on these small games for
now and we'll go ahead step by step
now in this particular game if you see
here we have three images one is of red
car the other one is of blue car and a
road behind them right so let's move on
to the programming part directly
and most of the parts will remain the
same like that of flappy birds let's
move on to vs code
so here is our game this is the html
file and then we have a css file and a
javascript file for this game
now what we'll do first is we'll create
a div tag we have to protect a block
right we have to move the container
either to the left or to the right so
for that we have to create div tags so
first of all we'll write here
div we'll take this particular div tag
for the game
and we'll write here another div with
ids
game fine
now we have two div tags over here now
what we'll do first is we'll add images
for
red car and for blue car right so what
we'll do is we'll take two div tags and
we'll write here id
as
blue car
for the blue car
and then we'll write here
img
src the source will be
blue dot png so we have a file named
blue dot png which is actually an image
and what we'll do is we'll write here
alt
so the alternate will be
blue car fine
we'll copy this piece of code and we'll
do the same for red vehicle as well so
instead of blue car we'll name the id as
red car
the image source we have in our computer
is red dot png
and alternate will be
red car fine
now we have added the two cars to our
div tag or we can say to a html file
save it go to the browser so this is our
document you can see here we have a blue
car and we have a red car you can see we
have both images over here but the size
is different the blue car looks big and
the red one is pretty small right not to
worry we'll figure it out in the css
part
so let's do the rest of the html part
here what we'll do is we'll move to our
html file again and
now one thing you might have noticed in
the game here is
on collision we are getting a card for
game over so we have to create this div
tag as well so let's finish the html
part first what we'll do is
we'll write here div again
and this time the id will be
resolved so we are
preparing for the game over part right
now what we'll do is we'll write here h1
heading
so inside h1 will write
game over so let me show you why we are
doing this so if you can see here on
collision we have game over right so
game over we have to write here now what
we'll do is we'll write here
game over like this
the next thing we need is the score so
what we'll do is we'll write here p
so we'll use the paragraph tag the id
will be score
and the score will do in javascript part
now what we have to do is we have to add
the restart button as well so for that
we'll write here button
id is equals to
let's say btn
and we'll use the on click event so on
click we'll write here
location dot
reload
we'll call this function so this is a
built in function in javascript what
this function will do is it will refresh
the whole page fine the game will start
again so we have added another div tag
for the score here we have a heading
game over and a paragraph with ids score
and then we have a button to reload the
web page
now let's style these elements and make
them look like a game so what we'll do
is we'll move to the css file now here's
a css file we'll
first write here some code for the whole
html document so for inside this we'll
define margin
and the default margin will be zero
similarly we'll define padding as well
so the default padding will also be zero
now
the next thing we have to do is we have
to write here some code for the body
fine here what we'll do is we'll use two
colors at a specific angle of 45 degrees
we have already been through the webkit
linear gradient property in the previous
game which is flappy bird so what we'll
do is we'll write here let's take a
background color let's say the
background color is this kind of sky
blue now the next thing we'll do is
we'll take a background image and inside
this will write
webkit linear gradient we have already
been through this in the previous game
so we'll write here 45 degree
this is the angle
and then we'll define two colors here
so our two colors will be
gray
and the next one will also be gray but a
little bit different from this one so
we'll write here 45 percent it will take
45 percent of the screen
and then we'll write here hash so this
is the code for dark grey color and it
will take the rest 55 of the screen fine
save it for now
go to the web browser so you can see
here we have two different colors
present over here in a web browser the
colors are divided at an angle of 45
degree what we can do here is we can
write here
50 50 instead for both the colors
save it now move to the browser and here
you can see
you can clearly spot the difference here
so here you can see these two colors are
different now
we'll leave it here you can do this
thing as you wish so
moving ahead we'll write here min
height will be
800 pixels
fine save it now move to the browser and
here you can see we have a
background color set for this particular
web page
now
so after the body tag we'll do some
styling for the game container so here
you can see we have the ids game for the
first div tag so what we'll do is we'll
write here
game will
will write some properties here we'll
write here height so the height will be
500 pixels
then we'll write here
width the width of the box is let's say
300 pixels
and the border will also define so the
border will be black
and
border will be one pixel thick
solid and black in color fine save it
you can see over here
so we can't see anything for now so
let's style this first completely
what we'll do is we'll write here margin
so the margin will be
one ram
auto
now
right here we'll write background image
so the background image is the one we
already have in a folder the name for
that image is
road1.png
now i will write here background
size so we'll write here
contain to fit this image inside the
container and we'll write here overflow
as
hidden
fine
save it
move to the browser and here you can see
now we have a div tag present over here
we have a container over here and we
have the blue image only for now now
what we'll do next is
we'll style these images as well so
first we'll do the same for
blue car we'll write here
blue car
and inside this will write
height
as 100 pixels
width
will be 130 pixels so there is a
specific reason behind writing this 130
pixel will understand it later
now the background color for this car
will be let's say blue for the blue one
and we'll write here
position
so the position will
be relative
next up we'll write here
top
stop will be
0 pixels so remember the value for these
properties we'll need them later in the
javascript part
now what we'll do next is we'll write
here left as
0 pixels
now next up
we'll write here text align is center
and
animation so this animation we have
already been through it
now what we'll do is we'll write here
move
after one second the animation should be
linear
and
it should be infinite fine
now this animation we have to define but
before that we'll write here blue car
img so
here what we'll do is we'll define the
height of image
we'll write a height as 100 pixels
fine
now save this go to the browser and here
you can see we have a blue car present
at the top left corner of a container
now what we'll do is we'll define the
animation for this particular div tag
right so here is our car present at the
top left corner so what we'll do is
we'll move this box to the middle of the
screen so we have already done it i
guess but there is some mistake
so here you can see we have given space
between one ramp save it now
and here you can see we have a box
present at the center of our screen
now we are good to go next up we'll
define the animation
so we'll write here at the rate
keyframe
and
instead of identifier the identifier we
have here is
move
fine
so inside this will write here
zero percent at zero percent
the top will be
zero fine zero pixels
and at hundred percent the top will be
501 pixels
fine
now one thing to notice here is
the total height of the container is 500
pixels and the animation will go till
501 pixels save it now
move to the browser and here you can see
the car is still not moving
so we have made a mistake here so here's
a mistake we have to write here move
only save it now
and here you can see the animation is
going swiftly now so the car starts from
0 pixel and goes to 501 pixel so it will
happen infinitely because we have
used a infinite inside the animation
property
what we'll do next is we'll do the same
for
red car as well fine so here you can see
we have a red car the id is red car for
this so what we'll do is we'll write
here
hash red car
and we'll start styling this
red car as well the height will remain
the same the height will be
100 pixels
and then we have the width
the width will be 130 pixels for this
car as well
the background color will be
red because the color color is also red
position will be relative for this as
well
the top will be 250 pixels let's say
and the left will be
130 pixels fine
now what we are doing here is we are
taking the
left as 130 pixels why so because what
we want is we want the car to be present
at 130 pixels away from the left corner
of the box so that's why we have written
130 pixels over here inside the left
property
now the next thing we'll write here is
text align and text line will be sent
fine
we'll do the same thing for red car as
well here we'll write here red car
img
we have to write here hash as well
now inside this will define the height
of this image
we'll write here height as 100 pixels
fine
save it now
go to the browser and here you can see
we have a red and blue car over here now
the box seems to be a little bit less
wide for these two cars so what we'll do
is
we'll
write the width here as 390 pixels
so that it will be divided equally in
three parts save it now
and here you can see now this box looks
totally fine we have a red car present
in the center we can move it to the left
and to the right
so we are done with styling these three
images next up we have to style the
result part as well right so here you
can see in this particular game we have
a card over here with
a different background the game over
color is white
and this color is gray i guess the
button color is black and the restart
color is
sky blue fine so we have to keep all
these things in mind we have to style
this box as well so what we'll do is
we'll write here
result
and inside this will write
height height will be
200 pixels for this box
then we'll write here
width
and width will be 400 pixels so we want
a rectangle for this
next up we'll write here background
color
so let's define the rgb value
the rgb value for this particular color
is 231
comma 1 0 5 comma
1 0 5
that's because we want to make the exact
same game so that's why we are using the
rgb values here save it now
move to the browser
and here you can see we have the game
over card over here
and the game over color is black and the
card color is pinkish we can say
now we'll move to a css file we'll write
here
margin and the margin will be
1 ram
auto
next up we'll write here
border radius so we want the box to be a
little bit round from the edges
so for that we'll write here border
radius as 20 pixels
and then we have
font size is
30 pixels for game over
then we'll write here
text align we want to align the text at
the center of this box
game over color will be white fine so
we'll write here white and we are done
with it save it
and here you can see we have a box over
here we have a game over card over here
now what we want is we want to hide this
thing right so for that we have to write
here
display as
none save it now and you can see we
don't have this game over box over here
anymore
now moving back to our css file what
we'll do is
we'll remove this particular statement
for now save it and here's our box again
we'll add this property later so for now
what we'll do is we'll write here
score
now what we have to do is we have to
write here font
size
as
2.2 ram
i hope you guys must have searched for
the ram keyword
now we'll discuss this keyword again in
the next video
so for now we'll write here
color and the color will be
let's say
take any color of your choice
so we'll write here gray
or we can say let's take golden rod i
don't know which color is it but let's
take it once
save it
and you are not getting anything over
here because we haven't defined it yet
so we'll see it later now the last thing
we have to do here is with the button
right so we'll use the button id for
that we'll write here btn
and inside this will write padding so
padding will be 0.5 frame
and
1 ram for
left
now we'll write here
border radius for this button is 20
pixels because the button is a little
bit round at the corners
next up will write here
border is
none we don't need any border for this
particular button then we'll write here
background color
is let's say
black
will write here
the color is
which color we should take let's take
this one
now we'll write here margin
top so let's say the margin top will be
10 pixels
next up we'll write here
cursor
so cursor will be point fine cursor will
change to pointer on taking it over the
restart button
we'll write here
text
transform we want to transform this text
to uppercase
fine save it now move back to the
browser and here you can see we have a
game over here
but this tag is not working for now
so let's see what's wrong here
okay so we have to write here restart
save it now
and here you can see we have a button
over here we have a restart button over
here the button looks a little bit small
so what we have to do is we have to do
some styling change here
we'll take let's say the font size
so we'll write here
font size is let's say 25 pixels
save it now
and here you can see the button is quite
right now
so we are done with it what we'll do is
we'll add the display property here
we'll write here display
none save it
and the box is gone fine
now we are done with the css part as
well now we have to make this game
responsive only that will do with the
help of javascript
so let's move on to the javascript file
first
here's a javascript file now we'll
access all the html elements here in the
javascript file
because we need them so what we'll do is
we'll write here where blue car is
equals to document
dot get element by id so the id for blue
car is
blue car
we'll write here where
red car
document dot get element by id
so the id is red car for the red one
next up
we'll write here where
our result will
get result as well we'll write your
document dot
get element by id and inside this will
write
a result fine we are accessing all the
elements with the help of get element by
id method
now what we'll do is we'll write here
where score
so the score will write your
document.getelementbyid and again we'll
write here score
then we'll write here where
game document dot
get element by id the id for game is
game
fine
we'll take another variable here let's
say the variable name is variable
counter
to count the number of cars passing
through the red one to get the final
score basically so we'll initialize the
value as zero for this counter variable
now the next thing we have to do is to
make the blue car move randomly in three
positions right
for that we'll use math dot random
function again we have used this
function previously in the flappy birds
game
so we'll write here
blue car dot ad event listener
will add an event
so we'll write here
animation iteration so this is a
predefined event listener in javascript
so for this we'll create a function here
we'll write here function
and we'll define the function as well
fine
so we'll take a variable let's say
random
and we'll write here math dot
floor
math dot random
so this is a predefined function in
javascript we'll write here into 3
and right here we'll write
130 fine
why 130 because 130 is the default width
which we have taken in a css file
so
we'll write here
blue car
dot style
dot
left
is equals
to the value of random in
pixels fine
then we'll increase the value of counter
after every car passes through after
every blue car passes through the red
one save it and move to the browser
you can see
the blue car has three positions over
here can either come from the left
right or from the center any random
number from these three numbers will get
multiplied to 130 so we have three
positions only any random position let's
say the position is 1 it means that the
car is present at the left
so that particular number will be
multiplied with 130 and the left value
of the blue car will change to that
particular number
the logic is simple if the number
randomly taken is 2 then the random
value will become 260 in that case and
the blue car will have a distance of 260
pixels from the left side of the
container
so this was the reason behind taking the
width of container as 390.
i hope you guys can relate to it now so
let's move ahead and write the code for
moving the red car as well so you can
see the red car is not moving as of now
will make it move so let's write the
code for that as well
we'll move to a javascript file
and we'll write here
window dot add event listener will add
an event here
we'll write here
key down
and we'll define a function here fine
so we'll take a parameter inside this
function
now what we'll do is we'll
write here if
e dot
key code
is equals to is equals to
then what will happen is
we'll take a variable where
red car left
is equals to
we'll write here power sent
window
dot
get
computed style
will get the computed style of
red car
and we'll write here get
property value fine we'll take the
property value yes we'll take the left
value so we'll write here left
and we'll write here if
red car left
is less than
260 pixels
then
red car
dot style
dot left
will change to red car left
plus
and the value will change to
pixels as well fine
now
we'll write the code for another key as
well so we have to add two keys over
here
what we'll do is
we'll write here if
e dot
key code
is equals to is equals to
this key code over here represents the
left and the right arrow key of our
keyboard so that's why we are using here
key code as 37 and 39
39 is the default key code for the right
arrow key and 37 is for the left arrow
key
so what we'll do here is we'll write
here where red car left
is equals to percent so what we'll do is
we'll copy this from here
and we'll paste it here fine
this will remain the same
now what we'll do is we'll write here if
red car left is greater than 0
then
it will change the
style so we'll write here
this
and here what we'll do is we'll change
the value of red car to red car left
minus 130 pixels so we are moving the
car to the left or to the right fine
now we are done with it
now save it
and move to the browser and now here you
can see we are able to move the red card
to the left or to the right as well fine
now we are good to go so the next thing
we have to do is to write the code for
collision of these two cars or we can
say the function for game over as well
fine
so let's head back to our javascript
file and we'll create another function
over here so what we'll do is we'll take
certain values and pass them through
some conditions if any of the
requirements fail then the game is over
the logic is simple let's implement this
logic so what we'll do is we'll write
here set interval so we'll use the set
interval method
and we'll write here
function
so let's say the function name is
game over will
now define the body of this function
now let's discuss some things what we
need is we need the top property of blue
car we need the left property of blue
car
and then we need the left property of a
red car fine so we'll take three
variables we'll write here
where
blue car top
then we'll take where
blue car left
and then we'll take where red car left
fine
so we have these three variables over
here now what we'll do is we'll write
we'll get these values first so we'll
again use the get computed style
property and the get property value
we'll write here percent and inside this
will write
window dot
get computed style so the computed style
is of the blue car
then we'll write here
get property value we'll write here
top because we need the top value
we'll do the same thing for
blue car left and for
red car left fine so we'll change the
values here
we'll write here left for the blue car
left
and we'll write here
for the
red car
fine
we are good to go we have these three
variables
and we have the properties
right we have the value of these
particular properties
now we'll write here certain conditions
we'll use the if statement again
we'll write here if
blue car left
is equals to
red car left
let's replace this left with a capital l
and we'll write here and then blue card
top
is
greater than
and
blue car top is also less than 450 so we
need the blue car in between 250 and 450
for collision right what we'll do is
we'll write here result dot
style
dot display so we'll change the display
property of a result element will write
here
is equals to
block
now we need a game over card over the
game and we'll also change the display
property of game as well we'll write a
game dot
style dot display
as
none fine we don't want the game for
this now
the next thing we'll do is we'll write
here score so for that we'll write it
score
dot inner html
is equals to
let's say it says
your score is
and we'll write here
dollar we have a variable counter right
we'll print the value of
counter here fine
now there is an error over here you can
see so what we have to do is
we have to put them
inside this
will not use
the double inverted commas we'll use
this instead and you can see the error
over here is gone now
so we are good to go
now after that we'll change the value of
counter to zero again in case the user
wants to restart the game
the value of counter will start from
zero again now we want to call this
function after a certain interval of
time so we'll write here 10
and we are good to
so the set interval method will be
called after 10 milliseconds
now the same thing we did for flappy
birds as well so some conditions here
are almost same and the output is also
the same as we had for flappy birds
now
save it and you can see on the browser
that our game is completely fine now
it's working totally fine so we can play
this game
now let's play it once so here you can
see we can move our red car and the blue
car is coming randomly from any of the
three directions it means that it can
either come from the left or from the
center or from the right fine on
collision you can see it shows that the
game is over and the score is 13. now
when clicking the restart button we can
restart the game the page reloads again
and it's working totally fine now
we have to create this particular game
and we can see that the game is
completely done we can play this game
anytime
and it's fun as well of course
so we can do certain things with the
graphics as well i want you guys to do
that thing and let us know in the
comments below what else can we do to
make this game more appealing to the
user
what is
typescript typescript is object oriented
and strongly type programming language
which is superset of javascript
typescript code is converted to
javascript which can be executed
anywhere javascript is supported in a
browser or node.js and any other
application
hypscript was designed by anders
hegelsberg at microsoft the limitations
of javascript for the development of
large-scale application at the microsoft
and among its external customers led to
the creation of typescript
due to the difficulty of working with
the complicated javascript code there
was demand for custom tooling to make
developing javascript components easier
typescript is javascript with some
additional features
to support a strong interaction with
your editor typescript adds additional
syntax to javascript typescript is a
scripting language that understands
javascript and uses type inference to
provide powerful capabilities without
the need for additional code
why typescript compilation javascript is
an interpreted language there is no need
to compile it as a result it must be run
to ensure that it is genuine if there is
an error that implies you write all the
code to find out an output
as a result you will have to spend hours
looking for the faults in the code so
error checking is provided via the
typescript transpiler if typescript
detects any syntax mistakes it will
compile the code and generate
compilation errors this aids in the
detection of mistakes prior to the
execution of the script
typescript provides an optional type
system for javascript code when a client
doesn't have a value for a parameter he
can pass a null optional arguments are
features of typescript we can declare
some arguments in the function optional
by utilizing optional parameter features
so that the client is not necessary to
supply a value to optional parameters
strong static typing javascript does not
have a powerful static typing system
does the tls typescript comes with an
optional static typing and type
inference system the tls that is a
typescript language service can deduce
the type of variable defined with no
type based on its value
supports object-oriented programming
such as classes interfaces inheritance
and other object-oriented programming
principles are supported by typescript
typescript supports type definitions
existing javascript libraries can use
typescript type definitions
external javascript libraries are
defined in typescript definition files
as a result these libraries can be
included in typescript code
now let us look at the difference
between typescript versus javascript
typescript is an object-oriented
programming language
whereas javascript is a scripting
language
and typescript supports static typing
whereas javascript does not support
static typing
errors can be found and corrected during
compile time in javascript errors can be
found only during the runtime as it is
an interpreted language
there is a concept for es3 es4 es5 and
es6 in typescript whereas no support for
compiling additional es3 es4 es5 or as6
features in javascript
functions can have optional parameters
in typescript whereas this feature is
not possible in javascript
converted into javascript code to be
understandable for browsers in
typescript in javascript this can
directly be used in browsers
in typescript proper build setup is
required for static type definitions no
build setup is required in javascript
now let us look at the features of
typescript
typescript supports other javascript
libraries typescript is a new microsoft
language that is highly typed super set
of javascript with support for object
oriented programming and other current
features like decorators
because browsers and nodes comprehend
javascript typescript compiles to
javascript
typescript is portable typescript is
cross browser cross device and cross
platform it can run in any environment
that supports javascript typescript
unlike its computators does not require
dedicated virtual machine or a specific
runtime environment to run typescript is
superset of javascript
it's a strong syntactical superset of
javascript with the addition of optional
static typing
typescript is a large scale application
development language that transcompiles
to javascript
typescript is static and typescript is
object oriented language
when a client doesn't have a value for a
parameter he can personal optional
arguments are a feature of typescript
when it comes to object-oriented
programming with javascript javascript
shines because of the class keyword it
makes object-oriented programming look
quite similar to programming in other
object-oriented languages like c-sharp
or java
applications of typescript
typescript can be used to develop
javascript applications for both
client-side and server-side execution
typescript can be deployed instead of
javascript language since it adds more
features and gives error directly with
the code
typescript is used for building large
scale application for enterprises
advantages of typescript
highlights error at the compilation time
during the time of
development in typescript it runs on any
browser or javascript engine
typescript has a namespace concept by
defining a module
typescript support strongly typed or
static typing
disadvantages of typescript
typescript takes a long time to compile
the code
typescript does not support abstract
classes
typescript has extra compilation step
for converting typescript into
javascript typescript has an overly
complicated typing system
setting up development environment
firstly we need to go to node.js
official website and install node.js
after installing
go to command prompt and type the
function
node space hyphen v to check if the node
is installed properly
to install typescript
run the command
in pm node package manager install
globally type script in the command
prompt and this will install typescript
so let's jump to the browser and see the
installation of load.js and typescript
then we will go to visual studio and see
the different components like loops
variables data types with examples
so to install node.js come to the
website
nodejs.org here come to the downloads
and from here you can install node.js
node is an open source server-side
execution platform for javascript code
node is commonly used for real-time
applications like chat news feeds and
web push notifications
because it allows for a persistent
connection from browser to the server
node.js is a javascript runtime based on
v8 javascript engine from chrome
node.js is an asynchronous event-driven
javascript runtime for building scalable
network applications
to install for windows click on windows
if you have mac os
click on mac os to install
so i'll click on windows here we go
node.js is getting installed since i
have already installed in my device i'll
cancel it
so once the installation is complete and
you have installed the node.js
just go to command prompt
in the command prompt run the command
node
hyphen v to check if whether the node.js
is installed properly
and here it shows the version of nodejs
installed in our device
so here we can see that node is
installed
properly next we need to install
typescript
to install typescript we need to run the
command npm node package manager install
hyphen g globally typescript
if you run this command the typescript
will be installed
the typescript will be installed
worldwide with this command
this implies that each project you
create on your computer can use
typescript dependencies without having
to reinstall the typescript package
so after running this the typescript
will be installed since i have already
installed will clear this
so after installing typescript to check
if whether the typescript is installed
properly
to check if the compiler is installed
just type dsc typescript compiler space
hyphen version
and here you can see the typescript
compiler of version 4.5.4 is
installed now that we know how to
install node.js and
type script now we will go to visual
studio and
see the
examples
so let us see the different types of
variables available in typescript
for variable declaration typescript
follows the same rules as javascript
variables can be declared with the
commands like
variable
or we have
let
and we have constant
const
so these are the three types of variable
declarations available in typescript
we'll see them one by one
variables can be declared in typescript
using the var keyword just like in
javascript the scoping rules are
identical to those in javascript
for example we can declare a variable
of parameter h
and it is of the type number
which is equal to
say 45 something like this
and similarly we have
let
so let is a ecmascript 6 introduce two
new types of variable declarations in
javascript using the keyword let and
const to solve the issues with variable
declarations
these additional sorts of variable
declarations are also supported by
typescript which is a superset of
javascript
for example we have let's say employee
name
is equal to john
similarly we have
constant constant variables are declared
in the same way as variable and let
variables are constant transforms are
variable into a constant whose value
cannot be changed the same scoping
constraints applied to constant variable
as they do to the let variables
for example we have constant
num
is equal to
something like this
next we will look at the different data
types in typescript
we have different data types like number
string boolean array etc
so number first we'll look at the number
just like javascript typescript supports
number data type
all numbers are stored as floating point
numbers
these numbers can be a decimal
hexadecimal
for example
say let
first
number
one two three
so
let's again
the third number
is equal to this is of the type now we
will write octal
and don't forget to put colon otherwise
it will show an error
let fourth
now we'll declare the number of type
say binary
so typescript supports number data types
like the numbers can be stored in
floating point numbers
or decimal or hexadecimal octal or
binary
so this is basically a number
and this is
hexadecimal
[Music]
this is octal
and this is binary these are the
different number methods in typescript
the method two exponential returns the
exponential notation in string format
two fixed returns the fixed point
notation in string format
to locate string converts a number into
a local specific representation of the
number
two precision returns a string
representation in exponential or fixed
point to be specified precision
tostring returns the string
representation of the number in the
specified base
and value off returns a primitive value
of the number
next we have string then the data type
which we have is string string is an
another primitive data type that is used
to store text data
string values are surrounded by single
quotation marks or double quotation mark
for example
we say declare it let employee
name
string of the type string
is equal to
johnson
so this is of the type string
the different string methods in
typescript are
kept method character at returns the
character at the given index concatenate
returns the combination of two or more
specified strings
index off returns an index of first
occurrence of this specified substring
from a string and minus one if not found
the method replace replaces the matched
substring with a new substring
and the method split splits the string
into substrings and returns an array
two upper case converts all the
characters of the string into upper case
to lower case converts all the
characters of the string into the lower
case
the next type which we have is boolean
boolean values are supported by both
javascript and typescript and stored as
true or false
example for boolean is say let
here note that the boolean with small b
is different from the boolean capital b
so the uppercase boolean is an object
type whereas the lowercase boolean is a
primitive type
it is always recommended to use the
primitive type boolean that is a
lowercase boolean in the code because
while javascript courses an object to
its primitive type the typescript type
system does not the typescript treats it
like in the object type
the another data type is of the type
array
an array is a special type of data type
which can store multiple values of
different data types sequentially using
a special syntax
typescript supports array similar to
javascript there are two ways to declare
an array one is using the square
brackets and the other is using a
generic array type
example
this is one type to declare with the
square brackets
and the other type is to use
the generic array type
both methods produce the same output
arrays can contain elements of any data
types numbers strings or even objects
arrays can be declared and initialized
separately
these are the different array methods in
typescript
we have pop that removes the last
element of the array and returns that
element and push adds the new elements
to the array and returns the new array
length
sort sorts all the elements of the array
and similarly we have concat index of
copy within
fill
shift splice
and shift
includes join
last index of that returns the last
index of the element in an array
similarly we have slice two string
and two locate string similarly we have
tuple
union any word and never as the data
types in typescript
next we'll look at the if statement in
typescript
an if statement can include one or more
expressions which return boolean if the
boolean expression evaluates to true
a set of statements is then executed and
in if else condition an if else
condition includes two blocks
if block and an else block if the if
condition evaluates to true then if
block is executed otherwise the else
block is executed
and we also have elsif
so the elsif statement can be used for
if statement
next we will see loops in typescript
typescript supports for loop the for
loop is used to execute a block of code
a given number of times which is
specified by a condition
so this is the for loop
the first expression is executed before
the for loop starts and the second
expression is the condition for the loop
to execute and the third expression is
executed after the execution of every
code block here in this example i is
equal to 0 declares and initializes a
variable the second condition i is less
than 3 checks whether the value of i is
less than 3 or not if it is less then it
exits the loop
the third statement
increases the value of i by one
this loop will execute the block three
times until the value of i becomes three
now that we have seen loops we'll see
the functions in typescript
functions are the primary blocks of any
program functions are the most important
part
since it is a functional programming
language with functions we can implement
the concepts of oops like classes
objects polymorphism and abstraction
functions ensure that the program is
maintainable and revisible and organized
into readable blocks while typescript
provides a concept of classes and module
functions still are integral part of the
language for example
we have function
sum
so this is the example of function
classes in typescript now let us look at
the classes in typescript
so in object oriented programming
classes are fundamental entities used to
create reusable components
typescript has been primarily a
functional programming language
where inheritance is prototype based
functions are used to build reusable
components
let us see an example for the classes
employee name
so we'll create a class employee
and
provide employee
id
employee name
so the typescript compiler
will convert the class to the javascript
code using the closure
and the constructor
is a special type of method which is
called when creating an object in
typescript the construction method is
always defined with the name constructor
so in this example the employee class
includes a constructor with the
parameter employee id
in the constructor members of the class
can be accessed using this keyword
example this dot employee id
it is not necessary for every class to
have a constructor
first up what is javascript
now javascript is a powerful client-side
scripting language
it is mainly used for enhancing the
interaction of a user with the web page
in other words you can make your web
page more lively and interactive with
the help of this language
javascript is also being used widely in
game development web development server
development and robotics among others
so talking about why javascript is being
used
first up is that it's open source
as discussed earlier it has excellent
user interaction
meaning the scripts are basically
written in html pages and are executed
automatically with embedded javascript
also javascript offers a wide range of
libraries and frameworks some popular
ones are react
angular vue.js among others
and some other key features of
javascript include excellent speed
cross browser compatibility that is
javascript code runs on all browsers
like google chrome
firefox safari you name it
and lastly simple things are done simply
it offers simple semantics allowing a
seamless developer experience
then what exactly is typescript
now typescript is an object oriented
programming language which is a superset
of javascript
it's basically javascript with other
impressive additional features
and all the code written in typescript
gets compiled to javascript ultimately
now let's look at some of the key
features of typescript that make you
want to use it
firstly it's a superset of javascript as
mentioned earlier typescript is a
superset of javascript
now it supports all javascript libraries
and apis
in fact angular which is a javascript
framework
that is used to build single page
applications is completely written in
typescript
now typescript uses object oriented
programming concepts
with the increase in code complexity
javascript had to fulfill the
requirements of object-oriented
programming
hence typescript was introduced to
bridge the gap
typescript helps with quicker code
development thus improving performance
and lastly as mentioned earlier it adds
several additional features to
javascript making coding excessively
easy
now let's look at some of the advantages
of typescript over javascript
typescript always points out the
compilation errors at the time of
development
now because of this at the runtime the
chances of getting errors are very less
however in case of javascript it's an
interpreted language and all errors are
shown during runtime
next typescript supports static typing
this means that all the variables that
are used in your program are basically
known during compile time now since this
feature is
used it leads to better code completion
type checking tooling and refactoring
as mentioned earlier typescript adds a
lot of features to javascript right so
typescript adds features like interfaces
generics namespaces null checking and
access modifiers
and lastly it provides excellent tooling
with intellisense which provides active
hints as the code is typed
moving ahead
i'm sure you must have gathered the
differences between the two languages
however let me just brief them up for
you
firstly typescript is object oriented
language while javascript is a
client-side scripting language
now typescript supports
strongly typed and static typing feature
while javascript does not support
it in case of typescript errors are
highlighted at the time of development
making it easier for codes to run
however
javascript makes sure that it highlights
errors at run time
now typescript code is always converted
to javascript and then run on browsers
while javascript directly runs on
browsers
now typescript supports prototyping
while javascript does not support
prototyping
lastly as mentioned typescript supports
modules generics
namespaces access modifiers etc
while javascript does not support these
features
so lastly which one should you choose
now what are the developers around the
world using
according to google trends
growth in typescript has plateaued in
the last 12 months while javascript
still has a large user base so with that
you can gather that a lot of developers
out there prefer javascript over type
script
but if you wonder which one suits you
better
well if you're an experienced developer
and work on smaller projects then
javascript is ideal
but if you prefer a statically typed
language
and you are working on a new library or
a framework or if you're working in a
big project with multiple developers
then typescript would be a better option
what is typescript generics
typescript generics is a tool for
creating reusable components in
typescript
rather than working with a single data
type it builds a component that can
interact with various data kinds it
enables users to consume these
components while also using their own
kinds
generics ensure that the software is
both adaptable and scalable over time
type safety is provided via generics
without sacrificing performance or
efficiency
the type variable in typescript is used
to denote types and uses generics
generic functions have the same type as
non-generic functions with type
arguments specified first as in function
declarations
why use typescript generics
consider the below code without generics
the identity function is a function that
returns whatever is sent in as a
parameter we could either provide the
identity function with the specific type
or identity function with any type
while the use of any is generic when we
use any the function accepts any kind
for the type of argument as a result
when function returns we lose
information about what the type was the
only information we have is that any
type could be produced if we pass in a
string
we need the means to capture the
argument type in such a way that we can
use it to signify what is been returned
as well we will utilize a type variable
here which is a form of variable that
deals with types rather than values
the identity function now has a type
variable called time this type allows us
to capture the type of data the user
supplies
for example a number or a string so that
we can use it later we are going to
utilize the type as a return type once
more
we can use two methods to invoke generic
identity function after writing it one
method is to pass all the parameters to
the function including the type argument
the other method is to utilize type
argument inference
now let us look at the typescript
generic types
generic functions have the same type
parameters as non-generic functions with
the type parameters listed first as in
the function declarations
we can call the generic type parameter
in the type by whatever name we like as
long as the number of type variables and
how they have utilized match
the generic type can also be written as
a call signature of an object literal
type
typescript generic classes
a generic class resembles a generic
interface in appearance
following the name of class generic
classes contain a generic type parameter
list enclosed in angular brackets
although this is relatively literal use
of the generic number class you will
notice that nothing restricts it to
using only the number type instead we
may have used string or even more
complicated objects
a class type has two sides a static side
and an instant side generic classes are
only generic on the instant side not on
the static side hence static members
can't use the class type parameters
while working with them
although this is relatively literal use
of the generic number class you will
notice that nothing restricts it to
using only the number type
instead we may have used string or even
more complicated objects
putting the type parameter on the class
itself like the interface ensures that
all of the classes property functions
with the same type
typescript generic constraints
typescript generic types allow you to
work with any data type we can however
use constraints to limit it to a
specific types
a type parameter can be declared that is
limited by another type parameter for
instance in this case we would like to
retrieve a property from an object based
on its name we'll put a constraint
between two types to ensure that we are
not obtaining a property that does not
exist on the object
now let us jump into visual studio code
and understand typescript generics more
better so here we are in visual studio
code the prerequisite is we need to
install node.js and we need to install
typescript
so let's get started
let's call the function
function identity
identity function is a function that
returns whatever is sent in as a
parameter we could either provide the
identity function with a specific type
or with any type
so this is the identity function with
specific type so if we had to write the
same
in the identity function with the
specific type so what we'll do
we'll write it with the specific type
so to write it with any type
what we have to do is we'll write any
in place of string
so while the use of n is generic when we
use any the function accepts any kind of
the type of the argument as a result
when the function returns we lose the
information about what that type was the
only information we have is that any
type could have produced if we pass in a
string
so we are passing up the type string
here and maybe we can pass this type as
number as well instead of string
so i can make this function generic by
passing the type any but this will lose
information about what type was passed
so for that we need the means to capture
the argument type in such a way that we
can use it to signify what has been
returned as well so we will utilize a
type variable here which is of the form
variable that deals with the types
rather than the values
so for that we will write the code as
we'll create a function
identity
so here the identity function now has a
type variable called the type
this type allows us to capture the type
of data the user supplies for example a
number or a string so that we can use it
later we are going to utilize a type as
a return type once more so we can use
one of the two methods to invoke the
generic identity function after writing
it
so i have written a few lines of code
with generic type function
so here i have written a few lines of
code in this example the type variable t
is specified with the function in the
angle brackets get array
so the type variable t also is used to
specify the type of the arguments and
then return the value
this means that the data type which will
be specified at the time of a function
call will also be the data type of the
arguments and of the return value
so we call generic function get array
and the pass numbers array the strings
array for example calling the function
as get array number and we have passed
the numbers as 16 and decimal number 2.0
and 55
this will replace t with the number and
so the type of the arguments and the
return value will be the number array in
the same way for get array string we
have passed the values as hello world
the type arguments and the return value
will be a string array so now the
compiler will show an error if you try
to add a string in number array or a
number in string array thus we get the
type checking advantage
so it is not recommended but we can also
call a generic function without
specifying the type variable the
compiler will use the inference to set
the value of t on the function based on
the data type of the argument values
now let us run this code and check
so let us go to the terminal and let us
first run the command
typescript.cmd and the file name type
dot ts
enter
now let us run the file
nodetype.js
and here we go
it's showing the number array has
1.5 to 36 and 400 we have pushed two new
values one for the number array it is
value 400 and for the string array hello
typescript
what is react
react is a javascript library for
creating user interfaces that is
declarative efficient and customizable
react allows to build complicated user
interfaces out of components which are
small independent pieces of code
react was first open sourced in 2013 by
facebook and has since become one of the
most popular libraries in the front-end
world
with frameworks like redux react can
simply be extended to integrate
functionality like routing and state
management patterns
of react
react is an open source library and is
developed by facebook
react apps are fast flexible modular and
scalable
react is powerful javascript libraries
that creates interactive interfaces
popular libraries of react are redux
material design and chest
redux helps manage state in javascript
redux is the most popular of all react
libraries because it easily tracks the
state as the application size grows
react has robust developer community and
variety of libraries
react is declarative and component based
declarative views make the react code
more predictable and easier to debug
and react is component based that is
react letters build encapsulated
components that manage their own state
and compose them to make complex uis
advantages of using typescript with
react
in a react project typescript allows us
to write html code directly typescript
delivers superior intelligence and code
completion for jsx when used with react
javascript xm is abbreviated as jsx
when using ides like visual studio
visual studio code autumn webstorm
eclipse and others typescript comes in
handy this allow better development by
improving autocomplete and snippet
generation
typescript has code that is easy to read
and understand
typescript is statically typed language
the distinction between statically and
dynamically typed programming languages
is when type checking occurs
variables in static language are type
checked
while creating react app complex type
definitions can be defined as interfaces
in typescript this is useful when you
wish to use a complex type in the
application such as an object with
multiple properties
microsoft supports typescript
an open source programming language
millions of developers all over the
world enjoy and use it this implies that
if you get stuck while learning or using
typescript you can easily obtain help
and answers on the community portal
we can integrate typescript into our
existing react projects for this we can
configure the typescript compiler
installing and configuring typescript
and react
before we install typescript we need to
install node.js
go to the node.js official website and
you can install node.js from there once
you install node.js go to the command
prompt and run this command npm install
hifunji typescript
this command is used to install
typescript globally
once you have installed typescript to
check if the typescript is installed
properly run the command tsc typescript
compiler
hyphen v to check the version of the
typescript compiler
next we need to install react
for installing react and creating a
react project
go to the command prompt and run this
command
npx create react app this command will
create a simple folder structure of the
application then install all the
necessary modules and get the project up
and running for you
first of all we need to install node.js
to install node.js go to the official
website of node
nodejs.org
go to the downloads in downloads here
you can
install the node.js if you have windows
if you have mac os
you can install it from here so i have
windows so i'll install windows since i
have already installed so i'll cancel it
so once you have installed node.js then
go to the command prompt
in command prompt we need to install the
typescript to install the typescript run
the command npm that is node package
manager
install
hyphen g
g stands for installing globally
and then typescript
what this command does is it installs
the typescript globally
run this command once you run this
command the typescript will be installed
since i have already installed
typescript i'll cancel it so after you
have installed typescript to check if
the typescript is installed properly run
the command typescript compiler tsc
space
hyphen hyphen b and press enter
and this will show the version
and this will show the version of the
typescript installed so i have version
4.5.4 installed in my device
so after this to get started with the
project after successful installation of
node.js and typescript
let us create a new folder to create a
new folder type the command make
directory
and we'll name the folder as
typescript
hyphen
react
so enter
so we have created the new folder next
we'll change the directory to the folder
which we created so cd
to
ts react
so after this we need to initiate the
project
so to initiate the project we will run
the command npm
init
it is asking for package name
just
click enter
and
then is this ok click s
after this what we need to do is create
react app
so to create react app run the command
npx
space create
reactor
and enter
so this command will create a simple
folder structure for your application
and then install all the necessary
modules and get your project up and
running for you
so this is the project folder which i
have already created
i have the vs code folder wherein i have
settings.json files in this then i have
installed all the node modules
then i have the source folder
in source folder i have app.tsx file
counter.esx
index.html declarations index.tx file
to install webpack just run the command
npm install web pack
space webpack hyphen cli indic terminal
this will install the web pack
so i'll show you a simple hello world or
hello everyone program
so in the app.tsx
we'll just type hello everyone
and we'll give the color as green and
align the text at the center input since
we have imported the counter
file so in counter file
we'll just type in subscribe to simply
learn with text align in the center and
with the color red
so we'll just run this
here we go we have the message hello
everyone and subscribe to simply
what is node.js
node.js is an open source server-side
execution platform for javascript code
node.js is a javascript runtime based on
the version 8 javascript engine from
chrome
node is an asynchronous event-driven
javascript runtime for building scalable
network applications
although node.js is excellent for
developing server-side apps it lacks
several current features such as type
checking it can also be difficult to
manage a node.js code base
node is commonly used for real time
applications like chat
news feeds and web push notifications
because it allows for a persistent
connection from the browser to the
server
the current coding method such as static
typing and type checking are supported
by typescript
it's designed to create complex and high
level applications that's why having
typescript as a primary language for
supporting node.js capabilities would be
idle
this also allows us to develop server
side apps with rigorous type checking
avoiding run type errors and other
typescript benefits while maximizing
node.js capabilities
now let us see how to set up the
development environment for typescript
with node.js
the prerequisites are we need to have
typescript installed in our device and
node.js
to install node.js go to the official
website
go to nodejs.org and go to downloads
so here you can see
we have node.js for different browsers
for windows mac os
and source code
so go to windows if you have windows pc
and click on install
click on windows and here you can see it
is getting installed since i have
already installed in my device i'll
cancel it
so once you have installed go to the
command prompt
and just enter
node.v to check if node is installed
properly
so here you can see the node is
installed in my
system
to install typescript just run the
command npm
node package manager
install
globally
typescript
run this command and typescript will be
installed since i have already installed
typescript in my device
we'll cancel this so once you have
installed typescript to check if
typescript is installed or not to see if
the compiler is installed just run the
command
typescript compiler space
version
here you can see it will show the
version of typescript compiler
so now that we have installed both
typescript and
node.js
let's see
our example program for typescript with
node.js
so let's jump into visual studio code
one more prerequisite is we need to have
visual studio code installed
so create a new folder and create a new
project
so we'll run an example program we'll
create a function
we'll write a program to add two numbers
so sum
number one
comma number two
will return number one and number two
console.log
we'll call the function sum
and we'll provide the arguments
so we'll provide the value
9 comma
so let's save
and run this program
first we'll run
typescript.cmd
type.ts command
then
we'll hit that
then we'll run node and the file name
here you can see
it's showing the value showing the
output as fourteen nine plus five the
sum of nine plus five is forty so we'll
delete this
and
write another program
to show a hello message or a welcome
message
so we'll create a function
we'll name the function as welcome
and will return
that user
to
we'll call the function
welcome
and pass
so here we go we'll save this and check
whether we have an error
so here we go showing welcome to simply
learn
what is express.js
express.js is a node.js web application
framework that is free and open source
it is used to quickly and easily design
and create web apps web applications are
applications that can be run through a
web browser because express.js simply
requires javascript
programmers and developers may create
web applications and apis with little
effort
tj holloway chook created express which
is now maintained by node.js and several
open source contributors
to construct our applications express
provides a simple interface it gives us
the resources we need to create our app
it's adaptable because there are a lot
more modules on npm that can be directly
integrated into express
let us look at some of the features of
express.js
server-side development is made easier
with express it's possible to create
single page multi-page and hybrid web
apps with express.js
express enables middlewares to respond
to http request to be configured
middleware is primarily responsible for
the orderly structure of express js
various functions
express js has a comprehensive routing
mechanism that uses urls to maintain the
state of a web page
it establishes a routing table that is
used to carry out various operations
based on the http method and url
express.js has templating engines that
enable developers to create dynamic
content for web pages by creating html
templates on the server
express js simplifies debugging by
offering a debugging mechanism that can
pinpoint a particular area of the web
application that is causing problems
advantages of express.js
express.js makes developing node.js web
applications quickly and easily
express.js is simple to set up and
personalize
it allows to define application routes
using http methods and urls
express.js includes a number of
middleware modules that can be used to
execute additional request and responses
activities
it is simple to interface with a variety
of template engines including
jade vash and ejs
it allows us to specify middleware for
handling errors
express is used to make a rest api
server and it's simple to provide your
application static files and resources
databases such as mongodb redis and
mysql are simple to connect to
express.js
now let us look at the demo on
typescript express
the prerequisites are we need to have an
editor may be visual studio code then we
need to have node.js installed and a
package manager installed such as npm or
yarn
so we'll jump into visual studio code
here i have created a new folder
named express typescript then we will go
to the terminal
next we'll run the command
npx
type script
hyphen init will initialize typescript
next to initialize the node.js
application will run the command
yarn
in it
once we have initialized the node.js
application you just need to click enter
just click enter
and we have successfully saved the
package.json file
next we need to
make a new directory
we'll make a new directory source
next we'll install the touch cli
globally
with the command npm install
touch
clip
so after installing this we'll run the
command
touch
source inside the source folder we'll
create the file app.ts
so here you can see we have created the
fileapp.ts inside the source folder
so after this we will install typescript
to install typescript run the command
yarn
add
type script
node
dev
type script
hyphen d
so after this we need to install express
to install express run the command
yarn
space add express
next we need to add node modules and
express modules for that run the command
yarn
add
type slash node
type slash express
so let us now go to the app.ts file
and
run the code
we will close this
so i'll copy paste a few lines of code
here
wherein i have imported express
module
the constant app creates an express
function
and we have dot json
and we have returning a message hello
world
so we'll save this and we are running it
on the local host with port number 3000
so we'll save this
and
run it
to run it we'll just
run the command e on
dev
so application is listening at the
local host 3000 so we'll copy this
and open in the browser
here we go it's showing the message
hello world
similarly we have routing
like this example with app.get and
app.host the app object provides a
collection of functions that attach
callbacks to http request made to
defined destinations
and other http methods such as post put
patch and delete can also have callbacks
attached to them
the router object is another approach to
setup routing
you can call the get put and patch and
delete methods on a router object just
like you do on a app object
and similarly we have
request and response
so the request object holds information
about http request including headers
query strings and parameters
when when an http request is received
the response object represents the http
response that the application provides
similarly for response the send method
is the most significant one it sends the
http response to the client so that it
can be received
the function accepts a variety of data
kinds including strings objects arrays
and buffers
the send method finishes the response
process with data but you can
alternatively use the end function to
end it without any data
the request and response objects are
accessible to middleware function
it can join the request response cycle
at any point
a third argument that middleware
receives is the next function
the get callback which processes the
http get request that we wrote in this
example
is an example of middleware
it's highly unique middleware that only
works in one situation they can also
carry out more general duties
we will first look at type assertions
type assertion is similar to type cast
in other languages but it does not do
any additional verification or
restructuring
it has no effect on runtime and is only
used by the compiler typescript expects
that you the programmer have completed
the necessary and specific checks
so there are two types of assertions
one is the as syntax
and the other one is the angle bracket
syntax both versions are identical
choosing one over the other is primarily
a matter of preference however only as
style assertions are allowed when
combining typescript with jsx
type aliases type aliases give type a
new name
type aliases are similar to interfaces
in that they can be used to name
primitives unions tuples and any other
kind that you would have to define by
hand otherwise
aliasing doesn't truly create a new type
instead it gives the type a new name
aliasing a primitive isn't very useful
however it can be used for documentation
purposes
type aliases like interfaces can be
general all we have to do is add type
parameters and utilize them on the right
side of the alias declaration
this is the syntax for type aliases
type generics
type generics is a tool for creating
reusable components in typescript
rather than working with a single data
type it builds a component that can
interact with various data kinds it
enables users to consume these
components while also using their kinds
generics ensure that the software is
both adaptable and scalable over time
consider the below code without generics
the identity function is a function that
returns whatever is sent in as a
parameter you could either provide the
identity function with a specific type
or the identity function with any type
while the use of any is generic when you
use any the function accepts any kind
for the type of argument
as a result when the function returns
you lose the information about what the
type was
the only information you have is that
any type could be produced if you pass a
string
so for that we need the means to capture
the argument type in such a way that we
can use it to signify what is being
returned as well
we will utilize a type variable here
which is a form of variable that deals
with the types rather than values
the identity function now has a type
variable called type this type allows
you to capture the type of data the user
supplies
for example
a number or a string so that you can use
it later you are going to utilize type
as the return type once more
next we look at the in operator
the in operator serves as a type
narrowing expression
the true branch narrows to types that
have an optional or required property n
and the false branch narrows through the
types that have an optional or missing
property n
for a n in x expression
where n is a string literal or a string
literal type and x is the union type
below is an example code for inoperator
null and undefined are two special types
in typescript that have the values null
and undefined respectively they are not
particularly useful much like void
null and undefined are subclasses of all
other types by default that means you
can give things like number null and
undefined values
when the strict null checks flag is set
however null and undefined can also be
assigned to unknown any and the
respective types
this helps you avoid a lot of frequent
errors you can use them as union type
string null and undefined if you want to
send in either a string null or a
undefined
next we have index types
using index types we can get the
compiler to check code that utilizes
dynamic property
names by using index types a typical
javascript pattern for example is to
select a subset of an object's property
we may build and use this function in
typescript using the index type query
and index access operators
let us jump into visual studio code and
understand index types more better
so consider this code as an example for
index types here key of t the index type
query operator
for any type t p of t is the union of
non-public property names of t
and t of k the indexed axis operator is
the second operator the type syntax
reflects the expression syntax in this
case
and t of k can be like index type
queries be used in generic environment
which is where its truly potential can
be seen
all we have to do now is make sure that
the type variable k extends p of t
in get property o
t and property name k so that means of
property name the compiler will initiate
the actual type of the key after you
return t of k result
therefore the return type of get
property will change depending on which
property you request
index signature
index signature interact with the key of
and the t of k
the type of an index signature argument
must be either a string or a number
if your type has a string index
signature key of t will be a string or a
number
because in javascript you can access an
object property using either a string or
number
t of string is simply the index
signature type
below is the syntax for index signature
if you have a type with number index
signature e of t will just be a number
map types
taking an existing type and making each
of its property optional is a typical
undertaking because this happens
frequently enough in javascript
typescript has a new feature called map
types that allows you to define new
types based on existing ones
the new types turn each property in the
old type in the same way in a map type
for example make all the properties
optional or the read-only type
it's important to note that this syntax
refers to the type rather than a member
you can use an intersection type to add
more members
this is the simplest map type and its
parts the syntax is similar to the index
signature with a 4 in the middle
there are three sections in total
the type variable k is assigned to each
property one by one
the little union of string the names of
the properties to iterate over a stored
in case
and third one the properties type is the
result
next we have conditional types
based on the condition given as a type
relationship test
a conditional type chooses one of the
two alternative types when t can be
assigned to u the type is x and when it
can't the type is y
because the condition depends on one or
more type variable a conditional type t
extends u
so x is to y and is either resolved to x
or y or delayed
whether to resolve to x or y or to
differ when t or u contains type
variables is determined by whether the
type system has enough information to
conclude that t is always assignable to
you
in conditional types we also have
distributive conditional type
that is a conditional type in which the
check type is bait type parameter
during instantiation distributive
conditional types are automatically
distributed over union types
supporting libraries from node modules
typescript includes a series of
declaration files to guarantee that
typescript and javascript support works
well right out of the box
and typescript includes a series of
declaration files however there are two
drawbacks to using these declaration
files with typescript
one drawback is since while upgrading
typescript
we must also deal with the changes of
typescript built-in declaration files
which can be difficult when the dom apis
change so regularly
and the other
drawback is that customizing these files
to meet your needs and the demands of
project dependencies is difficult
so to overcome this a new feature like
types
was added that allow us to override the
specific built-in library
then we can update typescript and lock
the file in dependency management
ensuring that it utilizes the same
version of dom types
as a result we can update the types on
our own schedule
then with
then with typescript 4.5
we can update typescript and log file in
our dependency management
await type and promise improvements
the awaited type is the new utility
introduced in typescript
this type is intended to represent
activities such as await in async
functions and the then method on
promises
notably the way they recursively unwrap
existing api such as javascript built-in
like
all promise dot race and others can
benefit from awaited time
in fact some of promise not all
inference concerns provided as
foundation for awaited promise that all
combines certain traits with awaited to
produce far superior inference results
tail recursion elimination on
conditional types
when typescript identifies potential
infinite recursion or any type expansion
that take a long time and damage your
editor experience
it often leak fails
as a result typescript includes
heuristics to ensure that it doesn't run
off the tracks while deconstructing an
indefinitely deep type or working with
types that provide a lot of intermediate
results
let's jump into visual studio code and
look at an example
the trim left type for example removes
spaces from the beginning of string like
time when provided a string type with
space at the beginning trim left returns
the reminder of the string to the user
this type is handy but it will throw an
error if a string contains more than 50
leading spaces
this is problematic because these types
are frequently used in modeling
operations on strings
such as parsers for url routers
to make matters worse a more powerful
type useful generates more type
installations resulting in even
additional input length restrictions
trim left is written in such a way that
it is tail recursive on one branch when
it calls itself again it returns a
result instantly and does nothing with
it
because these types don't require any
intermediate outcomes they can be
constructed more rapidly and without
activating many of typescript built-in
type recursion heuristics
next we have assert signatures
the asset signature features allow us to
construct functions that operate as type
cards as a side effect
instead of returning their boolean
result explicitly
consider a below example
after a search ring typescript has no
way of knowing if you have guaranteed
the type of input
to prevent this most people just make
the parameter input string which is fine
but it also moves the type checking
problem somewhere and in circumstances
where you just want to fail hard having
this option is beneficial
if this function ever returns typescript
can filter the type of input to string
exactly like it would be if it were
inside an if block with a type card
to make this safe the asset function
must either give an error or not return
at all if the asset
assession isn't true
and lastly we have recursive type
aliases
the ability to recursively reference
type aliases has been limited
the reason for which
is because each type aliases must be
capable of substituting itself for
whatever it aliases
because this isn't always possible the
compiler rejects some recursive aliases
interfaces can be recursive but their
expressiveness is limited and type
aliases cannot that involves combining
the two creating a type alias and
extracting the type's recursive
operations into interfaces
interfaces can be recursive but their
expressiveness is limited and type
aliases cannot
that involves combining the two creating
a type alias and extracting the types
recursive portions into interfaces it's
effective
by establishing an interface users may
write what was practically the same code
typescript has no trouble working with
the interfaces and other object types
because they introduce a level of
indirection
and their whole structure does not need
to be eagerly built up
however many found the workaround of
introducing the interface to be
inconvenient
and there was nothing wrong with the old
version of value or array that used
array directly in concepts
this is the chat application where we
have two users
and from the user one will send the
message hello
and the user two will receive it and
from the user to we'll send the message
hi
and the user one receives it so this is
basically a simple chat application how
we can create
how are you
so this is basically a simple chat
application which we can create
so in this video we will learn to make
this chat application from the scratch
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell icon so you never
miss an update from simply learn watch
the video till the end so that you don't
miss out anything so without wasting any
further time let's get started first of
all we will create a new folder
so i'll go to my d drive and i'll create
a new folder
i'll name the folder as
chat app
so after creating this new folder
so we will go to visual studio code open
a new window in new window we will open
the folder which we created
we created the folder in d drive
we will first create the user interface
to create the user interface for that we
need to create a new file called
index.html
so i've successfully created the new
file index.html
so we'll change the title
we'll name the title as io chat
next after this will open the link
before this we should know what is cdn
a cdn is a network of servers that
distributes content from an origin
server throughout the world by catching
content close to where each end user is
accessing the internet via a web enabled
device
the content they request is first stored
on the origin server and is then
replicated and stored elsewhere as
needed
so we will use bootstrap cdn and query
cdn for our project
so we'll use the link tag
the link element allows authors to link
the document to other resources
we will click on the link
so for this to get the bootstrap cdn
we will
go to the browser and type bootstrap cdn
so we'll copy this link
for bootstrap cdn
and will paste it here
bootstrap is the most popular css
framework for developing responsive and
mobile first websites
bootstrap 5 is the newest version of
bootstrap and bootstrap is free open
source css framework directed at
responsive mobile first front-end web
development
it contains css and javascript based on
design templates for forms buttons
navigation and other interface
components
after this next we need jquery cdn
next we will
next we'll get the jquery cdn and write
it in the script tags
so i'll select script
the script element allows authors to
include dynamic script and data blocks
in the documents
the element does not represent content
for the user
to get the cdn
for jquery
go to the browser
and just type
jquery cdn
and open the first link
click on uncompressed
and
copy this
go back to the visual studio code
and
paste it
so after this is done
jquery is fast small and feature with
javascript library it makes things like
html document transversal and
manipulation event handling animation
and ajax much simpler with an easy to
use api
that works across a multitude of browser
with the combination of versatility and
extensibility
so after this we'll take one more script
tag
and this time we will include
the
we'll take one more script tag inside
this script tag we will enter the client
site socket dot io web api that will
work inside the browser you can go to
the browser and search socket dot io you
will get all the information related to
socket.io
so just go and type
here
just go to the browser and type
socket.io and on this website socket.io
you have all the documentation and all
the details to get started with
dot io so you can go through the socket
dot io here
so in the script tags
i'll write source
just type socket
or typo slash
socket dot io dot js
so after this
we'll create a new div tag
so the div element has no special
meaning at all it represents its
children it can be used with the class
language and title attributes to markup
semantics common to a group of
consecutive elements
so inside this div will create a new
class
new class container
so class is basically a space separated
list of classes of the element classes
allow css and javascript to select and
access specific elements via the class
selector or functions like the method
document get elements by class name
so after this
we will create another div
class
row
inside this will create one more diff
class
this scholar medium for this class is
used when the device size is medium or
greater than 768 pixel and the maximum
width of the container is 720 pixel and
you want the width equal to four columns
that is when we use this function column
medium four
next we'll create another div
class
well
so after this will provide the heading
h3
the h3 element represents a section
heading
so in this will provide the heading as
online users
you can change the headings whatever you
want to but i'll keep it as online users
so after this will create an unordered
list
this class
list group
an id
so after this we'll create one more div
in this div class
will provide column medium
of size 8.
this column medium 8 starts for large
column
then we'll create a div another div
class chat
where id
is equal to chat
then i'll create a form
this form element represents a
collection of form associated elements
some of which can represent editable
values that can be submitted into a
server or processing
perform id
is equal
to for message form
this will create a diff class
form group
next we'll create the label
so label element represents a caption in
a user interface the caption can be
associated with specific form control
known as label elements label controlled
either using for attribute or by putting
the form control inside the label
element itself
so use the label element inside that
will write enter message
next we'll create a text area
use the label text area
so inside text area will create a class
form control
and
id
message
so text area element represents a
multi-line plain text edit control for
the elements raw value the contents of
the control represent the controls
default value
after the text area
will
just
right
then we will create an input element
input element of
will
assign a type submit
class
button
value
send message
in double quotes
so this input basically it represents a
type data field usually with a form
control to allow the user to edit the
data
so we have finished with the user
interface we'll just save this
and run it in the browser
right click and open with live server
so here we go
we have created the html
but
we we will now create assign few css
elements
we just need the margin top
for the body so we'll assign that
so we'll create styles element
the style element allows authors to
embed style information in their
documents the style element is one of
the several inputs to the styling
processing model the element does not
represent content for the user
so in the style
we'll just write this body
and will assign margin top
30 pixel
save this and we'll go to the browser
and just refresh
so till now we have created the user
interface
we'll just go to the browser and run
this user interface
just right click and click on open with
live server
now we will create a new file called
server.js
and will go to the terminal
in terminal we will run two commands
first of all we need to install
socket.typo for that we'll run npm
and there is one prerequisite we need to
have node.js installed in our device
so then run the command node package
manager npm
install
socket.typo
socket.io is a library that enables
real-time bi-directional and even-based
communication between the browser and
the server
it consists of a node.js server and a
javascript client library for the
browser
after installing socket.io then we need
to install express
for that run the command npm install
express
express is a minimal and flexible
node.js web application framework that
provides a robust set of features for
web and mobile applications
after installing socket.typeon express
you will get these two files
packet.json file
and package
log.json
next go to the server.js
wherein i will paste few lines of code
in the line 1 creates an express
application the express function is a
top level function exported by the
express module
then we have const listen
and then we require and socket dot io
then we we have created a variable app
express method then we have created and
variable server
so this server
that is we use the module http
so it creates a module http to use the
http server and client we must require
http the http interfaces in node.js are
designed to support many features of the
protocol which have been traditionally
difficult to use in particular large
possible chunk encoded messages the
interface is careful to never buffer
entire request or responses so the user
is able to stream data
then we have another variable io where
we require socket dot io server
and similarly we are listening in the
port 3000
so in port 3000 it starts a server
listening for connection
a net dot server can be an tcp or an ipc
server depending on what it listens to
do
then we have app.get
here the request is declared but its
value is never read we have request and
response
then we are routing it on the local host
so in this line we are transferring the
file at the given path so automatically
sets the content type response header
field the callback is invoked when the
transfer is complete or when an error
occurs
be sure to check request response sent
if you wish to attempt responding as the
header and some data may be already been
transferred
here we are connecting the client to the
server and here we add plug details to
the customer array and here we are
checking the current connections
and then we disconnect from the server
using the disconnect function
next we delete the plug details and
the again we show the current
connections
here
on the socket dot on we send messages
function data and then we console.log
the data then we emit the new messages
so then we have written console.log
server is listening
so now we will run this code and check
if the server is listening
now we will check if the server is
listening for that will run the command
node
server
and here we go server is listening
now
we will just go and
run the local host 3000 on the browser
go to the
new tab and just run localhost 3000
and here we go
it's running and when we come back to
the code
we can see it shows one socket connected
so again if we go and open it in a new
browser
and just run the local host
and go back to the code it will show two
sockets connected
so we are almost done we just have a
small part left out we'll go to
index.html
and here
we'll just scroll down
and above body we'll just paste few
lines of code
so here basically we are just creating a
function to get data form
so we'll get message form
and we'll we are creating variables
message and we are creating variables
chat
so basically in this line we will know
form between click event handle
and
then we will prevent default from
submission
next in this line we will trap data for
text box and call server
then we will create clear
then we will clear the form text box
then we'll console.log submitted
so our program is finished
now we'll just run and check the code
so we'll save this code
go to the browser
refresh it
so i have the two browsers i have opened
it in two separate window we'll just
check if the application is working so
we'll send the message hi
and here we go we have received the
message so we can say hello
so the chat application is working
successfully
we'll first look at beginner level
interview questions
what is typescript
typescript is an object oriented and
strongly typed programming language
which is a superset of javascript
typescript was designed by anders
hegelsberg at microsoft the limitations
of javascript for developing large-scale
applications at microsoft and among its
external customers led to the creation
of typescript
because of the difficulty of working
with complicated javascript code there
was a demand for custom tooling to make
developing javascript components easier
typescript code is converted to
javascript which can be executed
anywhere javascript is supported in the
browser or nodejs or any other
application
typescript is javascript with some
additional features to support a more
robust interaction with your editor
typescript adds additional syntax to
javascript typescript is a scripting
language that understands javascript and
uses type inference to provide powerful
capabilities without additional code
explain the features of typescript
typescript supports other javascript
libraries
typescript is a new microsoft language
that is highly typed superset of
javascript with support for object
oriented programming and other current
features like decorators
because browsers and nodejs comprehend
javascript typescript compiles
javascript
typescript is portable typescript is
cross browser cross device and cross
platform it can run in any environment
that supports javascript
typescript unlike its competitors does
not require a dedicated virtual machine
or a specific runtime environment to run
typescript is superset of javascript it
is strongly syntactical that superset of
javascript with the addition of optional
static typing typescript is a
large-scale application development
language that transcompiles to
javascript existing javascript programs
are also valid typescript programs
because typescript is a superset of
javascript
typescript is static
when a client doesn't have a value for a
parameter he can pass null optional
arguments are a feature of typescript
you can declare some arguments in the
function optional by utilizing optional
parameter features so that the client is
not necessary to supply a value to
optional parameters
object oriented language when it comes
to object oriented programming with
javascript typescript shines
because of the class keyword it makes
object oriented programming look quite
similar to programming in other object
oriented languages like c-sharp or java
what are export and import keywords in
typescript
import keyword is used to export
declaration example export star from
module and the export keyword is used to
export any variable function and type
aliases below is the example for import
keyword and export keyword
can typescript be used for the backend
typescript can be generally used for
backend applications by using node.js
and having additional safety that the
language brings
how to declare a variable in typescript
let and const are the two methods to
declare variables variable names can
contain alphabets and numeric digits
they cannot contain spaces and special
characters except the underscore and the
dollar sign variable names cannot begin
with a digit so is the example code
where we have declared a variable with
let method and we have declared a
variable inside a function
list the applications of typescript
script can be used to develop javascript
applications for both client-side and
server-side execution
typescript can be deployed instead of
javascript language since it adds more
features and gives error directly with
the code typescript is used for building
large scale applications for enterprises
how can a base constructor be called
from a child class
a base class constructor can be called
from child class using the super method
as shown in the example
what are getters and setters
getters and sectors intercept access to
a member of the object
they give us a way of having finer grain
control over how a member access each
objects a getter method starts with the
keyword get
and the setter method starts with the
keyword set
what is the purpose of
tsconfig.json file
tsconfig.json file is a json format file
in which we can specify different
options to tell the compiler how to
compile a given project this file in the
directory indicates that the directory
is the typescript project root
list the advantages of typescript
typescript highlights errors at the
compilation time during the time of
development
any browser or javascript engine can run
typescript
it has a namespace concept by defining a
module typescript supports strongly
typed or static typing typescript has
the advantages of being tightly typed or
allowing static typing
it may confirm type correctness at the
compile time because of static typing
what are rest parameters in typescript
when the number of parameters that a
function will receive is not known or
can vary we can use rest parameters
we can pass zero or more arguments to
the rest parameters the compiler will
create an array of arguments with the
rest parameter name
how to compile typescript with visual
studio code
visual studio code includes typescript
language support but does not include
the typescript compiler we need to
install the typescript compiler either
globally or in your workspace to
transpile typescript source code to
javascript the easiest way to install
typescript is through node package
manager
the node.js package manager if you have
npm installed you can install typescript
globally on your computer by using this
command npm install hyphen g type script
we can test the installed typescript by
checking the version or help for this
run the command tsc hyphen hyphen
version
list access modifier supported by
typescript typescript supports three
access modifiers
protected
private and public in protected all
class members can access them but the
instance cannot but in private it's only
accessible by members whereas in public
it is accessible by members child
classes and instance of the class
list the disadvantages of typescript the
typescript takes a long time to compile
the code typescript does not support
abstract classes
an extra compilation step for converting
typescript into javascript typescript
has overly complicated typing system
how to debug a typescript file
to debug a typescript file a dot js
source map file is needed to debug the
file
compile the dot ts file with the source
map flag for generating source map file
use the command
type script tsc space hyphen source map
file dot ts source mapping url is equal
to file.js.map
how can we convert a string to a number
with typescript in typescript conversion
from a string to a number can be done
using the following commands parse int
method
and we have parsefload method
and number method
explain type aliases
type aliases give a type a new name type
aliases are similar to interfaces in
that they can be used to name primitives
unions tuples and any other kinds that
you would have to define by hand
otherwise
alyasing doesn't truly create a new type
instead it gives that type a new name
alyasinga primitive isn't very useful
however it can be used for documentation
purposes type aliases like interfaces
can be in general
all we have to do is add type parameters
and utilize them on the right side of
alias declaration below is the syntax
for type aliases
what are nullable types in typescript
null and undefined are the two special
types in typescript that have the values
null and undefined respectively they are
not particularly useful much like void
null and undefined are subclasses of all
other types by default
that means you can give things like
number null and undefined values
when the strict null checks flag is said
however null and undefined can only be
assigned to unknown
any and their respective types the one
exception being that undefined is also
assignable to want this helps to avoid a
lot of frequent errors you can use the
union type string null undefined if you
want to send in either a string null or
undefined
what is in operator in typescript
the in operator serves as a type
narrowing expression
the true branch narrows to types that
have been an optional or required
property n
and the false branch narrows to the
types that have an optional or missing
properties in for a n in x expression as
shown in the example below where n is a
string literal or string literal type
and x is a union type explain index
types in
typescript using index types we can get
the compiler to check code that utilizes
the dynamic property names a typical
javascript pattern for example is to
select a subset of an object properties
we may build and use this function in
typescript using the index type query
and indexed access operators
in this example key of t the index type
query operator for any type t key of t
is the union of non-public property
names of t and t of k the indexed access
operator is the second operator the type
syntax reflects the expression syntax in
this case t of k can be like index type
queries be used in generic environment
which is where it's truly potentially
seen all you have to do now is make sure
that the type variable k extends to k of
t
what are map types
typescript has a feature called map
types that allow you to define new types
based on the existing ones the new type
turns each property into the old type in
the same way in a map type
it's important to note that this syntax
refers to a type rather than a member
you can use an intersection type to add
more numbers as you can see in the
example it is the simplest map type and
its parts are type keys and type flags
where syntax is similar to the index
signatures
with 4 in the middle there are three
sections in total
the type variable k is assigned to each
property one by one
and the literal union of strings the
name of properties to iterate over the
stored in case
and properties type as a result
what is meant by contextual typing
when there is a type on one side of the
equation but not on the other the
typescript compiler finds out the form
we can omit typing on the right side as
typescript can work it out automatically
this increases the amount of work needed
to type code
distinguish between typescript and
javascript typescript is an object
oriented programming language whereas
javascript is a scripting language
typescript supports static typing
javascript does not support static
typing
in typescript error can be found and
corrected during a compile time in
javascript errors can be found only
during runtime as it is an interpreted
language
there is support for
es3 es4 5 and 6 in typescript
whereas in javascript no support for
compiling
in typescript functions can have
optional parameters whereas in
javascript this is not possible
in typescript converted into javascript
code
to be understandable for browsers
javascript can be directly used in
browsers
typescript has proper build setup note
package manager is required for static
type definitions no build setup is
required in javascript
what is jsx
jsx is an xml like syntax that can be
embed it is intended to be turned into
legitimate javascript though the
semantics of that transformation will
vary depending on the implementation
typescript allows you to embed jsx type
verify it and compile it to javascript
immediately jsx needs to be translated
into a valid typescript we use the jsx
file with the dot tsx extension
define static typing
static typing refers to a compiler
having variables parameters and object
members that are recognizable at the
compilation type this helps in detecting
early errors static typing as is an
important concept
static typing is when the compiler
enforces that the values use the same
type here's an example
what is meant by type inference
when you don't specify an explicit type
for variable typescript can infer it
type inference is the term for this this
is normally done during the declaration
when the variables or parameters are
initialized
typescript recognizes that the variable
foo is a string even if we don't mention
string as a type
here is an example
how to create objects in typescript
objects are collection of keys and
values that resemble a dictionary the
keys must be one of a kind resemble rs
and are sometimes referred to as
associate arrays
an object type in typescript refers to
any value with properties it can be
defined simply by specifying the
properties and the kinds of these
properties
as an example
explain different data types in
typescript
number both integer and floating point
numbers are represented by the data type
number
boolean has true and false values
string it is used to denote a string of
characters
void is usually applied to function
return types
null it's used when an object isn't
worth anything
undefined indicates the value assigned
to an uninitialized variable
any any type of value can be assigned to
a variable if declared with any data
type
what are the benefits of using
typescript
compilation javascript is an interpreted
language thus there is no need to
compile it as a result it must be run to
ensure authenticity if there is an error
you write all the code only to find no
output as a result you will have to
spend hours looking for faults in the
code
error checking is provided via the
typescript transpiler if typescript
detects any syntax mistakes it will
compile the code and generate
compilation error this aids in detecting
errors before the execution of the
script
the next benefit is it provides an
optional type system for javascript code
when a client doesn't have a value for a
parameter he can pass null
optional arguments are a feature of
typescript
you can declare some optional arguments
in the function by utilizing optional
parameter features so the decline does
not need to supply a value to optional
parameters
strong static typing
javascript does not have a powerful
static typing system
through the tls typescript comes with an
optional static typing and type
inference system the tls can deduce the
type of variable defined with node type
based on its value
typescript supports object oriented
programming typescript support classes
interfaces inheritance and other object
oriented programming principles
typescript supports type definition
existing javascript libraries can use
typescript type definitions
external javascript libraries are
defined in typescript definition files
as a result it can include these
libraries in typescript code
how to install typescript
typescript is a javascript programming
language for use in application
typescript exchange javascript with
optional types that support tools for
large scale javascript application in
any browser or any host on any other
operating system to install typescript
globally with node package manager which
means you can run the typescript command
from anywhere in your terminal to
install the latest stable version of
typescript you just need to run the
command npm install hyphen g space type
script this will install the latest
version of typescript
what are decorators
a decorator is a type of declaration
that can be used to decorate the class
declaration method accessor property or
argument
decorators take the form expression
where expression must evaluate to a
function
that will be called with information
about the decorated declaration when it
is called at runtime
what are mixins
combining simpler particle classes is a
popular approach of constructing classes
from reusable components for languages
like scala you may be familiar with the
concept of mixins or characteristics
to extend a base class the design relies
on generics and class inheritance the
finest mix in support
in typescript is provided through the
class expression pattern
explain classes in typescript
classes are not supported in javascript
es5 or earlier this feature
the typescript inherits from es6
a class is a collection of items with
similar characteristics fields methods
constructor blocks
nested classes and interfaces are all
included in the classes
below is the syntax to declare a class
in terms of oops a class is a template
for producing objects
what is the namespace and how to declare
it
the namespace is used to group
functionalities logically to enable a
single or group of link functionalities
the namespace can include interfaces
classes functions and variables
the namespace keyword followed by the
namespace name can be used to construct
a namespace curly brackets can be used
to define all interfaces classes and
other objects
below is the syntax for namespace
explain the components of typescript
internally the typescript language is
separated into three layers each of this
layer is further subdivided into
language compiler and language services
language it is written in typescript and
includes typescript language components
it includes syntax keywords and type
annotations
compiler the typescript compiler
converts typescript programs into
javascript code it also converts our
typescript code to javascript code
parsing and type checking it
it provides information that allows
editors and other tools to deliver
greater assistance capabilities like
automated refactoring and intelligence
it adds a layer of abstraction to the
core compiler pipeline
what are the recent advancements in
typescript
typescript 4.2 has been released and it
includes more flexible type annotations
tougher checks and additional
configuration choices and a few breaking
changes
rest arguments can now be placed
anywhere in triple type in type error
messages type aliases are no longer
enlarged resulting in a better developer
experience
typescript 4.2 brings the language one
step closer to its aim of accurately
typing javascript at any size anywhere
javascript is used
describe as syntax in typescript
the as is an additional syntax in
typescript for type assertion it was
introduced as the original syntax
conflicted with jsx
while using jsx with typescript only as
style assertions can be used
define lambda function
typescript provides shorthand syntax for
defining function expressions a lambda
function is an anonymous function
without a name
below is an example for lambda function
what are conditional types in typescript
based on a condition given as a type
relationship test a conditional type
chooses one of the two alternative types
when t can be assigned to you the type
is x and when t can't the type is y
because the condition depends on one or
more type variables a conditional type t
extends to u
x is to y and is either resolved to x or
y or delayed whether to resolve to x or
y or to differ when t or u contains type
variables is determined by whether the
type systems has enough information to
conclude that t is always assignable to
you
what is an interface with reference to
typescript
the interface defines the syntax for
classes to follow a class implementing
an interface implements all its members
it can be referenced but not
instantiated typescript compiler uses an
interface for type checking
what is a declare keyword in typescript
as javascript does not have typescript
declaration to use it in the typescript
file without any compilation error
declare keyword is used the keyword is
used for ambient methods and
declarations to define a variable that
exists elsewhere
now we will look at advanced level
interview questions
what are object oriented principles
supported by typescript
all object-oriented principles
encapsulation inheritance polymorphism
and obstruction are supported by
typescript
encapsulation is a major component of
object-oriented programming language and
its method of structuring code so that
each block of code has its own set of
access points for external code
polymorphism occurs when many class
inherit from the same parent and
override the same functionality
each of those kit classes is now
responsible for implementing a property
or method but they may do so it on their
own unique way
inheritance
typescript makes creating an object
model and inheritance chain a breeze to
construct classes
simply use the standard class keyword
abstraction is a method of modeling
objects in a system that separates the
responsibilities of the classes or type
from the code that inherits it
explain index signatures in typescript
index signatures interact with the key
off and t of k
the type of an index signature argument
must be either a string or a number
if your type has a string index
signature
key of table will be a string
or a number because in javascript we can
access an object property using either
string or numbers and t of string is
simply the index signatures type
the index signature consists of the
index name and its type in square
bracket
followed by colon and the value type
what are assert signatures
asset signature features allows us to
construct functions that operate as type
guards as a side effect instead of
returning their boolean result
explicitly
after a search string typescript has no
way of knowing if you have guaranteed
the type of input to prevent this most
people just make the parameter input
string which is fine
but it also moves the type of checking
problem somewhere and in circumstances
where you just want to fail hard having
the option is beneficial
what is type assertion explain its types
a type assertion is similar to a type
cast in other languages but it does not
do any additional data verification or
restructuring it has no effect on
runtime and is only used by the compiler
there are two types of assertions
one is the as syntax other is the angle
bracket syntax
below is the example for asyntex and
angle bracket syntax
explain how typescript files can be
supported from node modules
typescript includes a series of
declaration files however there are two
drawbacks to using this declaration
files with typescript
one is while upgrading typescript we
must deal with changes to typescript's
built-in declaration files
and the other is customizing these files
to meet the needs and the demands of
project dependencies is difficult
a new feature like at the rate types was
added that allows to override the
specific built-in library then we can
update typescript and the log file in
dependency management ensuring that it
utilizes the same version of the dom
types as a result we can update the
types on our own schedule
explain the typescript generics
typescript generics is a tool for
creating reusable components in
typescript it builds a component that
can interact with various data kinds it
enables users to consume these
components while also using their own
kinds
the identity function now has a type
variable called type
this type allows us to capture the type
of data the user supplies for example a
number or a string so that we can use it
later we are going to utilize type as
the return type once more below is the
syntax for typescript generics
is recursive type aliases
the ability to recursively reference
type aliases has always been eliminated
the reason for this is because each type
aliases must be capable of substituting
itself for whatever it aliases
interfaces can be recursive but their
expressiveness is limited and type
aliases cannot
that involves combining the two creating
a type aliases and extracting the type's
recursive portions into interfaces it's
effective
typescript has no trouble working with
the interfaces and the other object
types because they introduce a level of
indirection and their whole structure
does not need to be eagerly built up
explain tail recursion elimination on
conditional types
when typescript identifies infinite
recursion or any type expansions that
take a long time and damage your editor
experience
as a result typescript includes
heuristics to ensure that it doesn't run
off the tracks while working with types
that provide a lot of intermediate
results
the trim left type removes spaces from
the beginning of string like type when
provided a string type with a space at
the beginning trim left returns a
reminder of the string to the user
advance type script removes tail
recursion from conditional types it can
prevent intermediary instantiations as
one branch of conditional type is merely
another conditional type
explain the awaited type and promise
improvements this type is intended to
represent activities such as await in
async functions and the dot then method
on promises notably the way they
recursively unwrap promises
existing apis such as javascript
built-ins like promise.all promise.race
and others can benefit from the awaited
type in fact some of promise dot all's
inference concerns provided as
foundation for awaited
promise.all combine certain traits with
the awaited to produce far superior
inference results
so with that we have reached the end of
this video thank you so much for being
here keep learning and stay tuned to
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you